Hello, beautiful nerds. A few weeks ago, I had the honor of being a guest on one of the best podcasts of all time. I've listened to every episode of Patreon Supporter. It's been a genuine comfort and companion to me for quite a while. It's called Blank Check with Griffin and David. It's a movie podcast that dives into director's filmography. I showed up during the Sam Ramy series, specifically examining his 1995 masterpiece,
大家好，美丽的书白痴们。几个星期前，我有幸作为嘉宾参加了史上最棒的播客之一。我听过《Patreon支持者》的每一集。在很长一段时间里，它一直是我的真正慰藉和伴侣。这个播客叫《格里芬和大卫的空头支票》（Blank Check with Griffin and David）。这是一个深入探讨导演电影作品的电影播客。我是在山姆·雷米（Sam Raimi）系列节目中登场的，具体探讨的是他1995年的杰作——
The Quick and the Dead. I'm such a fan of this podcast, and I had such a great time. And so I just thought I'd share this thing I love as a bonus episode with you. Just a warning, there are 78 curse words in this episode. So, and since it's their show, we decided to leave them as is.
《致命快感》（The Quick and the Dead）。我是这个播客的超级粉丝，那次经历非常棒。所以我想把这个我喜欢的东西作为特别节目分享给你们。警告一下，这一集里有78个脏话。而且既然这是他们的节目，我们决定保持原样。你们已经被警告过了。好吧，好好享受吧。所以，既然这是他们的节目，我们决定保持原样。你们已经被警告过了。好吧，好好享受吧。我他妈太快了。我可以在破晓时分醒来，抢劫两家银行、一列火车和一辆驿马车，在300英尺外射中一只鸭子屁股上的尾羽，录制一个三小时的播客，然后依然能在你醒来睡在我身边之前回到床上。
You've been warned. Okay, enjoy. So, instances there show, we decided to weave them as is. You've been warned. Okay, enjoy. I'm so damn fast. I can wake up at the crack of dawn, rob two banks, a train, and a stage coach shoot the tail feathers off a duck's ass at 300 feet, record a three-hour podcast and still be back in bed before you wake up next to me. That's pretty good. Thank you. I was trying to figure out which one to replace with podcasts.
这挺好的。谢谢。我一直在琢磨到底该用哪个词来替代播客。这就好像是把这个词直接加进去。直接扔进去。没错。这让吹牛显得更厉害了。对，完全是这样。我觉得那是一个还算不错的年轻小李子，对吧？我觉得挺好的。它有点那种……这就是那种韵律，吹牛。对，完全是这样。我觉得那是一个还算不错的年轻小李子，对吧？我觉得挺好的。它有点那种……这就是那种韵律，对吧？对。有一种《泰坦尼克号》和《罗密欧与朱丽叶》的……
And that was like just ask the list. Just throw it in. Exactly. It makes it even more impressive, the brag. Yeah, totally. Yeah. I thought that was an okay young Leo, right? I thought it was pretty good. It kind of had that. It's the rhythm of, brag. Yeah, totally. Yeah. I thought that was an okay young Leo, right? I thought it was pretty good. It kind of had that. It's the rhythm of, right? Yeah. The ring of Titanic and Romeo and
朱丽叶的感觉，好吧，其实不太像《罗密欧与朱丽叶》。但就是那种带点狂妄自大的气质。我不知道该怎么形容它。有趣的是，从成年到童年，小李子发生了多大的变化，却又保持了多少不变。有趣的是，从成年到童年，小李子发生了多大的变化，却又保持了多少不变。你知道的，我的意思是，当你看到《泰坦尼克号》和《罗密欧与朱丽叶》时，就在这之后，对吧？就在这之后。那时候他就像个年轻小伙子了，对吧？他已经成了万人迷。
Juliet that, well, not Romeo and Juliet, so much. But like that kind of like swaggery quality. I don't know how to describe it. It's funny how different and how much he is still the same It's funny how different and how much he is still the same from adult Leo to child Leo. You know, like this is, I'd say when you get to Titanic and Romeo and Juliet, right after this, right? Right after. That's when he's like a young man, right? He's become like a heartthrob.
这或许是他最后一次表演中还能让人觉得他还是个孩子。他演的就是个孩子。你觉得呢？他演的就是个孩子。表演中还能让人觉得他还是个孩子。他演的就是个孩子。你觉得呢？他演的就是个孩子。对，绝对是的。他在电影里感觉就像个男孩。是的，而且他大概只有八英寸宽。
This is maybe the last performance where he still feels like a kid. He's literally playing the kid. What do you feel like? He is playing the kid performance where he still feels like a kid. He's literally playing the kid. What do you feel like? He is playing the kid. Right, absolutely. He feels like a boy in this movie. Yeah, and he's about eight inches wide.
他非常小巧。他非常小巧。是的，他很娇小。他太小巧、太精致了。我觉得关于小李子的讨论中，有很大一部分其实都在探讨他拍完《泰坦尼克号》之后疯狂转型的时期，当时他的态度是：我需要人们不再觉得我是个乳臭未干的男孩，对吧？比如他极力摆脱那种蓬松的头发，不再显得那么迷人、
He's very little. He's very little. He's quite petite, yes. He's so little and delicate. And I feel like I think so much of the narrative around Leo was like his whole post Titanic square sazy jump was like, I need people to stop thinking of me as boyish, right? Like he went so out of his way to stop being floppy haired, stop being sort of like charming
轻浮以及诸如此类的事情。但你依然能看到许多极其相似的习惯动作和小把戏，甚至在他今天扮演那些最冷酷硬汉的角色时也是如此。没错，确实如此，但当时确实有那种特质，而且很适合他。显而易见，在这部电影以及《泰坦尼克号》里，早期这些表演中有一种带点叛逆、自我感觉极佳的特质，非常适合这种风格，这里简直是完美选角。对，对。他可能就像不管怎样，
and light and all that sort of stuff. But you still see so many kind of similar mannerisms and tricks, even in how he plays his most hard boiled people today. Yes, you do, but there was that, and it suits him. Yes. Obviously, in this, an intitantical thing, there's that sort of punky, I think I'm so special quality to these early performances that totally suits, like it's perfect casting here. Right, right. That he is maybe like whatever,
完全坚信自己就是个电影明星，而你当时的反应是：好吧，小李子，你现在还算不上电影明星，但现在看起来就很诡异了，因为他确实是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。我懂。看这部电影最迷人的地方之一就是看着所有的家庭媒体发行版。我甚至能想象他们在流媒体网站、租赁平台或其他地方使用的宣传图，
fully convinced that he's a movie star when you're like, well, you're not a movie star yet Leo, but now it's weird because he is a Leonardo DiCaprio. I know. It is one of the most fascinating things about watching this movie is like all the home media releases. And I imagine even just like the graphics they use on streaming sites and rentals or whatever
基本上是他们四个人享有同等署名权，对吧？比如莎朗·斯通、吉恩·哈克曼、罗素·克劳、莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。然后你看了这部电影的开头，上面写着：莎朗·斯通、吉恩·哈克曼、《致命快感》、罗素·克劳，名字、名字、名字、名字、名字、名字、名字、名字、名字、名字、名字、莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，他们被放在最后。是的，我知道，我知道这里有个核心四人组，但这就像是这俩家伙在这部电影之后立刻成了你能想象到的最大牌的电影明星。
are sort of like the four of them at equal billing, right? Like Stone, Hackman, Crow DiCaprio. And then you watch the opening of this movie and it's like Stone hack man quick in the dead Russell Crowe names names names names names names names names names names names and Leonardo de caprio and they are the end yeah, I know I know there's a central quartet, but it's like the two guys immediately become the biggest fucking movie stars imaginable right after this movie.
而吉恩·哈克曼在退休前大概还有六年的资深老戏骨时光。至于莎朗·斯通，我认为这也是导致好莱坞过早轻视她的电影之一。是的。尽管这也是……难道这不是她获得奥斯卡提名的那一年吗？是吗？因为《赌城风云》（Casino）是95年的，对吧？是的，《赌城风云》是95年的。
And Hank Hackman has like six more years of being elder statesman before he retires. And Sharon Stone, this is one of the movies that I think causes Hollywood's sort of disregard her prematurely. Yes. Although, this is also, is this not her Oscar nomination year? Is it? Because Casino is 95, isn't it? Yes, Casino is 95.
但我的意思是，我觉得你是对的，这……我的意思是，接下来的几部电影我们可以待会儿聊聊斯通。未来几年里，我想这才是真正给她作为电影明星的棺材钉上最后一颗钉子的时候，不过这部电影的表现确实低于预期，请继续。我觉得这是她的空头支票，因为她真的是个制片人。她就像是……她正在崛起。这正是我的观点。对，对。比雷米的还要强。从“空头支票”的角度来看，雷米的电影作品非常令人困惑。这让人有些担忧。但她用自己的支票雇用了雷米。
But I mean, I think you're right that this is I mean I mean the there's a couple movies coming we can talk stone in a minute There's a few years coming up that I guess is the true nail in the coffin for her as a movie star But this will be definitely under perform go ahead. I think it's her blank check like she's real producer She's like she's coming up. That is my exact point. Yeah. Yeah. More than Ramy's. Ramy's is very confusing filmography for blank check purposes. This is for some concern. But she used a check to hire Ramy. Someone people thought of only for doing sort of junky, sci-fi, horror sort of pulp beef stuff. I don't think they would have been quick, no pun intended,
一个人们只认为他会拍那种垃圾、科幻、恐怖以及低俗纸浆电影的人。我想大家当初绝对不会想到去雇他来拍这个，双关语可不是故意要用的。她用自己的支票请来了克劳，她用自己的支票请来了迪卡普里奥。千真万确。对，没错，但是……对吧，完全如此。这真的是她的主意。她让索尼买下版权给她拍。大卫，我觉得你说得对，像《赌城风云》感觉就像是一个加冕时刻，意思是：好吧，我们要尊重你是一位严肃的女演员，但也请你现在就滚开。《赌城风云》的提名里有一种奇怪的贬低，我发现人们总是说：好吧，马丁·斯科塞斯从她身上挖掘出了一次出色的表演。对。
to hire him for this. She used her check for Crow, she used her check for de Caprio. Literally. Yeah, no, but like, right, exactly. This was really her thing. Got Sony to buy it for her. I do think you're right, David, that like casino feels like a coronation moment of like fine. We're going to respect you as a serious actress, but also now can you go away. There was a weird dismissal in the Casino nomination I find where people are like, okay, Scorsese got a good performance out of her. Yeah.
所以在拍完这部电影的第二年，让我们直接切入正题吧。我得把这段内容放进去。我知道我们得选择我们的节目和嘉宾。这是由格里芬和大卫主持的《空头支票》。我是格里芬。我是大卫。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。等等，等一下。
So the year after this, let's just dive right in. I have to give this piece of it. I know we have to choose the show in our guest. This blank check with Griffin and David. I'm Griffin. I'm David. And I'm Roman Mars. Now, wait a second.
你不能这么做。好吧，我知道我应该在被介绍之前说话，但我只是想在被介绍之前先介绍一下我自己。这是你在本节目中绝对不能做的事情。这其实太绝了。没错。你可以在被介绍之前说话，并且你可以提出一个好观点，
You can't do that. Well, I know I was supposed to speak before I'm introduced, but I wanted to introduce myself before I was introduced. That's the one that you can't do on this show. That is brilliant, actually. Yes. You can speak before you're introduced, and you can make a good point,
而你在被介绍之前就已经做到了。但是……你不能在自己被介绍之前先介绍自己。好吧，我可不按你们的规矩办事。不，听着，你是……你的播客，绝对是传奇。我想你想怎么做就怎么做吧。难道罗曼一进入Zoom聊天室的那一瞬间，大卫不觉得我的声音听起来很糟糕吗？就像……但其实并没有。
which you did before you introduced. But you you can introduce yourself before you've been introduced. Well, I don't play it by your rules. No, look, you're your your podcast, the legend. I guess you could do what you want. Do you not immediately the second room and came on the Zoom, David feel like my voice sucks. Like the. But it wasn't.
但其实并没有。
I didn't even have. Griff, I didn't even have the, you know, I, the window in the front of my it I didn't even have Griff I didn't even have the you know I the window in the front of my I didn't have window open right I just heard the voice so right I just heard hello and I mean I can't even do it. I was like what the you know yes it really feels like I'm like a high school basketball player and like you know an NBA guy just walked in the locker room and I feel like, oh, I see. I feel like I'm the kid and fucking hackmonger just walk.
我甚至没有……格里夫，我甚至没有那个，你知道的，我，我正面的窗户，我甚至没有，格里夫，我甚至没有那个，你知道的，我，我正面的窗户，我甚至没有开窗户，对吧？我只是听到了声音，所以，对吧，我只是听到了一声“你好”，我的意思是，我甚至都无法模仿。我当时想，什么鬼，你知道的，是的，这真的让我想起，我感觉自己像个高中篮球球员，而你知道的，一个NBA球星突然走进了更衣室，我觉得，哦，我明白了。我觉得我就是个小屁孩，而他妈的黑客恶霸刚走进来。
Yeah. Well, that makes the Roman sound scary in me. No, look, Griff, I want to say something about Sharon Stone right away. I want to say that it's a podcast about filmography, director's about massive success early on in the careers and giving a series of blank checks and make whatever crazy passion projects they want and sometimes those checks clear
好吧。这让罗曼听起来很吓人。不，听着，格里夫，我想立刻说点关于莎朗·斯通的事。我想说的是，这是一个关于电影制片厂、导演的播客，关于他们职业生涯早期的巨大成功，并获得了一连串的空白支票去拍摄他们想要的任何疯狂的激情项目，有时这些支票能够兑现
and sometimes they bounce, pew, pew, baby. I shoot out, I couldn't think of a good, whatever. It's a mini series on the films of Sam Raimi. It's called Podcast Me to Hell. Today we're talking about his 1995 Western, the quick and the dead, which I think a lot of people don't know exist and I think a lot of people who know what exist don't realize it's a Sam Raimi movie,
有时它们会跳票，砰，砰，宝贝。我脱口而出，我想不出什么好词，随便啦。这是一个关于萨姆·雷米电影的迷你剧。它叫《与我共赴地狱》播客。今天我们讨论的是他1995年的西部片《致命快感》，我觉得很多人都不知道它的存在，而那些知道它存在的人又往往没意识到这是一部萨姆·雷米的电影，
which is bizarre because it is so much a same-ray movie. It is. And it should be called the Slaps and it's great. I don't know. Yeah, sorry. It's so good. The rules and it fucks. Yeah, exactly. But listen, speaking on Sharon Stone. Our guest today is Roman Mars of 99% of visible. He already introduced himself. Obviously Sharon Stone's early career is busting out of hit genre films like Turtle Reeng haul and then basic instinct and then sliver. Right. Like these are these are where she's making her name. This year she's got the quick and the dead, which we will talk
这很诡异，因为它带有太多的萨姆·雷米风格了。确实如此。它其实应该叫《耳光侠》，而且它棒极了。我不知道。好吧，抱歉。它太棒了。规则明确而且带劲。是的，完全同意。但是听着，说到莎朗·斯通。我们今天的嘉宾是来自《99%无形》的罗曼·马尔斯。他刚刚已经自我介绍过了。很显然，莎朗·斯通的早期职业生涯是通过热门类型片大红大紫的，比如《全面回忆》，然后是《本能》，接着是《银色猎物》。没错。这些都是她声名鹊起之作。今年她有《致命快感》，我们今天会聊到它，
about today, but did not do that well at the box office. And she has Casino, which is an undeniable hit, maybe a little bit of a come down from like Goodfellas or what, but still she gets an Oscar nomination. I was going to say a hit, it's certainly a win for her, but it was like, oh, Scorsese made lesser Goodfellas was the tag at the time. Now in the next year in 1996, Griffin, she had two films. She had Diabali, the remake of Late Day Abali, Big Flop, which is a Big Flop, and she had a Bruce Barisford movie
但它在票房上表现不佳。她还有《赌城风云》，这是一部毋庸置疑的热门电影，虽然比起《好家伙》可能稍微有点逊色，但她依然获得了奥斯卡提名。我本想说这是一部热门片，对她来说绝对是一场胜利，但当时的评价是“马丁·斯科塞斯拍了一部逊色版的《好家伙》”。到了第二年，即1996年，格里夫，她有两部电影。她有《旧爱新欢》，也就是对老电影《孽海狂花》的翻拍，结果彻底扑街了，这是一部大烂片；她还有一部由布鲁斯·贝里斯福德执导的电影
called Last Dance that was also a Big Flop, right? Now, this is what I want to get to. There's a Golden Raspberry Award that existed for quite a while until from 1992 to 1999 called for the Golden Raspberry for worst new star. And she was nominated for it that year. And I saw that and I was like, what do you mean new star?
叫《最后的舞者》，这也是一部大烂片，对吧？好了，这正是我要说的主题。金酸莓奖从1992年到1999年曾设立过一个奖项叫“最差新星”。她那一年就被提名了。我看到时就想，你什么意思，新星？
Sharon Stone, like she'd been around for a while. Like what were they thinking? So let me read you, Griffin, the five nominees for worst news star for the 1996 Golden Raspberry's, okay? Okay. Okay. These are rude to be quick. Yeah. No, I'm classic. I'm crazy. My self-uru-ness. Okay. Okay, here we go. All right. One and Ben's going to be mad. Beavis and Butthead and in Beavis and Butthead do America. What the fuck? Pretty rude. That's so undeserved, first of all. They're so cool.
莎朗·斯通，她已经在圈子里混了一段时间了好吗？他们在想什么呢？所以让我读给你听，格里夫，1996年金酸莓奖最差新星的五位提名者，好吗？好的。好的。这些可真够刻薄的。好吧。不，我很经典。我很疯狂。我的自恋。好吧。好吧，我们开始吧。好的，第一个会让本气疯的：底比斯和大头蛋，在《瘪四与大头蛋横扫美利坚》里。什么鬼？太刻薄了吧。首先这太不公平了。他们太酷了。
Whoever made this list is such a nerd who doesn't like font. And the movie was a hit. Totally. And it was a hit. And it was a hit. And it was good as hell. Okay, so the next two are the guy from fucking unsolved mysteries, right?
做这份名单的人简直是个不解风情书呆子。而且这部电影大获成功。完全是的。而且它很火。而且它非常好看。好吧，接下来的两个人是来自他妈的《未解之谜》的那家伙，对吧？
Yeah, the voice unsolved mysteries. Sure. What is his name? I don't know, but that's a huge get as far as I'm concerned. That's your argument against a particular razzi. No, I think there are other arguments. I don't think you have other stuff. That's great too. It's got Hank Hill in it, I think there are other arguments. I don't think you have. There's other stuff that's great too. It's got Hank Hill in it. I mean, come on. Don't get me started. Robert Stack was it Robert Stack at the time. Yeah. Okay. Okay. So some other nominees.
对，就是《未解之谜》里的那个声音。没错。他叫什么名字？我不知道，但就我而言，这绝对是一个超级大咖。这就是你反对某个酸莓奖的理由吗？不，我认为还有其他理由。我不认为你还有别的料。那个也很棒。里面还有汉克·希尔，我觉得还有其他理由。我不认为你没有。还有其他很棒的东西。里面还有汉克·希尔。我是说，拜托。别让我滔滔不绝了。罗伯特·斯塔克，当时是罗伯特·斯塔克吧。是的。好吧。好吧。所以还有其他提名。
Ellen DeGeneres was nominated for Mr. Wrong. I guess that was sort of the first Ellen Star vehicle. It didn't work out, right? That's that's more. Pretty disastrous movie. Yeah. Next, there's a group nomination for four friends cast members. So they're going after the friends cast members. So 96 would it be is Ed in there? Ed is in there. Matt LeBlanc. I feel like that's the one they're really going for. Yeah. Because the others are David Schwimmer in the Paul Barer. Right. Matt Reeves is directorial debut. Lisa Kudrow and mother, which is like a supporting role.
艾伦·德杰尼勒斯因《错体对错》获得提名。我猜那是艾伦的第一部大银幕主演作品。结果不太顺利，对吧？那更……简直是一场灾难性的电影。是的。接下来，是对《老友记》演员们的集体提名。所以他们冲着《老友记》的演员们去了。所以在96年，艾德在里面吗？艾德在里面。马特·勒布朗。我觉得这是他们真正针对的目标。是的。因为其他人有大卫·修蒙和保罗·贝勒。对。马特·里夫斯的导演处女作。丽莎·库卓还有《母亲》，那其实是个配角。
So that's a real stretch. And Jennifer Aniston and she's the one, which I feel like was a movie that everyone thought was okay. So they really should have just nominated Matt Leblanc in Ed. That would have actually been on target. Yes. Fair. Yeah.
所以这牵强附会得厉害。还有詹妮弗·安妮斯顿，她主演了《她是谁》，我觉得那是一部大家觉得还凑合的电影。所以他们其实应该只提名马特·勒布朗和艾德。那样才算真正切中要害。是的。没错。是的。
Then they've got Pamela Anderson and Barb wire. Okay. Now, an obvious razzi thing, right? They just pick on the model slash act. Right, you know, like, but let's put a pin in that. I'm going to come back to that later. This is connected to a larger point.
然后他们提名了帕特里夏·阿奎特和《芭比威龙》。好吧。现在，这是一个很明显的酸莓奖作风，对吧？他们就是喜欢挑超模兼演员的刺。对，你知道的，但我们先把这个放一边。我待会儿会回过头来讲。这和一个更大的观点有关。
I want to make going. Sure. And then the fifth nominee is Sharon Stone, but it's built as the new, quote unquote, serious Sharon Stone in Diabolican last dance. So they're basically, you know, stamping her with the like, don't try and fool us. Right.
我想接着讲。当然。然后第五个提名者是莎朗·斯通，但她被冠以“全新的，所谓的严肃演员莎朗·斯通”的名号，凭借的是《旧爱新欢》和《最后的舞者》。所以他们基本上是在她身上盖戳，意思是“别想糊弄我们。对吧”。
Sharon Stone, you're not a serious actress. You're a genre actor. Last dance is a death row movie. Yeah. Right. She's, she's the one making the, the clemency case. She is on death row for murder and Rob Morrow is trying to save her From death row. You've also got Randy quay Peter Gallagher. Skeet Ulrich. Wow. I mean, I'm just I'm looking at
莎朗·斯通，你不是一个严肃的演员。你是个类型片演员。《最后的舞者》是一部关于死囚牢房的电影。是的。对吧。她，她是在争取宽大处理的人。她因谋杀罪被判死刑，罗布·莫罗正试图将她从死刑中解救出来。里面还有兰迪·奎德、皮特·加拉格尔、斯基特·乌尔里奇。哇。我是说，我只是在看
At this no, no, no, no, I'm just looking at after this right so 97 she doesn't make a movie 98 She's got sphere which is a flop it is good be a high profile flop what if there was a sphere sure she's got mighty which I think is viewed as another sort of failed Oscar bait movie for her yes although I quite a sweet film I haven't seen it since I was a teenager but I remember being yeah I remember being relatively fine uh gets a golden globe nomination for that. Right. She's kind of like a fake lead.
这个……不，不，不，不，我只是在看这之后的作品，对吧？97年她没有拍电影。98年她演了《深渊》，这是一部票房惨败的电影，可以说是备受瞩目的大扑街，如果有一部《深渊》的话……当然。她还有《夺命姣娃》，我觉得这被视为她的又一部失败的冲奥电影，是的，虽然我觉得它是一部挺温馨的电影，自我十几岁起就没再看过，但我记得挺……是的，我记得它相对还不错，因此还获得了金球奖提名。对。她有点像是假主角。
Like the kids are obviously the leads. She's the supporting mom, but yeah. It's billed as a Sharon Stone movie. Right. Then voice and ants. 99 is rough. 99 is the voice. 99 is the voice and ants.
就像孩子们显然是主角一样。她是那个配角妈妈，但确实如此。它被宣传为一部莎朗·斯通的电影。对。然后是配音《蚁哥正传》。99年很难熬。99年是配音。99年是配音和《蚁哥正传》。
Yeah. The glory remake. No one wants. Disasterous movie. Right. Lumet remaking Casavetti's only 15 years later, whatever it is. Bizarre, a bizarre choice. Yes. The muse, which she gets the Golden Globe win for that. And the story immediately becomes, she bought every member of the Hollywood
是的。重拍版《光荣之战》。没人想看。灾难性的电影。对。西德尼·吕美特仅仅在15年后续集或翻拍卡萨维蒂的作品，无论具体是哪部。诡异，一个极其诡异的选择。是的。《缪斯女神》，她因此获得了金球奖。而故事立刻变成了，她买下了好莱坞的每一位成员
foreign press like a Rolex. And she bought her way to the award. It's an infamous sort of, this is how easily the Hollywood foreign press can be swayed story. Griff, way to the award. It's an infamous sort of this is how easily the Hollywood foreign press can be swayed story. Griff, here's the thing. She didn't even get the win. That was the nomination story. Are you kidding me? She lost to Janet McTier for tumbleweeds. Wow. The Golden Globes ordered all 82 members to return luxury gift watches that share a stone and or October films had sent. So yes, it became this embarrassing
like she didn't even earn the award, the nomination. She's pretty good in the muses, isn't she? That movies are all right. She is good, isn't it? Yeah, but like truly from that point on, she's done. Sympathico, if these walls could talk to picking up the pieces, which I think isn't even theatrically released, beautiful Joe, like these are like movies that do not exist. I know. By the time she's popping up in catwoman as the villain, yes, it's this like joky thing of like Sharon Stone, like remember her. And of course, she was famously attacked by a Komodo dragon. Yes. Right. That's the other thing. What's right. Yeah. Talking about she was like Ben Exactly. He's talking about exactly what he just said. She was attacked by a Komodo dragon. She told me. How big are those fucking things?
There's the biggest land animals or whatever. They're like 10 feet long or something. They're terrifying. They paid to close down a reptile house at a zoo so they could have a private tour, right? Yeah. Well, she was married to Phil Bernstein who was the editor-in-chief for, I don't know, something of the San Francisco Chronicle. So this is the local story that I knew of the time.
And they close down, I'm an East Bay guy. And I will correct you. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. You're're an SF guy. They close down, I'm an East Bay guy. Yeah, I will correct you. I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry. Wow, you're a Bay Area guy. Wow. And then, but I lived in San Francisco too, so I don't mean to be so rude about it. But they close down to get a special viewing
of the Komodo Dragon and actually, bit Phil Bernstein's foot. Right. And which is notable because the way that they kill things is they have this horrible mess of bacteria in their mouth. They don't actually like kill things by killing them, tromping them. They kill things by biting them
and then letting them fester and die and then eating later. Wait, that's kind of sick. That's so metal, actually, to be honest. They are very bizarre. I remember when you're a kid, I feel like you learn like, Commodo dragons are like the largest lizards that exist. And you hear like, that sounds awesome.
They're called dragons. And then you see them. And they just kind of look like big lizards. They're like, and you're a little disappointed. Like they don't even look like a crocodile or something cool. They just look like, and you, you, you never see them in comparison to anything. So they just kind of, say, it's tough to gauge size. That's the thing. I can't get any perspective on them. They just kind of look like lizards. Yeah. They're pretty big. They're pretty. They're low to the ground. Obviously.
What's there? There's a, there's a James Bond with the Komodo dragons in it. I think it's skyfall is the one where he's in Macau. And gets kicked into a Komodo dragon pit or whatever. Yeah, classic. It's always happening. But that is truly her biggest credit in that five year period, right? Between 99 and 2004, Catwoman, where they're repositioning it as
is this the sort of ironic comeback of Sharon Stone playing full camp. It's just news stories like that. And it's her going on the Golden Globes and giving a rambling speech and then any polar making fun of it. Like she just becomes this weird sort of pop culture figure who isn't even thought of as an actor anymore. And it sucks because she is so good. She is so good in this. She's so good in this. I think she's a very underrated star in general, not
by everybody, but by a lot. I think her 90s run is very strong and she took good risks. And certainly the story of this movie is her making a lot of correct creative decisions. Correct. She's handed some power and she uses it well. Yeah. I mean, when this movie came out, I was a 20 year old into movies. And so I saw it in the theater. I was very excited for this movie. And Sharon Stone was a thing I had to overcome to be excited about this movie.
Because I only knew her as basically distinct sliver, and I never saw those movies, but they just were distasteful for me as a like a snobby movie guy, you know, at the time. And yeah. And but now when I when I watch it and I at the time, I love this movie and it but now when I watch it, I'm just like, she's amazing in this movie. Yes. She's so good in this movie. She has incredible on screen presence. And I want I want more for her, like a time machine me wants more for her in her career than this. But when we were doing the Verhoeven series some years ago and watching a total recall and basic instinct back to back,
you're just like, how did within five years of basic instinct coming out all of Hollywood decide she is a joke? Like it just doesn't make sense. And it's not like that's a fluke performance, but I do think if I can circle back to the Pamela Anderson thing, right? Because the Razzis are dumb and they're rude. But they do, in their own stupid way, represent the sort of worst type of consensus opinion
around popular culture within eras, right? There are things that they do latch onto of just like, this is what the dumbest people feel. This is what they're reducing movements in pop culture too. And you look at a list like that, you look at a category like that, David, and two things I find run really, really strongly through the entire history of the Razzies is,
they hate things made for women. No, they absolutely do. Yeah. Right. They also look, they make fun of big dumb boy action movies. They hate Michael Bay and Silvester Stallone and whatever. But like, it does feel like movies that are specifically made for women. There's this attitude of the nerve, how dare you even try. What is this dumb shit? The other thing is they, they like hate anyone who too explicitly titillates them, right? Like I'm not saying Pamela Anderson is good and barbed wire, but there's this fury of how dare you make this movie where you show us your tits the whole time, right? And like they gave basic instincts so many fucking nominations. It is absurd. And it's like that is wild considering considering obviously the basic instinct.
Right. Oh my God. I'm realizing Sharon Stone was also nominated for worst new star in 1992. Exactly. For that. Right. It's like rejecting her before she has a chance to reject their nerdy asses. Right. Right. But it's like it's a Madonna and the horror thing of being like, how dare you be this sexy on screen? In this hyper sexual movie, that means I can't take you seriously.
You have to be frivolous. And then once she makes the shift to like, I'm ready to use my clout to make serious films, interesting films, they're like, how dare you try to be serious now? You fucking piece of shit, you know? Like the first time they give her a worst star for being in an erotic thriller,
and the second time they give her a worst star nomination for not being in erotic thrillers anymore. Because the run in between is her doing like sliverer and specialist and the movies that you would do after Basic Instinct, if that's the thing you wanna maintain. And the second she starts veering off from that, like the razzies get angry at her again. It's very interesting, you know, beyond the razzies though,
that like, I guess the roles, like quick and the dead is a great pick. That's sort of out of the ordinary in that she has actually identified a script with a very compelling female lead, right? That she can play. And she's like, cool, I'm going to do this. Casino, obviously, that's, of course, he tapping her at the absolute perfect time
for the absolute perfect role. She is such good casting in Casino. I love that performance. And then after that, things like Diaballi last dance sphere feels like her agents Hollywood, whoever being like, okay, let's find you more like steely ladies, right? Like, how can we class that up or how can we, you know, make that a list? And I just feel like the scripts aren't there. Here's the other thing. And this is totally superficial. But she cuts her hair, right? Yes. Everything pre casino long hair.
And then post casino, she has the look that I knew when I was a teen person, getting into a teen person, getting into movies. Sharon Stone always had short hair. She always had the like very short blonde hair in movies like The Mighty, not in Gloria obviously. She needs like the big, you know, but muse has it to me. Yeah. Yeah, sphere. obviously she needs like the big, you know, but Musey has it to Muse. Yeah.
Yeah, sphere like. And does that like kind of like put her in a weird like sort of post, you know, femme fatale box, I have no idea. I just I just feel like her image shifts and Hollywood gives up on her or something. I don't know. I don't know. Sharon's known things weird. No, but I mean, look, rum, as the person who saw this in theaters at the time, and as
you said, it's like there is that sense of even if her erotic thrillers or her more, you know, sexy roles were big hits that it was like, but we can't take that seriously. I also think on top of that and tell me if I'm wrong here, everyone was just making fun of her all the time. Like even when she was at the peak of her career, she was kind of like a classic, like Leno style punchline. Yeah, I think so. I think that's the nature of those erotic thrillers. Like make in the same way that you talk about the ranzis, it makes people like nervous and nervously make jokes and nervously like dismiss her because they're afraid of their feelings.
Right. Right. And then when she cuts the hair and it's like, wait, you're not trying to be a pin-up model anymore. Like you're not looking like the idealized form of a femme fatale, then people get angry at her again. It's a tragedy. What? It is. Her career.
But I also think that she probably, you know, she stepped away. She seems to have a lot of other interests. She's super smart, you know. And I'm pretty sure that part of her career was her choice too. I wouldn't take that away from her because she definitely made choices later on to not being things, I'm sure. Yes, I mean, she's talked about being really fucking fed up with everything. Why not?
Absolutely, why not? I mean, why not? Yeah, absolutely. Why not? And so, and especially because I think this is one of those ones where it is both, it is so quickly dead, it's so against the grain. Like, this is not the heyday of the Western. This is not, Sam Remy is not an established director, a list director. It is a strange role and she took all that stuff, but together and made this thing happen.
And it is the testament to how on it she was and how much she was not really just trying to take boxes and that kind of will Smith way of just like, okay, I'm going to study all of the box butchers of the world and I'm going to decide I'm going to make block butchers. She just made a cool ass movie with her power, which is awesome. She also put her neck out on the line successfully for two of the guys who were about to become made a cool ass movie with her power, which is awesome. You know? She also, like, put her neck out on the line successfully for two of the guys who were about to become two of the biggest leading men in Hollywood
and the man who had direct the first huge super hair franchise. It's amazingly prescient. It's stunning, yeah. It's funny for 1995, and I can get into some of the context and say, but like, when you think of Westerns, obviously, it was sort of a supposed boom for the 90s Western was to have had me write dances with Wolves, Wins Best Picture and then on for given Winfers Best Picture. And then you have
these movies like Geronimo, you have Tombstone, uh, why is Lickers city's like a city's like a huge one. Uh, like, and so in 1995, all the movies we just mentioned have come out. And not I would say a lot, most of the movies we just mentioned were hits, not wider, but not Toronto mode. Toronto was not the most of them are all hit. Yeah. And, and like like This I would say is right when the bloom is again off the roads like Hollywood's western come back really just last A few years yeah, and by 1996 the only big westerns I'm seeing here are from dust hill dawn, which is not count. That's a horror movie obviously, but it's got western Themes I guess western aesthetics. I love that movie to be clear. Loan star, which is like, you know, dark, neo-Western mystery, contemporary. And like that's basically it.
Like, I mean, this list has last man standing. I don't think of that as a Western really. It's like a prohibition movie. It's like gangsters. Yeah, but it's definitely in the style of these. I mean, it's like a prohibition movie. It's like gangsters. Yeah, but it's, it's definitely in the style of these. I mean, it's a remake of, it's a remake of, a Jimbo. A Jimbo and what's the, what's the western version of your Jimbo? I can't remember, but there's another one in between there.
And then by 97, it's like the postman. That's like the only western Hollywood. This is what I was gonna say though. Like, Costner is the guy who's like really working to bring the Western back. And by the second half of the 90s, he's kind of shifted more to sci-fi. Like postman is like Western sci-fi. He's done Westworld now or Waterworld rather, not Westworld.
You can sneak in horses and stuff in like the Mascazaro, you know, some wild, wild west, like something like that where it's like, it's not just a straight ahead western, but the quick and the dead is really stripped down in that it's like, here we are in a town. There's a mean sheriff. There's guys. There's a saloon. Everyone's got guns.
This is not about like the American experience, you know, in the west at all. It's about like, what if there was a town where everyone's job was cowboy who shoots you, right? Like, you know, there's no like economics that work. No, it's like, it's like fucking like karate kid part two with shootouts or whatever. But, but also, yes, you have Gene Hackman doing a western for the first time since he won an Oscar for playing the bad guy in a western. Which was just like three years ago. What was that log of a? It is really funny to me the juxtaposition of those two characters which are basically the same character. Yeah, but one of them is like serious with serious motivations where you can see he's a
good guy or maybe at one point in his life was a good guy who went down a very, very dark path or maybe at one point in his life was a good guy who went down a very, very dark path and the Herod character in this one where he's just a cartoon villain. And they're both so good. I know. I like both performances so very, very much. And it makes me think that maybe Gene Hagwin
is the best actor of all. There's a solid argument. And he's when I hear someone suggest that it's hard to shoot it down. Like you, he's at least in that very, very upper realm of debate. The whole thing with Gene Hackman is he could absolutely just give you Gene Hackman, right? Like if I just called him up and I was like, you're going to play kind of like a gritty, tough guy in this who doesn't take a lot of shit.
绝对是最好的演员。这很有说服力。而且当我听到有人这么说时，很难反驳。像你一样，他至少处于那种非常、非常顶尖的讨论领域。吉恩·哈克曼厉害的地方在于，他完全可以只演出“吉恩·哈克曼”本色，对吧？就像如果我打电话给他，跟他说，你在这部电影里要演一个那种有点粗犷、硬汉、不好惹的角色。
And you're maybe going to have a mustache. He would be like, you know, play kind of like a gritty tough guy in this who doesn't take a lot of shit. And you're maybe gonna have a mustache. He would be like, you know, that would be fine. And so you could be fooled into thinking like, yes, Gene Hackman was a great movie star, but he kind of just did his thing. And then you'll see something like Get Shorty, one of my favorite Gene Hackman performances ever, where he plays like a quivering buffoon, like an absolute idiot, Cuck great character, so funny. And then you're like,
而且你可能还得留着胡子。他就会说，你知道的，演一个那种有点粗犷的硬汉，不好惹。而且你可能还得留着胡子。他就会说，你知道的，那挺好的。所以你可能会被误导，觉得没错，吉恩·哈克曼是个伟大的电影明星，但他其实也就是在做他自己。然后你会看到像《矮子当道》这样的电影，这是我最喜欢的吉恩·哈克曼的表演之一，他在里面演一个战战兢兢的丑角，就像个绝对的笨蛋，一个好笑的大傻瓜，角色太棒了，非常搞笑。然后你就会觉得，
Jean Hackman secretly could do anything. And like, and like, that is why, yes, there's an argument that he is the greatest actor in Hollywood history, I think. I think he's, there's an argument. You never hear horrible things about him. He's sort of like, he like he just is able to do. Everyone said, and I think he's admitted in the years since he retired and chilled out.
吉恩·哈克曼暗地里其实什么都能演。所以，这就是为什么，是的，有人认为他是好莱坞历史上最伟大的演员，我认为。我认为他，这种观点是成立的。你从来没听过关于他的可怕传闻。他有点像，他就是能够做到。每个人都说，而且我想他在退休和放松之后的这些年里也承认过，
He was incredibly difficult. Oh, okay. That he was not a friendly man. I'm not using like language to screw around it, but I feel like even like when they've done Royal Tannenbaum's retrospectives, and that's like his second or third to last movie ever, they all say like he's not pleasant. Like he's very intense and he's angry, which look is his superpower on screen. Like he is better at harnessing anger. Oh, he's so good.
他非常难相处。哦，好吧。他并不是一个友好的人。我不是在用什么委婉的词，但我觉得甚至在他们做《特南鲍姆一家》回顾展的时候——那已经是他倒数第二或倒数第三部电影了——他们都说他很不讨人喜欢。他非常强势而且易怒，你看，这正是他在银幕上的超能力。他非常擅长驾驭愤怒。哦，他太棒了。
He's so good. His levels of anger are fantastic. Yeah. I like his sort of growly anger. And I like his, like, when he gets, you know, upset. It's like, like, when he gets in his red shirt, he goes, you're not faster than me. You know, like, it's really up here.
他太棒了。他表现愤怒的层次简直绝了。对。我喜欢他那种低沉咆哮式的愤怒。我喜欢他那种，当他，你知道的，情绪激动的样子。就像，当他穿上红衬衫，他说，你没有我快。你知道的，这真的是情绪拉满了。
Like, I just fucking love it. Yeah, you are dead right, though, Roman, that, like, the facility in just sort of, him understanding the difference in just sort of, him understanding the difference between these two characters, you know, this character and the character and unforgiven, that on paper are very similar. And the difference is the sort of shifts he makes in energy modulation and performance style to fit into each movie and the demands of that narrative properly.
就像，我他妈太爱了。对，罗曼，你说得完全对，那种游刃有余的感觉，他单纯地理解这两个角色之间的区别，你知道的，这个角色和《不可饶恕》里的角色，纸面上看非常相似。但不同之处在于他在能量调节和表演风格上做出的种种转变，以完美契合每一部电影以及该叙事的要求。
It's totally different. Cause I was coming in, so I watched a quick and the dead and unforgiven for this, Oh wow. For this little broadcast here. And I was like, because I was gonna make the case that they were the same character. And they are not, they are very, very different.
完全不同。因为我当时来看的，为了这次小小的广播节目，我快速重温了《致命快感》和《不可饶恕》，哦，哇。为了我们这里的这个小广播。我当时想，因为我本来打算论证这两个其实是同一个角色。但它们并不是，它们非常、非常不同。
And it's all comes from the way Jean Hackman plays it, not how necessarily how they're written. It is surprising that he was cast because of what you're just the super special connection. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Right. It's the kind of thing we're studying. Studios are both like, let's just have them play Little Bill again. But also you wonder if that's a deterrent if audiences can be turned off by seeing something they've already seen. Right. But, um, but they're totally different. I mean, it takes a minute to notice it in a way, or you have to really be paying attention to it. The same way I think you have to notice
这一切都源于吉恩·哈克曼的演绎方式，而不一定取决于剧本是怎么写的。他能被选中其实挺让人意外的，因为你们刚才提到的那种超级特殊的联系。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。没错。这就好比制片厂都在想，让他在演一遍小比尔吧。但你也会想，如果观众看到似曾相识的东西会不会感到厌烦，这会不会成为一种阻碍？对。但是，呃，不过它们完全不同。我的意思是，你得花点时间才能注意到这一点，或者你必须真的非常专心去看。就像我觉得你也得注意到
all the incredible things I think Sharon Stone is doing. Like, she's one character in the very beginning. She is playing a character of what is, what if Clint Eastwood was this role, but it's a woman playing it. And then Herod shows up. It freaks her the fuck out so much that every moment after that, she's twitchy, she experiences her trauma all the time. You see it in her face, you see it in the movement. Like they really train on her reactions in her face.
莎朗·斯通在片中所做的所有不可思议的表演。比如，在电影开头，她是一个角色。她所扮演的角色设定是：如果克林特·伊斯特伍德演这个角色会怎么样，但扮演它的是个女人。然后希罗出现了。这把她吓得魂飞魄散，以至于在那之后的每一个时刻，她都神经质，无时无刻不在经历创伤。你能从她的脸上看出来，从她的动作中看出来。他们真的很注重特写她脸上的反应。
And I think it's brilliant. I think it's brilliant choice. I think it's a brilliant way that she plays it. And it really is about a person being affected by another person that changes their whole facade. And I think that the way they interact together is incredibly well done. I think you see how much you learn from working
我觉得这太绝了。我觉得这是一个绝妙的选择。我觉得她演绎这个角色的方式堪称精妙。这确实关乎一个人如何被另一个人影响，从而改变了她整个人设。而且我觉得他们之间的互动拍得极其出色。你会发现，从拍摄
on those for Hover movies about not needing to be realistic, right, or naturalistic in her performances that she can do something more expressionistic not needing to be realistic, right? Or naturalistic in her performances, that she can do something more expressionistic to better suit the tone, the mood, the genre. It's sort of make bigger statements because so much of a character is this sort of, I mean, this entire movie comes out of this like, if you were to just have the man with no name be a woman, how does that change the dynamic of every scene, right? And so she's playing with that very consciously
那些霍华德·霍克斯的电影中，她学到了多少关于不需要那么现实主义，对吧，或者说在表演中不需要那么自然主义，她可以做一些更具表现主义色彩的东西，不需要那么现实主义，对吧？或者在表演中不需要那么自然主义，她可以做一些更具表现主义色彩的东西，来更好地契合基调、氛围和类型。这有点像是在表达更大的主张，因为这个角色的很大一部分，我的意思是，整部电影都源于这样一种设想：如果你让无名客变成一个女人，这会如何改变每一个场景的戏剧张力，对吧？所以她非常有意识地在拿捏这一点：
of when she needs to play the emotions of the character, when she needs to play the iconography of what she's representing. And it's, yeah, it's like really impressive work. And Hackman is able to make this entirely different character from Little Bill. Despite not doing any obvious actory things, it's not like he said, I want a prosthetic nose
什么时候需要展现角色的情感，什么时候需要展现她所代表的符号化特征。这真的是非常令人印象深刻的表演。而哈克曼则能够塑造出一个与小比尔截然不同的角色。尽管他没有做任何显眼的“演员式”的小动作，他并没有说，我想要一个假鼻子
and a mustache with the character's different. I'm gonna do a different voice. I'm gonna call this some tick to make him really unique. It's just emotional modulation and knowing exactly what movie he's in and what role he needs to serve within that story. You guys know Hackman lived with like Dustin Hoffman and who was the other, other devol right back in
和一撮小胡子来让这个角色与众不同。我要换个声音。我要加点什么口头禅来让他独一无二。这纯粹是情感的调节，并且清楚地知道自己身处哪部电影，以及在这个故事中需要承担什么角色。你们知道哈克曼当年在纽约跟达斯汀·霍夫曼以及另一个，另一个德沃（指罗伯特·德尼罗）住在一起吗，
the day in New York, right? The original pussy posse, yeah. That, but like imagine living with him, even young hackman, like who's maybe has less gravitas, yeah, or what, you know, and like you ate his cheese out of the fridge or like just imagine like having a roommate conversations, they to me, chills me to my bone. Yes, yes, like try and ask him to do the dishes like. Exactly like, um, when you come home and I,
最早的“泡妞小分队”，对。但是，想象一下跟他住在一起，哪怕是年轻时的哈克曼，可能还没那么有威严，对吧，或者怎么着，你知道的，比如你吃了他放在冰箱里的奶酪，或者仅仅是想象一下和室友的日常对话，对我来说，想想都让人不寒而栗。对，对，就像试着要求他洗碗一样。
Yeah, slam the door, it's waking me up, like whatever. I mean, the other thing is he just, he always looked like that. Yeah. You know, he just like had jean hackman face and had that voice. Yeah, he just had, like, a G'd-Hackman face. He had that voice. Yeah. Yeah, young Gene Hackman is very, very hard to picture.
完全就像，呃，当你回到家，我，
Obviously, there's sort of like night moves, Gene Hackman, right? Like, sort of, like, middle Gene Hackman with the stash where he just looks exactly the same. You look at young Gene Hackman, you're like, yeah, I get it. Like I get that that makes sense. But he's like a little, he's, he's bulkier in French connection, which is his, yeah, and he's a little sausage. You see, you see it with a little hat and a little jacket.
是的，摔门声把我吵醒了，诸如此类的。我的意思是，另一回事是，他长相就一直那样。对。你知道的，他就是长着一张吉恩·哈克曼的脸，有着那样的声音。对，他就是长了一张吉恩·哈克曼的脸。他有那个声音。对。对，年轻的吉恩·哈克曼非常、非常难想象。
Like, yeah, he's, yeah, he's not a trim guy intimidating. Yeah, that's basically it. He's intimidating, but I think one of his reasons why, like I have such reverence for him, is because he was never quite that lean man style. Yeah. He was able to be the best part in so many movies. Well, he can be big, he can be smaller.
当然，某种程度上就像《夜间行动》里的吉恩·哈克曼，对吧？差不多就是，留着小胡子的中年吉恩·哈克曼，长相完全没变。你看到年轻的吉恩·哈克曼，你会觉得，对，我懂。就觉得这很合理。但他在《法国贩毒网》里有点，体型更魁梧，那是他的，对，他有点胖乎乎的。你看到他戴着一顶小帽子，穿着一件小夹克。
I mean, he didn't just do so much, and I kind of like all of it. I agree, he's fascinating because he can selflessly take on a supporting role or a villain role or be a mentor character or whatever it is and be the most interesting part of the movie. And then whenever he was placed at the top of the movie to play the plot driver,
就像，对，是的，他可不是个苗条精干、充满威慑力的家伙。对，基本上就是这样。他很有威慑力，但我认为我对他如此崇敬的原因之一，是因为他从来都不是那种精瘦型的帅哥。对。他能够在那么多电影里贡献最精彩的表演。嗯，他可以演大人物，也可以演小人物。
he also somehow remained the most interesting person in the movie. Like he never collapsed under the weight of that sort of narrative responsibility or needing to be the leading man type or any of that. There's a story, I think I sent this to you and the Doe Boys David. We were texting about how good Hackman is.
我的意思是，他不仅作品高产，而且我基本上都挺喜欢。我同意，他很迷人，因为他可以毫无私心地去演一个配角、反派或者导师之类的角色，并且成为电影中最有趣的部分。然后，每当他被安排在电影的中心位置去驱动剧情时，
And I sent you guys that clip of Kevin Costner on the Rich Eisen show talking about Hackman. Did you watch that? Maybe. What's the, there was whatever thriller the two of them did together. Hackman and Costner, pretty early in Costner's. Oh, no way out.
他不知怎么的依然是电影中最有趣的人。就像他从未被那种叙事责任的重量、或者需要成为男主角的压力之类的不堪重负。有一个故事，我想我把这个发给你和“面团男孩”大卫了。我们当时在短信里讨论哈克曼有多棒。
Yeah, good way out. Yes, yes. So they were talking about on that movie, Costner was coming in pretty hot, right? Like he is a man with a lot of opinions and he was very ready to be a leading man and a director and all of that. So they're doing all these scenes
我把凯文·科斯特纳在里奇·艾森秀上谈论哈克曼的那段视频发给你们了。你们看了吗？可能吧。那是讲，他们俩合作过什么惊悚片来着。哈克曼和科斯特纳，在科斯特纳的早期。哦，无路可逃。
and I think he was saying that like most of his scenes with Hackman were in like office rooms behind a desk and they didn't feel very dynamic. I've never seen this movie but that he was behind a desk for most of his scenes with Hackman were in like office rooms behind a desk and they didn't feel very dynamic. I've never seen this movie, but that he was behind a desk for most of it and that he got to set and was sort of like, this is boring. We should do this, move this chair, stand up, change the block, and whatever. And was just being very opinionate with everything. Roger Donaldson was sort of pushing back on him.
对，好片《无路可逃》。对，对。所以他们谈到那部电影时，科斯特纳当时正处在事业上升期，干劲十足，对吧？就像他是一个有很多想法的人，而且他非常渴望成为男主角、当导演之类的。所以他们在拍所有这些场景时，
He was really being stubborn about like, I finally become a leading man. Like, I don't want to blow it. I don't want to be lazy. I don't want to rest on my laurels. I want to make every scene as dynamic as I can. This is Gene Hackman. This is one of my idols.
我想他是说，他和哈克曼的大多数对手戏都是在办公室的办公桌后面拍的，感觉不是很动态。我从来没看过这部电影，但他和哈克曼的大多数对手戏都是在办公室的办公桌后面拍的，感觉不是很动态。我从来没看过这部电影，但他大部分戏份都在桌子后面，他到了片场就觉得，这太无聊了。我们应该这样拍，移开这把椅子，站起来，改变场面调度，等等。对所有事情都非常有主见。罗杰·唐纳森当时还在跟他顶撞。
And Hackman was just sitting there like silently the entire time as these fights were happening. And then would just wait for them to settle and would do whatever they landed on, right? And at the end of the day, and costume was like, I don't know if I pissed him off. I don't know what's going on here. And at the end of the day, Hacman stops him when he's like walking out of his trailer to get to his car and he goes like, Hey, kid.
他真的很固执，心想：我好不容易成了男主角。我不想搞砸。我不想偷懒。我不想吃老本。我想让每一个场景都尽可能充满活力。这可是吉恩·哈克曼。这是我的偶像之一。
And Costner, Kevin Costner was like Jean Hacman's about to chew me out. Like it is terrified of Jean Hacman, even at peak physical Kevin Costner, right? And it's just like, this guy's going to fucking destroy me. And Costner goes up to him and he is like, you know, I had a bad divorce and I had to take some movies I didn't really want to do and pay my settlement. I think I sort of forgot what I like about doing this and watching you today fight for that. It reminded me of when I was a young actor and I cared about every single choice. So thank you for that.
而哈克曼在这些争吵发生时，只是一言不发地坐在那里。然后静静等待他们争论出一个结果，并照着他们最终确定的方案去演，对吧？到了收工的时候，科斯特纳心想：我不知道我是不是惹恼他了。我不知道这到底是怎么回事。结果在收工时，哈克曼在他走出保姆车去停车场的时候拦住了他，然后说道：“嘿，小子。”
Well. And he liked walked off and then Hackman has like a golden period right after that. Huh. Yeah. It's true. Passes the, he, he, he, he like reignites the torch. Sorry. Yeah.
科斯特纳、凯文·科斯特纳当时觉得吉恩·哈克曼要狠狠训斥我了。就像是对吉恩·哈克曼充满恐惧，哪怕当时正是身体状态处于巅峰的凯文·科斯特纳，对吧？心想这家伙要彻底整死我了。结果科斯特纳走过去，听他说：“你知道吗，我经历了一场糟糕的离婚，我不得不接拍一些我其实并不想拍的电影来支付赡养费。我想我有点忘记了我为什么喜欢做这件事，而今天看你为表演据理力争，让我想起了我年轻时作为演员、对每一个选择都在乎的时光。所以，谢谢你。”
It's like when Hackman, because I feel like why Hackman won an Oscar for unforgiven. I mean, obviously, he's really good in unforgiven. It's a perfect supporting act, but it was also kind of the Oscars being like, you still got the juice buddy, like, or what, you know, like, it's that rediscovery thing. Yeah. I mean, I think his 80s were not particularly great outside of Hoosiers and Costner says that Hoosiers, I think came out when they were shooting No Way out. Yes, right. And Adam was like, I gotta be honest, I didn't know what we had.
哇。然后他就走开了，紧接着哈克曼就迎来了他的一段黄金时期。哈？对。确实如此。薪火相传，他，他，他，他重新点燃了火炬。抱歉。对。
I thought that was a piece of shit and I didn't think I was giving it my all. He's incredible in Hoosiers, but it's obviously a very quiet internal performance. Yeah. But Hacken by his own admission was like, I feel guilty by how much I wasn't respecting that movie and appreciating it while we were making it.
就好像哈克曼，因为我觉得为什么哈克曼会凭《不可饶恕》赢得奥斯卡。我的意思是，很显然，他在《不可饶恕》里演得真的很好。这是一个完美的配角，但这也同时有点像奥斯卡在说：“老兄，你宝刀未老啊”，或者类似的话，你知道吗，就是那种重新被发现的感觉。对。我的意思是，除了《球场岁月》之外，他在80年代的作品并不是特别出色，而科斯特纳说过，《球场岁月》上映的时候，他们好像正在拍《无路可逃》。是的，对。亚当当时说，我得老实说，我当时真不知道我们拍了个什么东西。
I feel like he did a lot of stuff for money, right? Like he's in Super Men 4, that's kind of embarrassing. He did a lot of shit. It kind of like- Well, like, Uncommon Valor was a movie that was like a hip, I wasn't respected. Like, he did a lot of, the 80s, this was what he was saying. He had like a't respected. Like he did a lot of the 80s. This was what he was saying. He had like a bad divorce and he did a lot of movies for money.
我觉得那就是个狗屎，而且我当时觉得我并没有全力以赴。他在《球场岁月》里表现得不可思议，但这显然是一部非常安静、内敛的表演。对。但哈克曼自己也承认，他说：对于我们在拍这部电影时，我竟然没有那么尊重它、没有好好欣赏它，我感到很内疚。
And it's not like in the 90s, he did all jambs. Like he did a little bit. But I mean, God, this year he has quickened to dead Crimson Tide and get shorty. It's his 95. Well, I just feel like even though he's in movies that don't turn out to be great, he always comported himself. Well, where it's like even though he's in movies that don't turn out to be great, he always comported himself. Well, I don't think this stink of a bad movie ever really
我觉得他以前为了钱拍了很多烂片，对吧？比如他演了《超人4》，那挺尴尬的。他拍了很多烂片。有点像——嗯，就像《特殊任务》是一部热门电影，但我不怎么尊重它。我的意思是，他拍了很多，80年代时，这就是他所说的。他经历了一场糟糕的婚姻，为了钱拍了很多电影。
stuck to him, which is part of the grace of not being a Dustin Hoffman or Robert De Niro, or like that. He gets to be good in things and be respected. But I don't know, like he doesn't take, I don't remember him in those bad movies. No, and I also think, I mean, David, we've talked about like the Tommy Lee Jones phenomenon where Tommy Lee Jones is another actor whose superpower is like anger, right? And so when he's giving anger, right, right.
而且并不是说他在90年代演的全是杰作。他也拍了一些一般的。但天哪，他这一年有《致命快感》、《赤色风暴》和《矮子当道》。这是他在1995年的作品。嗯，我只是觉得，尽管他参演的电影最后不一定很好，但他总是举止得体。好吧，就好像尽管他身处那些最终不怎么样的电影中，他总是能表现得很好。我觉得一部烂电影的恶名从来没有真正
And like disgust and distaste for everything around him. When he's giving a movie his all he's incredible and when he hates that he's in a movie, he's incredible because his actual disregard his movie or action translates. So I think like whatever period Regina Hackman's heart was maybe in it a little less, the performances were still really fucking compelling. And then I think in the 90s he started just being like putting his heart fully back into everything. And then yes, even when he was taking paycheck jobs, he's like over-delivering on all of it. Uh, God, he's so good. He is good. The quick and the dead is good. This film is directed by Sam Rehab. And boy was it directed.
粘在他身上，这就是不当达斯汀·霍夫曼或罗伯特·德尼罗的好处——或者说那种优雅。他总能在各种作品里表现出色并赢得尊重。但不知道为什么，他不会接，我不记得他在那些烂片里有什么糟糕的表现。不，我也觉得，大卫，我们讨论过汤米·李·琼斯现象，汤米·李·琼斯是另一位以愤怒为超能力的演员，对吧？所以当他展现愤怒时，对，对。
It really was. It directed this shit out of this shit. Look, I love Sam Raimi. And I love this movie. And I love how he directed it. But it is that kind of thing. Like when I was 12 years old and I was trying to understand what is a director?
还有对周围一切的厌恶和鄙视。当他全力以赴投入一部电影时，他简直不可思议；而当他讨厌一部电影时，他同样不可思议，因为他对待电影或角色的这种真正的不屑一顾转化成了银幕上的张力。所以我觉得，无论在哪一个时期，吉恩·哈克曼的心可能没有完全放在上面，但他的表演依然极其引人入胜。然后我觉得到了90年代，他开始把全部的心思重新投入到每一部作品中。然后，是的，哪怕他只是为了拿薪水而接片，他也会超额完成所有表演。天哪，他太棒了。他确实很棒。《致命快感》很好看。这部电影由山姆·雷米执导。天哪，这导演功力太强了。
How can I watch a film and understand how it was directed? This would be a good entry level where you're like, did you notice there are a few subtle choices? How the story was told? That's sort of Sam Raimi's fingers that you're these little fingerprints that you're noticing here, right? You notice that gun floating across the screen for no reason. That's a very Sam Raimi move right there. You watch this movie, you're like,
确实如此。他对这破电影的执导简直发挥到了极致。听着，我爱山姆·雷米。我也爱这部电影。我爱他执导它的方式。但这就是那种感觉。就像我12岁的时候，我试图理解什么是导演？
it was he the only guy who watched the man with no name, trilogy, and during all the shootouts and standoffs was like, come on, let's blow some juice and not enough stuff happening. Right. I love it. I think it's like, it's weird that Western, which is often kind of an excuse to kind of have a movie do nothing
我怎么才能看懂一部电影并理解它是如何被导演出来的？这会是一个很好的入门级影片，你会想：你注意到里面有一些微妙的选择了吗？这个故事是如何被讲述的？这就是山姆·雷米的风格，你在这里注意到这些小小的指纹了吗，对吧？你注意到那把枪无缘无故地在银幕上漂浮移动了吗？这绝对是山姆·雷米的典型手法。你看了这部电影，你会想，
except for just have Vista's being in display, that he takes that and just like pours Sam raeminess into it in a way that is like, I find so compelling, like I really love it. It's like, I would never put it together that these like succession of shootouts is the perfect use of his superpower, but it totally is. It's just a video game of like, of a boss level, like, you know, like continued like series of boss level fights that allow him to like do, can't at angle, that just, you know, flips all the way over or the jaw, the jaw is like pull back angle sort of thing.
难道他是唯一一个看过《无名客三部曲》，并且在所有枪战和对峙场面时都在想“拜托，搞点刺激的吧，发生的事情还不够多”的人吗？对。我太喜欢了。我觉得这很奇怪，西部片通常往往是让电影无所事事的借口，
And he just does every single fight is different. He's like, it's so good. It is a thing. He is as every tool in the toolbox, he doesn't repeat himself. And the other thing with him is for how loud his directing style is. I don't think there's a single thing in this movie that is like the flash or style for its own say. Like every choice he makes as loud as it is is in support of trying to convey the emotion of that moment with the most sort of extreme amount of energy, which for a film that is very, very clean and simple and straightforward, plot-wise,
除了展示壮丽的风景之外，而他却打破常规，将山姆·雷米式的风格倾注其中，我觉得这太吸引人了，我真的很喜欢。这就好像，我绝不会把这一连串的枪战看作是他超能力的完美运用，但它确实是。它简直就像一个视频游戏里的Boss关卡，你知道的，就像一连串持续的Boss战，让他能够使用荷兰角镜头（斜拍镜头），那种整个翻转过来的镜头，或者下巴仰拍角度之类的。
it does help a lot. I totally agree. And I think that also the emotion stays with it. I mean, there's some key emotional moments that are played sincerely and you feel them sincerely. They are not a joke. And it's a really delicate balance to strike. And he does it. I think throughout this movie, which is why I think one of the reasons why I think it's a real triumph. I agree with everything you guys are saying, but I think that at the time critics did not agree. Oh, absolutely. The popular reaction was this movie is all flash.
而且每一场打斗都不尽相同。太棒了。这真的是一回事。他拥有工具箱里的所有工具，而且他从不重复自己。关于他的另一件事是，尽管他的导演风格如此张扬，但我认为这部电影里没有任何东西是为了炫技而炫技。他做出的每一个选择，无论多么张扬，都是为了以最极端的能量来传达那一刻的情感。对于一部在情节上非常、非常干净、简单、直白的电影来说，
You know, it's all sizzle, no steak, and I'm not getting any emotion and Sam Remy can't fucking calm down, right? Like that was the hit at the time. Well, so all the Westerns you're talking about in this sort of like 90s, late 80s, 90s wave, right? That is dying at this moment. All of them are like very austere. They are the steige adult revisionist Westerns by and large that have like a simplicity
这确实帮了大忙。我完全同意。而且我也认为这种情感一直贯穿其中。我的意思是，有一些关键的情感时刻表现得很真挚，你也能真切地感受到。它们不是开玩笑。要把握好这种微妙的平衡非常不容易。但他做到了。我觉得整部电影都是如此，这也是为什么我认为这是一次真正的胜利。我同意你们所说的一切，但我觉得当时的影评人并不这么认为。哦，绝对的。大众的反应是这部电影全都是浮夸的视觉效果。
to their filmmaking style. And this is a popcorn movie. Right. I would say to tombstone is the trashiest of those 90s westerns. It's not nearly as sort of fizzy as this movie, but tombstone obviously definitely a little more, a little less austere. And then city slickers was not the most austere work. But of course, I'm joking when I include city slickers and all this. But but truly was not the most austere work, but of course I'm joking when I include city slickers in all this. But but truly city stickers is more austere, cinematically than this is like city slickers are
你知道的，全是花架子，没有实质内容，我感受不到任何情感，山姆·雷米根本停不下来，对吧？这就是当时的差评。好吧，所以你们谈论的所有这些90年代、80年代末到90年代浪潮中的西部片，对吧？在那个时期正在走向消亡。它们大体上都是非常朴素的。它们是斯托伊奇式的成人修正主义西部片，其电影制作风格往往具有一种简单性。
very sacram. Yes, I would say that most things are more austere than that. Yeah, it's a low bar, but yes, it absolutely is. Yeah, so quick and the dead, even though it has actors from one forgiven and it has like The aesthetics that the look not not the way the camera's moving But you know the the frontier town and the costumes and all that that would feel very recognizable. Yes, it is aesthetically Completely different from all the other westerns people are seeing so maybe that through people off like Too goofy. I'm looking at Jean Hackman here. I forgot that in between unforgiven and quick of the dead,
而这是一部爆米花电影。对。我想说《墓镇》是那些90年代西部片中最流俗的一部。它远没有这部电影那么有活力，但《墓镇》显然确实多了一点，少了一点朴素感。然后《城市滑头》也不是最朴素的作品。当然，我把《城市滑头》也归入其中是在开玩笑。但真正说来，《城市滑头》在电影美学上其实比这部电影更朴素，因为《城市滑头》
he is also in white herb and geronimo. Yeah, no, he other movies we've been he would sign on. Yeah, he would sign on. He's still like money. Yes, he loved it. I remember this being a flop or being a critical flop as it was completely confounding to me. Like, as I saw it, and I just like, well, that's one of the greatest movies I've seen this year. And I mean, I think that one of its, the other thing that was going on is like you're, you're kind of in the pulp fiction, you know,
非常萨克拉门托风格。是的，我会说大多数东西都比这部更朴素。对，这标准很低，但确实如此。对，所以《致命快感》，尽管它有来自《不可饶恕》的演员，并且拥有诸如美学风格——不是指运镜方式，而是你知道的，边境小镇、服装以及所有这些——让人感觉非常眼熟。是的，它在美学上与人们看到的其他所有西部片完全不同，所以这可能让大家感到困惑：太滑稽了。我看着这里的吉恩·哈克曼，我差点忘了在《不可饶恕》和《致命快感》之间，
I, ironic, like this, this is a pastiche in an interesting way of Sergio Leone, but it's also not ironic, it's not me. It's not I rot, spirit. No. It has a real sincerity to it that I think also short-circuited the kind of cinephile reaction to it too.
他还演了《怀亚特·厄普》和《杰罗尼莫》。对，没错，他还会接演其他我们提到过的电影。对，他还是会签约。他依然很喜欢钱。是的，他爱钱。我记得这部电影成了一部票房或口碑上的滑铁卢，这让我感到完全莫名其妙。因为当我看完它时，我只是觉得，好吧，这是我今年看过的最伟大的电影之一。我的意思是，我觉得其中一个，当时还在发生的事情是，你有点处在《低俗小说》那种，
Like it had, it didn't get embraced by any group of movie goers at the time. And I just, I don't know why it was this a big fat me-pull for me. Yeah, it was a February release. Like, I feel like that's kind of a weird dumping from Sony and like, the whole thing is just kind of neither. It's like, well, this is an expensive movie of movie stars. Is this an Prestige project?
你知道的，我这种，讽刺的，这在某种有趣的方式上是对赛尔乔·莱昂内的一种致敬，但它同时又不是讽刺的，不是那种冷嘲热讽的风格。它不是讽刺的调性。不。它有一种真正的真诚，我觉得这也阻碍了影迷群体对它的反应。
No. Is it for families? Definitely not. Oh, okay. You know, like the options are kind of narrowing. Is it for families? Definitely not. Okay. The options are kind of narrowing. It's only a war domination is a Saturn award for best actress. That's it. For her.
就像它当时没有受到任何特定影迷群体的拥抱。我不知道为什么，对我来说这绝对是一部完美直击我好好的电影。对，这是一部二月份上映的电影。我觉得这有点像是索尼公司随手扔出的炮灰档期，整部电影给人的感觉就是不上不下。就像，好吧，这是一部众星云集的大制作电影。这是部冲奖大片吗？
Wow. From Dusteldon is the year after this. And that's what you're talking about, Roman. That's the Western that is now speaking to the post-Tarantino generation by being written by Tarantino, hostarring Tarantino, and 30 minutes in being like, just kidding, we're not a western. Right. And to be clear, I adore that.
不是。是拍给全家人看的合家欢吗？绝对不是。哦，好吧。你知道的，选择的范围正在缩小。是拍给全家人看的吗？绝对不是。好吧。选择的范围正在缩小。它唯一的重大奖项是土星奖最佳女主角。就这。颁给她的。
Same. The whole joke of that movie is that it stops being a western. And it's, you know, right. Anyway, the quick and the dead, let me give you guys some context, okay? Please. All right, so this one's written by Simon Moore, who at the time is best known for the TV
哇。从《全面回忆》到这部电影是一年之后的事。而这正是你提到的，罗曼。那是部通过由昆汀编剧、昆汀客串演出、并在片子进行到30分钟时突然来一句“开玩笑的，我们其实不是西部片”来迎合后昆汀时代的西部片。而且要明确的是，我非常喜欢那部。
mini series Traffic with a K. How would you know that? Traffic is spelled with an IC in the United States of America where we all have lived our entire lives. In 1989, there was a British mini series for Channel 4 in it called traffic. Are you talking like that, David? Yeah, this is very odd. It doesn't sound right, actually. No. Famously turned into the film traffic by Steven sort of worked many years later.
我也是。那部电影的整个梗就在于它突然不再是一部西部片了。而且，你知道的，对。不管怎样，《致命快感》，让我给你们一些背景信息，好吗？请吧。好吧，这部电影的编剧是西蒙·摩尔，他当时最著名的作品是电视迷。
I'm assuming none of you have ever seen it. I have never seen the film. Sorry, the mini series. Sorry. I'm not saying any of those series. Well, David, how would we have seen it? I don't think it aired in the United States until... It actually, 2000s. No, it aired on masterpiece theater in 1990.
迷你剧《交通贩毒网》，Traffic带K字母的。你怎么会知道这个？Traffic在美国拼写是用C的，我们在那里生活了一辈子。在1989年，第四频道有一部英国迷你剧叫《Traffic》。你说话也这样吗，大卫？是的，这非常奇怪。听起来确实不太对劲。没有。后来大名鼎鼎地被史蒂文·索德伯格多年后改编成了电影《毒品网络》。
It was a very big deal. Well, how would you know that? I'm reading Wikipedia. I've never seen traffic. Despite having lived in England for a very... He's like, we're getting very close to something. I said it. I said it. What?
我猜你们谁也没看过。我从来没看过这部电影。抱歉，是那部迷你剧。抱歉。我没看过那些剧。好吧，大卫，我们怎么可能看过？我觉得它在美国播出要等到……其实是在2000年代。不，它是在1990年在PBS的“杰作剧场”播出的。
No, it's funny when you look at traffic because obviously the Soda Rig movie was about the cartels, right? And all that, you know, like it was about Mexican direct dealing and so on and so forth. But the British movie was about heroin dealers, I think, and it was about like Afghan and Pakistani growers and all that, right?
那当时反响很大。好吧，你怎么会知道这个？我在看维基百科。我从没看过《交通贩毒网》。尽管在英国住了很长一段时间……他就像是，我们越来越接近真相了。我说了。我说了。什么？
Like it's funny how it got transposed. Anyway, that thing was a big deal. So I guess Simon Moore gets kind of brought out to Hollywood where it's like, okay, buddy, what do you got? And he had written a movie called Under suspicion. He writes and turns into a movie, right? Did he direct it as well? He did direct it. Which I've never seen. Hilarious, Of course, Gene Hackman later started a different film called under suspicion. That is not what we're talking about. We're talking about the Liam Neeson, Laura Sanjiakomo, like kind of sex thriller, which I've never seen. It is funny. Sometimes when you like troll through IMDB, like that, and you find a movie
不，你看《交通贩毒网》时觉得很有趣，因为索德伯格的电影显然是关于贩毒集团的，对吧？所有这些，你知道的，就像它是关于墨西哥直接毒品交易等等。但英国的那部电影讲的是海洛因贩子，我想，它是关于阿富汗和巴基斯坦的种植者之类的，对吧？
where it just feels like four things pulled out of a hat. You're like, you're gonna be tri and you're slapping magnets on the board. You're like Liam Neeson, Fox, Laura, San Jacamo. Is that a movie? Yeah, right. It just sort of sounds like something that would have happened in 1991. Like, what are you gonna check?
这很有趣，它是怎么被转换成那样的。不管怎样，那部作品当时影响很大。所以我猜西蒙·摩尔被带到了好莱坞，就像是，好吧，老兄，你有什么点子？他曾写过一部名为《疑云重重》的电影。他写了并把它拍成了电影，对吧？他自己也当导演吗？他确实自己导演了。我从来没看过。太搞笑了，当然，吉恩·哈克曼后来主演了另一部也叫《疑云重重》的电影。那不是我们在谈论的。我们说的是连姆·尼森、劳拉·圣杰科莫那种类型的性感惊悚片，我从没看过。这很有趣。有时当你像这样在IMDB上闲逛，找到一部电影，
Like, that sounds bad. What do I call it? I don't know, under suspicion or something. So Simon Moore basically is like, I loved spaghetti westerns. I loved the, you know, Sergio Leone style western. I loved the Mexican standoffs. And I was just like, what if there was a movie that was all that cool? We cut everything else out.
感觉就像是从帽子里随机抽出了四个词。你会觉得，你简直在贴磁铁。就像连姆·尼森、福克斯、劳拉·圣杰科莫。这也是部电影？对，没错。这听起来就像是1991年会发生的事。像，你要查什么？
And it's just shoot out after shootout. The princess bride. A fact, you know, the kind of, yeah, take all the good stuff. So smart. It is quite smart. And he wanted to do it. Spit Gideost Western style. He was going to direct it himself.
听起来很烂。我叫它什么？我不知道，就叫《疑云重重》或者别的什么吧。所以西蒙·摩尔基本上就觉得，我喜欢意大利通心粉西部片。我喜欢塞尔乔·莱昂内风格的西部片。我喜欢墨西哥式的对峙。我当时就想，如果有一部电影全都是这些酷炫的元素，把其他所有东西都剪掉会怎么样？
He was going to like go out to Italy, you know, try and get like $4 million, right? From some studio. And basically what happened was eventually Sony, who had turned down the idea of the movie with him directing, calls him and they're like, we'll buy it for a lot of money. Like we will, you know, turn it all around. And he true, like I think he didn't even know what script they were talking about because he was so confused. Like I guess he had several scripts out.
然后就只剩下一场接一场的枪战。《公主新娘》。事实上，你知道的，那种，对，把所有好东西都拿来。太聪明了。确实挺聪明的。他想用意大利通心粉西部片的风格来拍。他打算自己当导演。
And then like the way he puts it is like it was a Frank Capra moment where you're, you know, like where he was like, I'm never going to have any success. I'm always going to be poor. And he got the phone call and like that was it. It was like all the money in the world and he was like his whole life changed. Sure, what happened?
他打算去意大利，你知道的，试着从某个制片厂弄到400万美元左右的资金，对吧？基本上发生的事情是，最终索尼公司拒绝了由他执导的想法，却打电话给他，说他们愿意花大钱买下它。就像他们会，你知道的，把整个项目盘活。而他真的，我猜他甚至不知道他们在谈论哪个剧本，因为他当时糊涂了。我猜他当时手里有几个不同的剧本。
Was that because Sharon Stone had found the script? Was Sony buying it to try to lower Sharon Stone to the Sharon Stone ask Sony to buy it? Yes, basically, I think the, and it sounds like classic Hollywood stuff, which is like, Sony calls him and they're like, we want the script and it sounds like classic Hollywood stuff, which is like, Sony calls him and they're like, we want the script, we'll pay top dollar. And he's like, what do you want to do with it? And he's like, we can't tell you.
然后他当时的描述就像是一个弗兰克·卡普拉式的时刻，你知道的，就像他当时觉得：我永远不会成功，我永远都会这么穷。然后他接到了电话，事情就这样成了。就像拥有了全世界所有的钱，他感觉自己整个人生都改变了。当然，后来怎么了？
Sony, you know, like, won't reveal any of that. And then eventually, they are like, so, yes, we're going to, this is going to be a star vehicle for Sharon Stone, and she wants Sam Remy to direct it. And Simon Moore was like, wait, that sounds great. I love Sam Raimi. Like, I think like they maybe assumed that he would be like, Sam Raimi, like, forget that. And he was like, Sharon Stone. Yeah, yeah. And he did the re-writes.
是因为莎朗·斯通发现了这个剧本吗？索尼买下它是为了吸引莎朗·斯通吗？莎朗·斯通要求索尼买下它的吗？是的，基本上，我觉得，这听起来像是经典的好莱坞桥段，那就是：索尼打电话给他，说他们想要这个剧本，愿意出最高价。然后他问，你们想拿它拍什么？他们说，我们不能告诉你。
Like, basically, they never took the script away. Like, uh, oh, no, I'm sorry. No, they did eventually take the script. There's the uh, oh, no, I'm sorry. No, there's the John sales thing. Right. Yeah, right. For a while, he's he's working on it for them. And then one day they fired him and they brought in John sales. And he beefed up the script to a two and a half hour movie. Jesus. Well, it's so funny that you mentioned Loanstar, which is John sales written and directed that came out at the same time, which is almost like if you could have a polar opposite Western from Quick and the Dead,
索尼，你知道的，什么都不肯透露。然后最终他们说：行吧，我们要把这个项目打造成莎朗·斯通的个人主演大片，而且她想让山姆·雷米来执导。西蒙·摩尔当时就想：等等，听起来太棒了。我喜欢山姆·雷米。就像，我猜他们可能以为他会说：山姆·雷米？算了吧。但他当时说：莎朗·斯通？好啊，好啊。然后他参与了重写。
it's probably Loan Star, which is a movie I fucking adore. Like I love it. That movie is fantastic. Phenomenal. But certainly it is not a pointbuster tin straight. Exactly. It is a slow and interesting film.
基本上，他们从来没有把剧本从他手里拿走。哦，不，抱歉。不，他们最后还是把剧本拿走了。这里有个，哦，不，抱歉。不，中间有个约翰·赛尔斯的环节。对。对。有一段时间，他一直在为他们修改剧本。然后有一天他们解雇了他，找来了约翰·赛尔斯。赛尔斯把剧本扩写成了一部两个半小时的电影。天哪。
And what's interesting about it from the way I read it is that I think they brought in sales because they were like, this thing might be a little too popcorny. Can he add some like serious Western gravitas to it? Right. And then he does that by adding an hour on to the runtime, which they're like, this thing is overblown now. So then they bring more back to rewrite sales as draft. And what he did was just hook out all the sales stuff and they went, great, you fixed it. So he was like, essentially what they made was the first script from before
不过，你提到《孤星》太有趣了，《孤星》是约翰·赛尔斯自编自导的电影，和这部片子同期上映。这几乎就像，如果你想找一部和《致命快感》截然相反的西部片，
they fired me. What a waste. I mean, it is like Griffin, you and I have heard stories like this. Absolutely. About Hollywood production where they ruin a script trying to fix it and then like turn back around to the like, hey, can you fix it? Right. And the answer isn't, hey, can we go back to your original draft? It's, hey, could you come back and change your change script so that we like it again? Like they, they, they, they can never admit the mistake enough that they're actually like, you know, well, let's go to draft eight instead of draft 47.
那大概就是《孤星》了，一部我他妈超级喜欢的电影。我太爱它了。那部电影棒极了。非凡之作。但它当然不是一部直白的爆米花大片。没错。这是一部缓慢而引人入胜的电影。
Draft eight was actually when it was good. Like they just have to keep going. They feel like it has to be an additive process. And especially in this day and age, you can just be like, go to my email from February. There's a draft that is dated. There's a story I remember hearing about an uncredited writer who I think he a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person.
从我的理解来看，它有趣的地方在于，我觉得他们找来赛尔斯是因为他们觉得：这部片子可能有点太爆米花商业化了。他能给它增加一些严肃的西部片厚重感吗？对。然后赛尔斯通过在片长上加了一个小时做到了这一点，制片厂一看就觉得：这片子现在搞得太臃肿了。所以他们又把摩尔找回来重写赛尔斯的初稿。而摩尔所做的就是把赛尔斯加的东西全删掉，制片厂看完说：太棒了，你改好了！所以基本上，他们最后拍出来的还是
I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person.
被解雇之前的那个最初版本剧本。真是浪费。我的意思是，格里芬，你和我都听过这样的故事。绝对的。关于好莱坞的制作过程，他们试图通过修改来修复一个剧本，结果却把剧本给毁了，然后又转过头来找原作者：“嘿，你能改回来吗？”对。而他们的回答绝不是：“嘿，我们能回到你最初的初稿吗？”而是：“嘿，你能回来把你们改过的剧本再改改，让我们重新满意吗？”就像他们，他们，他们永远无法彻底承认错误，并说：“你知道的，我们用第8稿而不是第47稿吧。”
第8稿其实挺好的。他们就是得一直折腾下去。他们觉得这必须是一个不断叠加的过程。而且特别是现在这个年代，你完全可以说：去翻翻我2月份的电子邮件吧。那里有一个标了日期的剧本。我记得曾听过这样一个故事，关于一个没有署名的编剧，我想他，他经历过这种事。
I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. I'm not a bad person. but they were just sort of like, this whole movie doesn't make sense. This is like, hey, what are you talking? She come every day and have so many notes on the scene. This and that, I want this and I want more of that. And at some point, this writer just cut like 90% of her dialogue out and was like, because the studio was just sort of like, she's becoming like a nightmare. We just like can't solve this.
但制片厂只是觉得：整部电影根本说不通。这就像是，嘿，你在说些什么？某位大明星每天来片场，对每一个场景都有无数的意见。这个那个，我要这个，我要那个。在某个节点，这位编剧直接删掉了她90%的台词，并心想：因为制片厂已经觉得，她简直成了一场噩梦，我们根本无法解决这个问题。
And she's holding everything up. Can you just like can't solve this. She's holding everything up. Can you just like cut her dialogue down? So she's got as little to do in every scene as possible. And he comes to set the next thing. He's like terrified. They're just gonna, Alba's gonna chew him out. She runs up and gives him a kiss and a hug. And she's like, finally, someone cracked my character.
而且她把所有进度都拖慢了。你能不能直接，无法解决这个问题。她把所有事情都耽误了。你能不能直接删减她的台词？让她在每个场景里需要做的事情尽可能少。结果第二天他来到片场。他吓坏了。以为自己会被大骂一顿。谁知她跑过来给了他一个亲吻和拥抱，并且说：“太好了，终于有人懂我的角色了。”
Not present. All they did was just remove. Wow. It's look, I'll say this is someone who writes professionally for living. Sometimes, you know, you'll turn into a story and you're like, I want this, this, this, this, and this. And you'll like make one change. And it'll be like, yeah, I love it.
什么都没做。他们只是把台词删掉了。哇。听着，作为一个以写作为生的人，我这么说吧。有时候，你知道的，你会交出一个故事，然后你会想：我想要这个、这个、这个、这个，还有这个。然后你做了一个改动。他们就会说：太棒了，我喜欢！
It looks great. Like, you know, like it's sometimes it's just some weird vibe thing. It's, it's, it's so bizarre. I don't know. It is a mystery of editing. I edit for most of my life is focused around editing, and it is weird how much of it is like we work on it, work on it, and the answer is, let's just cut that completely. I'm in more here says that a specific concern the studio had was the repetitive
看起来很完美。就像，你知道的，有时这纯粹是一种奇怪的氛围玄学。这太诡异了。我不知道。剪辑真的是个谜。我的大部分职业生涯都围绕着剪辑，而神奇的是，很多时候的过程都是：我们反复打磨、反复打磨，而最终的答案竟然是：把这部分彻底删掉吧。摩尔在这里说，制片厂的一个具体担忧是重复性。
nature of the movie. Like it's just gunfight after gunfight. Is this isn't this going to be boring? Ramy solves that. Yeah, like I guess I understand that concern in theory, but like it's mortal combat boring. No, we love this street fighter board. No, you mother fuckers. I mean, I think something that's very important is that you make every character, even if
电影的本质。就像这是一场又一场的枪战。这难道不会无聊吗？雷米解决了这个问题。对，我想我在理论上能理解那种担忧，但这就跟《真人快打》一样无聊吗？不，我们喜欢《街头霸王》这种。不，你们这群混蛋。我的意思是，我认为非常重要的一点是，你让每一个角色，哪怕是
they're a little character, really pop. Yeah. If it was just a bunch of anonymous villains who are getting shot off the screen because you know, Sharon Stone is not going to die until, you know, like, then sure, it, maybe that would be an issue. But Sam Remy is like, no, there will not be one face that you do not remember in this movie. Yeah.
他们是一个小角色，都非常出彩。是的。如果只是一堆无名的反派，在银幕上被击毙，因为你知道，莎朗·斯通直到最后才死，你知道的，那当然，也许这会是个问题。但萨姆·雷米会觉得，不，在这部电影里绝对不会有一张你看过就忘的脸。是的。
It reminds me, it's sort of like when we make radio, which is my only context for this, I don't do anything visual at all, is like, if you can read a script and it functions the same as the audio product, then you didn't actually make radio. You know, like, you shouldn't be able to read it and have it be the same. And so if you read it, you know, and that's what it's added with all visuals and all the tricks and all the cool things with it. It's just like, they made a true movie
这让我想起，这有点像我们制作广播节目——这是我对此唯一的认知，我完全不做任何视觉方面的东西——就像是，如果你能读一份剧本，而它的效果和音频产品完全一样，那你就根本没有做出广播节目。你知道的，就好像，你不应该光靠阅读就能达到和成品一样的效果。所以如果你去读它，你知道的，再加上所有的视觉效果、所有的把戏和所有那些酷炫的东西，这就好比，他们拍出了一部真正的电影
because if you read the script of it, you'd be like, well, that's dumb. You know, like that doesn't do enough, but it shouldn't, you know. Yeah, no, yeah, not only does he have sort of unique visual ideas for each gunfight and is, are those ideas uniquely paired to each gunfight, not arbitrarily applied for the sake of variety, right? But also, as you sort of said, David, it's like, we got to get through a lot of characters
因为如果你读它的剧本，你会觉得，好吧，这太蠢了。你知道，这表达得还不够，但它本就不该只靠剧本。是啊，不，是的，他不仅为每一场枪战设计了独特的视觉构思，而且这些构思与每一场枪战都是独特搭配的，而不是为了追求多样性而随意套用的，对吧？但正如你刚才所说，大卫，这就好比，我们必须在短时间内处理大量角色
fast. How do you characterize them fast? How do you cast great character actors? People that will be... It's got to have through a lot of characters fast. How do you characterize them fast? How do you cast great character actors? People that will be... That's good. Has a scar. Right, we'll be with them. Has a scar.
快。你怎么能快速塑造他们的性格？你怎么挑选伟大的性格演员？那些将要……必须在短时间内处理大量角色。你怎么快速塑造他们的性格？你怎么挑选伟大的性格演员？那些将要……这很好。脸上有一道疤。没错，我们会跟着他们。脸上有一道疤。
How do you style them specifically? Like all of this shit. It truly is though. Like I've been listening to so much, Dead Eyes, our friend Conor Ratless podcast and so much of that, is talking about the weird, when he talks all these other actors, when you lose parts or gain parts
你怎么专门为他们设计造型？就像所有这些屁话一样。不过确实如此。就像我听了那么多《Dead Eyes》——我们的朋友康纳·拉特利斯（Conor Ratliff）的播客，其中很大一部分都在谈论那种奇怪的事情，当他跟所有这些其他演员交流时，当你失去角色或得到角色时
or how people gain parts and the weird ass interests of casting. And part of it is like a movie like this where Sam Rainey has to make sure that every person looks distinctive, right? Has a different voice, has a different name, has a different gimmick. Is it an actor who we all know?
或者人们是如何得到角色的，以及选角中那些古怪的兴趣。其中一部分就像这样一部电影，萨姆·雷米必须确保每个人看起来都与众不同，对吧？有不同的声音，不同的名字，不同的噱头。他是我们都认识的演员吗？
So we got the shorthand of that's Keith David, or is it a guy who you make like be named Ratsby and you kind of give him fucking rap for that? Or like ace in his cards and it's it is so it is so Mike Tyson's punch out like I'm 10 years old and you're to my video game references or slightly over reference, but it's like it's very much just like this is the guy that does let me go dancing and so he has the name flamenco in his name you know like it's, it's right with one for one.
所以我们都知道那是基思·大卫（Keith David），还是一个被你取名为“拉特斯比”（Ratsby）的家伙，然后你还得给他配上一段该死的快板？或者像牌局里的王牌，这实在是太像《迈克·泰森的拳击突破》了，就好像我才10岁，而你抛出的那些电子游戏梗或者稍微有点过时的梗，但它非常像是这就是那个跳弗拉门戈舞的家伙，所以他的名字里就带个“弗拉门戈”，你知道的，这真的是一对一的还原。
But it's a very smart understanding of how what the audience is going to need to hold on to in order to be able to stick with this movie. Yeah. Because when it starts, it's like, wow, you're introducing a lot of characters in the first five minutes. You know, yeah. You're like, you track of this. Right.
但这是一种非常聪明的理解，知道观众需要依靠什么来支撑自己，从而能够坚持看完这部电影。是的。因为当它开始的时候，你会觉得，哇，你在前五分钟里引入了大量的角色。你知道的，是的。你会觉得，你能记住这些吗？对。
What complicated spider web narrative. Right. And then you're just like, yeah, they're like, you track of this right? What complicated spider web narrative right? And then you're just like, yeah, they're all going to be on chalkboard. We're just introducing me all now and then there's going to be a tournament one by one that will get shot down. So Sharon Stone, as we said, is the producer of this movie along with the star. She picks this movie because she likes the, you know, role that's been written here. It's unusual. She likes the idea of a woman with no name, right? She had, it guess been mogul enough on sliver and said that she like rolled over a lot there. Like she was trying not to step on toes or whatever. And that movie, you know, didn't do amazing. I mean, sliver's sort of like
多么复杂的蜘蛛网般的叙事啊。对。然后你就会想，是的，他们就像是，你能记住这些吗？多么复杂的蜘蛛网般的叙事啊，对吧？然后你就会想，好吧，他们最后都要被写在黑板上，我们现在把他们全都介绍出来，接着就会有一场比赛，他们会一个接一个地被枪杀。所以正如我们所说，莎朗·斯通是这部电影的制片人兼主演。她选择这部电影是因为她喜欢这里写这个角色，你知道的。很不寻常。她喜欢一个没有名字的女性的构想，对吧？她在《银色猎物》里大概已经足够大牌了，并表示她在那部电影里作出了很多让步。就像她尽量不去踩雷或者别的什么。而那部电影，你知道的，表现并不是惊艳。我的意思是，《银色猎物》有点像
a trash masterpiece, I guess of the early 90s, so there's sort of like a trash masterpiece. I guess of the early 90s, but it's not like a well-received film. No, and was certainly right, not well-respected. So this is her like, I am putting my foot down like movie, right? Like this is where she has all the, she's calling the shots and she's like, I'm not fucking this around. Like just because you like a big thing she cites is that someone, some people quote, who shall remain nameless, wanted her to wear a dress when she rides into town. And she was just like, we're not doing that.
90年代初的垃圾杰作，所以它有点像是垃圾杰作。我猜是90年代初的，但它并不是一部备受好评的电影。是的，而且当然对吧，并不受尊重。所以这就像是她的“我要态度强硬”的电影，对吧？就像在这里她掌握着所有主动权，她大权独揽，而且她觉得“我可不瞎胡闹”。就像她提到的一个大情况是，某个——某些名字就不点名了的人——希望她在骑马进城时穿裙子。而她直接就说，我们不这么做。
I am not going to be sexy in whatever way you, like whatever normal way you think for this movie. They actually shot a sexy that got removed. With her and Crow, I must have been, It's not clear. It's not sighted. Yeah. Where would that have happened? Yeah. Outside. Yeah. You always chained up to the phone. Wait, is that where we moved down? And of course, she got to pick her director and she picks Sam Raimi. And it's sort of a weird thing because Sam Raimi,
我才不会用你所认为的任何性感方式、任何你觉得拍这电影该有的那种常规方式来表现性感。他们其实拍过一段性感戏，后来被删掉了。她和克劳（Crow），那肯定是在——这并不清楚。没有被提及。是的。那会在哪儿发生呢？是的。在外面。是的。你总是被铐在电话旁边。等等，那是我们删掉的地方吗？当然，她可以挑选自己的导演，她选了萨姆·雷米。这其实挺奇怪的，因为萨姆·雷米，
I don't think he's ever directed a movie at this point that he didn't write, right? Like this is his first kind of four higher job. Uh, correct. And the main thing I read that she hired him off of was Army of Darkness. That was the Army of Darkness, right? And like, Sam Raimi, not only, this is the thing,
我觉得他在这之前从来没有导演过一部不是自己编剧的电影，对吧？就像这是他第一份算是“受雇执导”的工作。呃，没错。我读到的主要资料是，她看中他是因为《鬼玩人3：黑暗军团》。那是《黑暗军团》，对吧？而且，萨姆·雷米不仅——这就是重点，
had basically never worked with a big actor before because like Liam Neeson and Darkman is not like that famous at that point. No, it's pre fucking chinlers list like this is the first time he's working with established movie stars. And then everything else is like literally his friends like you know that it's almost what's most impressive to me about this movie is that like crime wave was obviously such a sort of knockback for him. But how well he transitions to like new budget level working with established movie stars in a new genre in a studio system with a script he didn't develop. And it's just seamless. It feels as personal as any of his earlier films and it feels as of a piece. seamless. It feels as personal as any of his earlier films and it feels as of a piece. Bruce Campbell, I think does actually have a tiny role in this movie, but he was, Remy wanted him to have a bigger role, one of the gunfighters, obviously, but he was shooting
基本上从来没有和知名大演员合作过，因为《黑暗侠》里的利亚姆·尼森当时还没那么出名。不，那是在《辛德ラー的名单》爆火之前，这是他第一次与成熟的电影明星合作。而他以前的其他作品基本上全都是他自己的朋友，你知道的，这几乎是我对这部电影最印象深刻的地方，那就是《犯罪浪潮》对他的打击显然非常大。但他却能如此出色地过渡到新的预算水平，在新的类型中，在制片厂体制下与成熟的电影明星合作，并使用一个并非由他开发的剧本。这一切简直天衣无缝。它感觉和他的任何早期电影一样充满个人风格，而且浑然一体。天衣无缝。它感觉和他的任何早期电影一样充满个人风格，而且浑然一体。布鲁斯·坎贝尔（Bruce Campbell）我想在这部电影里确实有一个小角色，但他当时——雷米原本想让他演一个更大的角色，当然是演其中一个枪手，但他当时在拍
Briscoe County, Jr. So he was on a good reason, at least. Yeah, it is a good reason. But he should have been one of these guys. He absolutely. I mean, he's any one of these roles is made for him, basically. Absolutely. I mean, he's any one of these roles is made for him, basically. And he's very nice in that kind of Ramyway where he's like, this is Simon Moore's thing. Like, it's a great script. 90% of it is him. Like, good job by him. I just wanted to do a good job, like putting it on screen. Like, he, I think he, as someone who had never directed another person script before, was very deferential to the script. What a manch.
《布里斯科·县历险记》。所以他至少是有个好理由的。对，这确实是个好理由。但他本该演这些家伙之一的。他绝对是的。我的意思是，这些角色随便哪个都是为他量身打造的。绝对是的。我的意思是，这些角色随便哪个都是为他量身打造的。而且他非常随和，表现出那种很“雷米式”的风格，他会说：这是西蒙·摩尔（Simon Moore）的东西。这是一部很棒的剧本。90%都是他的功劳。他做得很好。我只是想做好自己的本职工作，把它呈现到银幕上。就像他，我觉得作为一个从未导演过别人剧本的人，他对剧本表现出了极大的尊重。真是个男子汉。
He is a bit of a manch. He had a good time working with Sharon Stone. Guess who he had a tougher time working with. Jean Hackman. That's correct. Things were a little difficult. He says, Jean, very strict. Reminded me of an elementary school principal teacher called Mr. Little.
他确实挺有男子汉气概的。他跟莎朗·斯通合作得很愉快。猜猜他跟谁合作起来比较费劲？吉恩·哈克曼。没错。事情确实有点棘手。他说，吉恩非常严厉。让我想起了一个叫小先生的小学校长。
Just that was kind of cool actually. He was shooting Jaronimo. Sam Raimi goes to meet him and he says, Sam, tell me about the picture. At that point, I would shoot myself and piss my pants. If Jean had to just said, tell me about the picture. I would be like, no, I won't. I will commit suicide in front of you. By the way, he said that with a gun, a loaded gun cough to Sam Ramey's talk. Tell me about
光是这一点其实就挺酷的。他当时在拍《杰罗尼莫》。萨姆·雷米去见他，他对萨姆说：“萨姆，跟我讲讲这部电影。”要是在那个时候，我会当场自杀并吓得尿裤子。如果吉恩对我说“跟我讲讲这部电影”，我就会说，不，我不会说。我会在你面前自杀。顺便说一句，他说这话时，手里还拿着一把枪，一把顶着萨姆·雷米脑门的上膛的枪。跟我讲讲
the picture. So Sam says he talked for about 15 minutes and he was kind of just like, and then Hackman says, tell me about my character, Herod. Does he love the kid or not? Talking about the Capriote. Yeah. And Sam Ramey's like, well, of course he does. That's why he's so mean to him all the time. And Gene Hackman apparently nods and goes like, and then there's no further discussion because then he accepts the part. But I guess like that was Gene Hackman's sort of weird test was like, do you understand this character in the way I want you to or something? Do you do you know that Brian Cox succession thing? Either of you. He plays, I know he plays the role of Logan Roy and succession.
这部电影。于是萨姆说他讲了大约15分钟，哈克曼就只是那种态度，然后哈克曼说：“跟我讲讲我的角色——希罗德。他爱那个孩子吗？”指的是卡普里奥蒂（Capriotti）那个角色。是的。萨姆·雷米就回答：“呃，当然爱了。这就是为什么他对那孩子总是那么严厉。”吉恩·哈克曼显然点点头，说了句“哦”，然后就再也没有进一步的讨论了，因为他就这样接下了这个角色。但我想，这大概就是吉恩·哈克曼那种奇怪的测试吧，就像是——你对这个角色的理解和我要求的一样吗，或者诸如此类？你知道布赖恩·考克斯（Brian Cox）在《继承之战》里的那个梗吗？你们俩谁知道。他扮演的是——我知道他在《继承之战》里扮演洛根·罗伊（Logan Roy）。
He does. Okay, that's a little asking. It's a little trivia fact I found out I'm D.B. I didn't know if you know. Um, no, what's Jesse Armstrong when he was, uh, I get, maybe he had taken the part already. They were meeting with him. They hadn't started filming though, right?
他演了。好吧，这是一个冷知识。这是我在IMDb上发现的一个小冷知识。我不知道你们知不知道。呃，没有，杰西·阿姆斯特朗（Jesse Armstrong）当时，呃，我想，也许他当时已经接下这个角色了。他们正在跟他会面。不过他们还没开始拍摄，对吧？
And he said to Jesse Armstrong, like, I just have the one question for you. I can do all my work. I'm not going to pester you with shit. The one question I just need to know before I can play this part. And either answer is fine, but I need to know what your definitive answer is. Does he actually love the kids or not? Right. And I wonder how much the hackman thing was like a test versus him being that kind
他对杰西·阿姆斯特朗说：“我只有一个问题要问你。我能做好我所有的工作。我不会用屁大点事去烦你。我只需要在出演这个角色之前搞清楚这唯一的问题。无论哪个答案都行，但我需要知道你确切的答案是什么。他实际上爱那些孩子吗，还是不爱？”对。我在想，哈克曼的那次经历有多少是一次测试，而又有多少是因为他本来就是那种非常务实的演员，他会说：“我只需要你告诉我到底是哪种情况。然后我才能决定自己能不能搞懂该怎么演这家伙。”我确实觉得，没错，布赖恩·考克斯是个相当务实的演员。是的。在什么方面呢？因为很显然他拍了很多奇怪的烂片。对。我是说，对他的演技没有不敬的意思。因为我最喜欢的事情——我的意思是，我还没读过布赖恩·考克斯的书。我打算去读。但显然，你知道的，大家都听说那本书里写满了他是如何评价别人的，比如“哦，杰瑞米·艾恩斯（Jeremy Irons），真是个庸才。我讨厌他。”
of very practical actor where he's like, I just need you to tell me which it is. And I can tell you whether or not I can get my head around playing this guy. I do get the sense that right, Brian Cox is a fairly practical actor. Yeah. In what is it? Because obviously he does a lot of weird crap. Right. I mean, no offense to him. Because my favorite thing, I mean, I haven't read the Brian Cox book yet. I'm going to. But obviously, you know, everyone's heard that that book is him being like, you know, and Jeremy Irons, what a hack. I hate it.
而且他写了十个段落，全都是各种刻薄的评价。这就好比，布赖恩·考克斯，你演过大概40部没人听说过的电影，剧情大概是，你知道的，你在潜艇里对加里·奥德曼（Gary Oldman）大吼大叫，然后你带着一袋袋的钱大摇大摆地走掉。他们甚至都没把电影名字传下来。就像你，你拿到了一些铝制品，然后你可以去，你知道的，拿它去物物交换。就像对吧，你知道的，布赖恩·考克斯自己是个不折不扣的庸才，却又如此心安理得地去贬低所有人，这不是很奇怪吗？不过说真的，我超爱他。顺便说一句，这本书的最后一章，大卫，因为你刚才说你还没读过。还没读过。顺便说一句，这本书的最后一章，大卫，因为你刚才说你还没读过。还没读过。
And he's 10 paragraphs and all the shitty spin. And it's like Brian Cox, you've done like 40 movies that no one's ever heard of that are like, you know, you yelling at Gary Olman on a submarine and then you walk off with money in bags. They didn't even, they forgot to come down to the movie. Like you, you're handed some like aluminum that you can go, you know, barter with it. Like right, like, you know, it's just weird that Brian Cox is such a hack and yet also so comfortable calling everyone out. And I love him to be clear. The last chapter of the book by the way, David, because you said you haven't read it yet. Haven't read it yet. The last chapter of the book, by the way, David, because you said you haven't read it yet. Haven't read it yet.
那本书的最后一章，内容就是他点名批评你没读过这本书。他知道了。他知道了。他知道了。太经典了。他闲得蛋疼在搞什么狗屁播客。快读我的书吧，该死的。
The last chapter of that book is him calling you out for not having read the book. He knows. He knows. He knows. Classic. He's sitting around doing fucking podcast. Read my book, God damn it.
滚开。他真是个。吉恩·哈克曼——再说一次，这可能会让你们大跌眼镜——并不是特别喜欢萨姆·雷米的拍摄风格。非常技术化，镜头设置极其复杂，需要拍很多条。正如他所说，他在某种程度上是在摄影机里剪辑电影，这意味着他从来不让一个主镜头一气呵成地拍完。
Fuck off. He's fucking. He's so gene hacken.man, again, this may not, this may stun you guys to hear, was not super into ZamRamie's style of filming. Very technical, complicated setups, many takes. As he says, he cuts the film in the camera to some degree, meaning that he never lets a master scene run through.
所以我想这就是哈克曼在抱怨：“你为什么不直接把摄像机对准我，让我好好当我的吉恩·哈克曼呢？”而萨姆·雷米则说：“不，不，不，不，不，我想先拍这个，然后我想拍那个，然后，你知道的，我懂的，我，我，必须严格按照这个来，否则制片厂就不会，
So I guess that's Hacman saying, like, why don't you just point the camera at me and let me be Gene fucking Hacman? And Sam Raimi's like, no, no, no, no, no, I want to do this and then I want to do this and then, you know, like, I know, I, I, I, it has to be exactly this way, or else the studio's gonna not like,
你知道的，让我这么拍，对吧？”所以，我敢肯定他真的很让人抓狂，是的。这也是为什么我认为——听着，我大致上不知道他对演员的技术是什么样的，但我确实觉得萨姆·雷米在如何让电影里的表演变得出色这方面没有得到足够的赞誉，考虑到他的电影制作风格对演员的表演来说有多么困难。
you know, let me do it, right? You know, so I'm sure he got on his nerves, yes. It is a reason why I think, I, I, look, I don't know what his technique is with actors by and large, but I do think Sam Raimi doesn't get enough credit for how good the performances are in his movies, considering how difficult his style of filmmaking is for performances.
而且我认为部分原因在于他选角眼光极佳，即便他跟哈克曼相处得并不融洽，哈克曼在片中的表演也实在是太棒了，尤其是——我们一会儿会聊到。但在与那个孩子进行枪战之后的那个时刻，他的表演方式简直太迷人了。那可不是哈克曼从他的演艺生涯里随便拿出一个以前用过的现成场景来应付。你知道吗？是的，我的意思是，那一幕被认为是电影中最好的一幕。我觉得这部电影里有很多好戏。我可以读一下这段吗？你刚才提到的大卫，那种想象和
And I think part of that is he casts very well and even if he wasn't getting along well with Hackman, Hackman is so fucking good in this and especially we'll get to it. But the moment after the shootout with the kid, he plays that in such a fascinating way. That's not Hackman like pulling a scene off of the shelf that he's done before. You know? Yeah, I mean, that's seen as the best scene in the movie. I think I'm just a lot of good scenes of this movie. Can I read this thing? You were talking about David, the terror of imagining living with
吉恩·哈克曼一起生活作为挣扎求生的演员的恐惧。我刚好在看他的维基百科。所以在那个时期，他和达斯汀·霍夫曼（Hoffman）以及罗伯特·杜瓦尔（De Niro）合租时，他的主要工作之一就是在时代广场的一家霍华德约翰逊餐厅（Howard Johnson）打工。所以如果你觉得当他的室友很吓人，想象一下不得不在一家该死的餐厅里向吉恩·哈克曼点冰淇淋。但他在这家餐厅服务过的一位顾客，以前曾是他在帕萨迪纳剧场（Pasadena Playhouse）的一位导师，那人说他在霍华德约翰逊打工就是他一事无成的证据。
Jean Hackman as a struggling actor. I'm just on his Wikipedia. So his one of his main jobs at that period of time living with a Hoffman in DeVal was that he worked at a Howard Johnson and Times Square. So if you think it's scary to be his roommate, imagine having to order ice cream from Jean Hackman at a fucking diner. But he, one of the people he served at that restaurant was previously one of his instructors at the Pasadena Playhouse who said that him working at Howard Johnson was proof that he wouldn't amount
嗯，真惨。真惨。哇。天哪。是的。然后是海军陆战队员，他曾经是一名海军陆战队员。他16岁就参军加入了海军陆战队。他谎报了年龄。好吧，他当时大概看起来像47岁。
to anything. Hmm, damn. Damn. Wow. Jesus. Yes. And then a marine, he had been a marine. He enlisted the Marines when he was 16 years old. He lied about his age. Well, he probably looked 47.
绝对是的。这就是他不得不撒谎的原因吗？是的，他在电影里才24岁。但他16岁时谎报年龄参军，在海军陆战队当了四年战地无线电操作员，对吧？所以他经历了帕萨迪纳剧场的那个人对他说“你一事无成”，然后又过了一两年，他在当门童，而他以前的海军陆战队军官、他以前的直属海军陆战队军官说：“哈克曼，你这个可悲的混蛋。”这里有一段哈克曼的话，他谈到了当时每个人是如何看不起他的
Absolutely. Is that the thing he had to lie? Yeah, he's 24 in this movie. But he lied about his age at 16 to enlist in the Marine Corps for four years as a field radio operator, right? So he's had this Pasadena playhouse guy tell him you're not gonna amount to anything and then a year or two later He's working as a door man and the former Marine officer his former commanding Marine officer said officer, his former commanding marine officer said, Hacman, you're a sorry son of a bitch. And there's this quote from Hacman here where he talks about how much everyone dismissed
那时候。他说，这更多的是一场心理战，因为我不会让那些混蛋把我压垮。我坚信自己会不惜一切代价找到一份工作。这就像是我与他们的对抗。而且不知何故，不幸的是，我至今仍有这种感觉。但我觉得如果你真的对表演感兴趣，你内心深处其实会享受这种挣扎。这就像是一种苦行，你被训练去做这项工作，但没有人愿意让你做。所以你其实有点神经质。你对别人撒谎，你作弊，
him at that time. And he said, it was more psychological warfare because I wasn't going to let those fuckers get me down. I insisted with myself that I would continue to do whatever took to get a job. It was like me against them. And in some way, unfortunately, I still feel that way. But I think if you're really interested in acting, there is a part of you that relishes the struggle. It's an arctic in the way that you're trained to do this work and nobody will let you do it. So you're a little bit nuts. You lie to people, you cheat,
你为了得到一次试镜机会、为了得到一份工作不择手段。这确实让人感觉这就是吉恩·哈克曼在其整个职业生涯中一直保持的那种干劲，直到他退休为止。就像他对他合作过的所有人始终都带着一种对抗的姿态。倒不是说虐待，你知道吗？这就是我在想的时候想到的，我没听到过太多关于他的坏话，那就是这种对抗从未上升到虐待的程度。感觉他只是那种典型的艺术家式的吓人。是的，他就是一直在跟所有人抬杠，无时无刻不在抬杠。是的。
you do whatever it takes to get an audition, you get a job. It does feel like that is the energy Gene Hackman carried with him throughout his entire career until he retired. Like, he was just sort of adversarial to everyone he worked with. Not like abusive, you know? That's what I think when I was thinking that I hadn't heard much bad about him, is like, it never went to a level of abuse. It seems like he's the typical kind of artist style scare. Yeah, he was just constantly locking horns with everyone all the time. Yeah.
你为了得到试镜机会不择手段，然后找到了一份工作。吉恩·哈克曼在他整个职业生涯直到退休，似乎都一直带着这种能量。就像，他对身边的每个人都有点对立情绪。也不是说虐待，你知道吗？这就是我之前在想我没怎么听过他的坏话时所想的，也就是，它从未达到虐待的程度。他看起来像是那种典型的艺术家风格的让人敬畏的人。是的，他只是不断地与所有人针锋相对。是的。
And it's one of the reasons he's like, when the rare times he does interviews, and very clear on why he doesn't want to come out of retirement, he's like, I'm a lot happier now. I finally let go of all that shit. Yeah, is this the movie where Remy kind of puts on the suit and does stuff like this? Is this him trying to like, like, I wear fancy clothes to basically as my armor and my costume? Yeah, yeah, yeah, confidence. Like I got it, you know. And, and here to four, you know, he had been like you said, just mainly working with his friends. Maybe that wasn't required, but like do you know when he made that transition to kind of wearing a suit all the time?
这也是为什么他在极少数接受采访时，明确表示不想复出的原因之一，他说，我现在幸福多了。我终于放下了那些破事。对，这就是雷米穿上西装做这种事的电影吗？这是他在尝试像，我穿华服基本上是作为我的盔甲和戏服吗？对，对，对，自信。就像我能搞定，你知道的。而且在此之前，正如你所说，他主要是在和朋友们合作。也许那并不是必需的，但是你知道他是什么时候开始过渡到整天穿西装的吗？
I don't, although I know of course that, that is his onset by right, is he dresses up, right? Right, right, right, Chris? Yeah, I would not be surprised if this was the moment. And if it isn't, it still does feel like this is the moment where symbolically the shift happens. Well, this, that's what I, the my psychology is, this is the moment I would dress up. If I was asking Gene Hackman to sit there while I rearranged the cameras would be the moment when I would be sure I was wearing this Hackman to sit there while I rearranged the cameras would be the moment when I would be sure I was wearing this to when I asked him respectfully to do this. JJ our researcher found this. He posted this on Twitter recently. I imagine it was in doing
我不清楚，但我当然知道那是他拍摄时的标志，对吧，他会盛装打扮，对吧？对，对，对，克里斯？是的，如果这就是那个时刻，我一点也不会感到意外。如果不是，它依然给人一种象征性转变发生的感觉。这就是我的心理所想，如果我让吉恩·哈克曼坐在那里，而我却在重新调整摄像机，这就是我会确保自己穿着这身衣服的时刻。当我对吉恩·哈克曼说，请坐在那儿等我调整摄像机时，这就是我会确保自己穿着这身衣服的时刻。我们的研究员JJ发现了这个。他最近把它发到了推特上。我猜这是在为
research for the show, but I don't know what specific episode. Do you see this quote, David? Which one? I don't know where this interview is from, but they said to Rainy, he just did the screen grab of this question and answer. You always wear a suit on set. Rumor says it's a nod to I don't know where this interview is from, but they said to Rainey, he just did the screen grab of this question and answer. You always wear a suit on set. Rumor says it's a nod to Hitchcock. And he said, although I have a tremendous amount of respect for Alfred Hitchcock, who is the true master of horror and the father of such modern filmmaking technique, I don't
节目做研究时找到的，但我不知道具体是哪一集。你看到这段话了吗，大卫？哪一段？我不知道这个采访是从哪来的，但他们问雷米，他刚刚截了这段问答的图。你在片场总是穿西装。有传言说这是在向我不知道这个采访是从哪来的，但他们问雷米，他刚刚截了这段问答的图。你在片场总是穿西装。有传言说这是在向希区柯克致敬。而他说，虽然我对阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克怀有极大的敬意，他真正的恐怖片大师，也是现代电影制作技术的先驱，但我其实
actually wear a suit as a tribute to him. Believe it or not, I wear a suit and tie as a sign of respect to the casting crew. I like a very serious and well-ordered film set. For me, it's the best way to work, and out of that order, I like to get a tremendous amount of creativity. At the same time, the old masters used to dress in a very formal manner on set, and I always thought it was super cool. And then in a line that might have been gust-written by my father, the end of this answer is Sam Remy saying,
并不是为了向他致敬才穿西装的。信不信由你，我穿西装打领带，是对演员和剧组的一种尊重。我喜欢非常严肃且井然有序的电影片场。对我来说，这是最好的工作方式，而在这种秩序之中，我能迸发出极大的创造力。与此同时，老一辈大师在片场总是穿着非常正式，我一直觉得这酷毙了。接着，有一句可能是我父亲代笔的话，这个回答的结尾是萨姆·雷米说：
nowadays, everyone's got the nose rings and the colored hair. So for me, to wear the suit and tie is a different way to go. Uh, Sam Raimi is not here for the nose rings. My father always talks about the Mohawk hairdo and only refers to it by that full name. The definite article. Look, the no, the Mohawk hairdo and the thing in the nose is what my dad always says. I mean, there's this story that Bruce Campbell relates because I feel like Sam Remy doesn't talk a lot of shit, right? Like Sam Remy strikes me as someone who's not going to be a gentleman. Gene Hackman was a huge pain in the ass, but apparently Sam had a very specific setup. He wanted Gene to do six different things and Gene looked at him and said, I'm not doing any of that.
现在每个人都戴着鼻环、染着彩色头发。所以对我来说，穿西装打领带是一种不同的选择。呃，萨姆·雷米可不赞同鼻环。我父亲总是谈论莫西干发型，而且只用那个全称来称呼它。那个定冠词。你看，不，莫西干发型和鼻环上的东西，这就是我爸常说的话。我是说，有这样一个布鲁斯·坎贝尔讲述的故事，因为我觉得萨姆·雷米不怎么说别人的坏话，对吧？萨姆·雷米给我的印象是一个不会当面失礼的人。吉恩·哈克曼当时是个极大的麻烦，但显然萨姆有非常具体的安排。他想让吉恩做六件不同的事情，而吉恩看着他说，我什么都不会做。
He wanted Jean to do six different things. And Jean looked at him and said, I'm not doing any of that. Hahaha. Hahaha. And Sam had to talk to him for like 15 minutes about the character to be like, this is why I want you to tip your hat, to sit in the chair, to say this like, you know,
他想让吉恩做六件不同的事情。而吉恩看着他说，我什么都不会做。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。然后萨姆不得不花大约15分钟跟他讲这个角色，解释说，这就是为什么我希望你点一下帽子，坐在椅子上，说出这样的话，你知道的，
like, you know, he had to like, talk him all the way through it. Because clearly Jean happened was like, I'm not your action figure, you fucker, right? Or whatever it is. Right. But like with Campbell not your action figure you fucker right or whatever it is. Right, but like with Campbell was his action figure. You know, he like he had this big goofy friend who was also a producer who was down for anything and he could just manipulate into a billion takes
就像，你知道的，他不得不一直给他做思想工作。因为很显然吉恩·哈克曼当时的心态是：我可不是你的动作玩偶，你这个混蛋，对吧？诸如此类。没错。但像坎贝尔就是他的动作玩偶。你知道的，他身边有这么一个又高大又滑稽的朋友，对方同时也是个制片人，什么都愿意配合，他可以独自一人把对方当工具人拍上几十亿条镜头。
by himself. It's just I just like every single performance in this movie is good and he gets people at very different stages in their careers. Well speaking of when, when are we going to talk about Russell Crowe? Because this is his first American movie, yeah. About to pivot to Russell Crowe, who, I mean, I feel like I've lavish some praise on Russell Crowe on this. You're a fan. Yes. Have we covered a lot of Russell Crowe films? Insider. Insider, obviously, really compelling, wonderful performance. But is there another one? That's a good question. I feel like we talk about him a lot.
这部电影里的每一个表演都非常精彩，而且他找来的是处于演员生涯不同阶段的人。说到这个，我们什么时候聊聊罗素·克劳？因为这是他的第一部美国电影，对吧。马上就要转到罗素·克劳了，对于他，我的赞美可以说是毫不吝啬。你是他的粉丝。是的。我们聊过很多罗素·克劳的电影吗？《惊爆内幕》。《惊爆内幕》，当然，非常引人入胜，精彩的表演。但还有别的吗？这是个好问题。我觉得我们经常聊到他。
We're obviously developing a live action, Donkey Kong movie with him, but that might be the only proper Russell Crowe film we've covered. Well, in addition to Rainy, the thing I was most excited about when I came to this movie was Russell Crowe, because I had seen him in Australian movies.
我们显然正在用他开发一部真人版《大金刚》电影，但那可能是我们聊过的唯一一部正经的罗素·克劳电影了。除了雷米，我拍这部电影时最兴奋的事情就是罗素·克劳，因为我以前看过他在澳大利亚拍的电影。
You did you see Rompers, Tomper? That was a big, I saw R Rampersomper? That was a big deal. Which was a big deal. But this other movie, another one that I hope people find and love, is this movie called Proof from 1991. Proof is a wonderful, yes. A Jocelyn Warehouse film. It is so good, and he plays just a dude that is not very notable in any way, except for he is so charismatic that he makes this very ordinary guy, very compelling.
你看过《罗马本色》吗？那是一部大，我看过《罗马本色》吗？那是一部大制作。那是一部很重要的作品。但另一部电影，也是我希望人们能发现并爱上的作品，是1991年上映的《证明》。《证明》是一部精彩的电影，没错。乔斯林·莫尔豪斯的电影。太棒了，他在里面扮演一个各方面都不太起眼的小伙子，除了他极具个人魅力，能把这样一个极其普通的人物演绎得十分引人入胜。
And between that and Rompershopper, I was like, this is the guy. I was like, I was super convinced on him really early on. Well, guess who else was convinced? Sure and still. Sharon Stump. Fucking good ass taste. Because guess who Sam Raimi wanted for this role. Oh, I don't know. Liam Neeson, who he had just worked with. Obviously. Now at this point, Liam Neeson is coming off as Shinler's list. I don't know if
从那部片子到《罗马本色》，我就觉得，就是这个人了。我当时真的很早就被他深深折服了。好吧，你猜还有谁也被折服了？当然到现在也是。莎朗·斯通。真他妈的好品味。因为你猜萨姆·雷米在这个角色上最开始想要谁。哦，我不知道。利亚姆·尼森，他刚刚和对方合作过。理所当然。现在这个时候，利亚姆·尼森正凭借《辛德勒的名单》大红大紫。我不知道
Liam Neeson would want to do this. He would be make total sense for it. Like totally big him, you know, imposing. But Sharon Stone had seen Rompers, don't her. She thought he was charismatic, attractive, talentless, talented, not talentless. I was gonna say, what a nag talented and fearless, which I do feel like is fairly crucial. Crowhead edition for a small role, he'd edition for one of the, you know, many gunslingers, I guess. And Sharon Stone basically was like, you have to audition for the lead role for court. And I basically talked Sam Remy into it. Like, you know, and I, I, this is not even a, probably not even a top 10 realsal crowd performance.
利亚姆·尼森愿不愿意演这个。这对他来说完全合情合理。完全符合他的形象，你知道的，气势逼人。但莎朗·斯通看过《罗马本色》。她觉得罗素·克劳充满魅力、有吸引力、有才华，不是没有才华。我本想说，真是一个有才华又无畏的人，我觉得这确实相当关键。克劳为了一个小角色去试镜，他为众多神枪手中的一个进行了试镜，我猜是这样。而莎朗·斯通基本上是说：你必须为男主角科特去试镜。她基本上说服了萨姆·雷米。你知道的，而且，这甚至可能都不是罗素·克劳十佳表演之一。
He's given a lot of wonderful performances. But he really fucking magnificent in this movie. And he is so hot. It is crazy. How good he looks. I think it's one of his best. Maybe it's maybe it is. It's sort of like his subtlety that I, you know, his bluster that sort of comes on later is like a is the part of a school I don't enjoy as much. You know, I mean, can bless you. But his, all over the room. He can throw a fucking phone at your head. But his ability to play gentle and tough, and kind of an addict, and kind of, you like, he's basically a violent addict, that's recovering.
他奉献过许多精彩的表演。但他在电影里的表现真的是他妈的太棒了。而且他太性感了，简直疯狂。他的外形状态太好了。我认为这是他最好的表演之一。也许就是，也许真的是。这有点像他的那种内敛，我，你知道的，他后来那种张扬的做派是我不太喜欢的部分。你知道的，我是说，上帝保佑你。但是他在片中，在房间里走来走去。他可以把一部该死的电话砸到你头上。但他既能演温柔也能演强硬，还带着点瘾君子的特质，某种程度上，你喜欢他，他基本上是一个正在戒毒的暴力成瘾者。
And for him to do that and be, I, this might be my favorite role of his ever. That's the obviously look. I mean, it's not just disgusting. Listen, David. Go ahead, go ahead. I may be a notorious soft boy. And I don't want to fucking become Eddie Redmain here, but I do think there is a fragility in this performance that I don't know I've ever seen
能把这个角色演得如此到位，这可能是我有史以来最喜欢的他的角色。那当然很显眼。听着，大卫。说吧，说吧。我可能是一个臭名昭著的软弱男孩。我可不想在这里变成埃迪·雷德梅恩，但我确实认为这种表演中有一种脆弱感，我不知道我是否曾在
cro capture as well. And the way that is cut with his natural sort of brutish animalistic intensity is really fascinating. It's a, I don't think he is ever called upon to pull up this same amount of energy, the same kind of energy rather. It's a different energy. And also like, when you capture him here and something that you get is this infinite possibilities with him. You just see that all the movie stars he could possibly be and just over time, you watch them narrow and those walls close off and he chooses a path
克劳身上看到过如此出色的捕捉。而这种脆弱感与他天生那种粗野、动物般的张力交织在一起，真的非常迷人。这是一个，我觉得他再也没有被要求展现出同等数量的能量，或者说同等类型的能量。这是一种不同的能量。而且，当你在这里捕捉到他时，你会发现他身上有着无限的可能性。你只看到他未来可能成为的所有电影明星的模样，随着时间的推移，你看着这些可能性逐渐缩小，道路逐渐封死，他最终选择了一条路，
and he becomes more of a Russell Crowe as a person. And in this one, I just see this like amazing performance and this infinite potential and it sort of delights me when I see it. It's so good. I'm regretting the top 10 comment. I think I might revise it to a top five because I'm just looking at his filmography right now because my favorite Russell Crowe performance
他作为一个人的“罗素·克劳”特质变得更加浓厚。而在这一部里，我只看到了这种惊艳的表演和无限的潜力，每当我看到它时，我都感到十分欣喜。太棒了。我开始后悔刚才说的那句十佳了。我想我可能会把它修正为前五，因为我刚刚看了看他的电影作品表，因为我最喜欢的罗素·克劳表演
is not mastering. Oh, what? That's probably my favorite Russell Crowe movie. That's probably what, you know, but LA Confidential is my favorite. Oh, sure. That's like one of my favorite performances of all time. Yeah. And that's right after this, right?
并不是……哦，什么？那可能是我的最喜欢的罗素·克劳电影。那可能是什么，你知道的，但《洛城机密》才是我的最爱。哦，当然。那绝对是我有史以来最喜欢的表演之一。对。那就在这部之后拍的，对吧？
Yeah, it's like a virtuosity. Virtuosity. It's basically his, for his next performance in a serious movie because God bless virtuosity, which is a very bananas piece of 90s, you know, Hollywood crap. And he's, he is really good at it. And he's like, you know, he pops really hard at it, but that's like a, you know, a real serious movie or whatever. You know, yes, so Ellie confidential. This looks good. Virtuosity. You haven't seen virtuosity. 6.77 the ultimate killing machine. Correct. He is a PR, a Malgum of every serial killer, Ben. Ben, do you know what it stands for?
对，这简直是一种炉火纯青的演技。炉火纯青。这基本上是，他随后在一部正经电影里的表演，因为上帝保佑《时空骇客》，那是部非常荒谬的90年代好莱坞烂片。他在里面的表现其实真的很不错。他在里面真的很卖力，但那毕竟是一部真正的正经电影之类的。你知道的，没错，所以是《洛城机密》。这看起来不错。《时空骇客》。你没看过《时空骇客》。6.77分的终极杀人机器。没错。他是所有连环杀手的结合体，本。本，你知道它代表什么吗？
No. Sadistic, intelligent, dangerous. That would be a... I got a guess. Hands on this shit. I'll bring it over, Ben. I've got it, Humbly Ray. I'll bring it to you.
不知道。虐待狂、高智商、危险。那将会是一个……我来猜一个。把这些东西拿过来。我把它拿过来，本。我拿到了，虚心的雷。我把它拿给你。
Perfect. That's another movie I saw on the theater I was very excited for that movie But what I would like to be you're all the pros yeah look but but why does my favorite Crow performance ever that's one of my favorite you know characters ever I love that movie And that is true I would put maybe that one is higher than this one but I just find this one so I would put maybe that one is higher than this one, but I just find this one so, he just has a different type of appeal. And yeah, no, and that I just, I find it really stunning. What's interesting, you sang Rhyme the thing about, like you see all the different ways he could have gone.
完美。那是另一部我在电影院看过的电影，当时我为那部电影感到非常兴奋。但我想成为你的所有优点，对，看，但是，为什么我最喜欢的克劳表演，那是你最喜欢的角色之一，我太爱那部电影了。这倒也是，我可能会把那部排得比这部高，但我只是觉得这部，我会把那部排得比这部高，但我只是觉得这部，他有一种不同类型的吸引力。对，不，而且我，我觉得这真的很惊艳。有趣的是，你顺着雷米的话说，就像你能看到他本可以走的所有不同道路。
In this, you see how he could have become a little more like Liam Neeson. Like I think Liam Neeson probably had a little too much gravitas to pull this off at this point and also was probably a little too known and is a little bit too much of a physical presence. There's something about the fact that Russell Crowe in this movie still even watching it from a modern perspective. You can't really tell if that violence is inside of him or not. You know, there's an actual tension to how much this guy seems to be fighting this stuff. Totally.
在这部电影里，你可以看到他本可以变得更像利亚姆·尼森。我觉得利亚姆·尼森当时可能有着过多的威严来驾驭这个角色，而且当时可能名气太大了一点，身体气场也太强了一些。而罗素·克劳在这部电影里的特别之处在于，即使从现代的角度来看。你也很难看出那种暴力究竟是不是深藏在他内心深处。你知道的，这个家伙似乎一直在跟体内的这种倾向做斗争，这其中存在着一种真实的张力。完全赞同。
Can I fill out my top five? I'm now flanking this. I think it's like a teleconfinancial. I do think I would put Master and Commander second. That performance is so beautiful. Then I guess I would have the insider. Those are sort of, right, that's kind of like your Holy Trinity of Crow. And then I, you guys are talking about tenderness.
我能凑齐我的前五名吗？我现在正在权衡。我觉得应该是像《洛城机密》。我觉得我会把《怒海争锋》排在第二。那个表演太优美了。然后我猜我会把《惊爆内幕》放进去。这些差不多是，对，这就好比是你的克劳圣三位一体。然后我，你们刚才在谈论温柔。
Like the movie is, I don't like the movie that much. I know what you're gonna say. I do think his performance in a beautiful mind is like that. He's tapped into that. You know what I did know? Did you think I was gonna say that? No. I thought you were gonna say boy erased. Boy erased is we talked about it. Yeah, I like I like that performance that movie did very little for me. Yes
就像那部电影，我其实没那么喜欢那部电影。我知道你要说什么。我确实觉得他在《美丽心灵》里的表演就是那种感觉。他触及了那种特质。你知道我当时想到了吗？你以为我要说那个吗？没有。我还以为你要说《被遗忘的男孩》。《被遗忘的男孩》我们聊过。对，我喜欢那个表演，但那部电影对我的触动微乎其微。是的。
He's he looks so strange in the movie that it's almost As you said his eyeballs are fat like Do you remember that line Griffith? no, I do it on me. And I sleep, yeah. Nice guys is this sort of a derailleur to crow that people forget about. That's a really great performance. Great.
他在电影里看起来是如此奇怪，以至于几乎正如你所说，他的眼珠子鼓鼓的，就像……你还记得那句台词吗，格里菲斯？不，我懂我懂。还有《耐撕侦探》，这是人们常常忽略的克劳的一部另类之作。那真的是一次伟大的表演。太棒了。
Obviously, Gladiator is a movie star performance like no other like that, you know, that shit is for real. I like Gladiator Master Commander less than you. Roode, I know. I would, I'm with you. I like Gladiator, Master Commander, less than you. Roode, I know. I would. I'm with you. I like Master Commander better. I did not like Gladiator when I started the Ditter.
很显然，《角斗士》是一场独一无二的巨星级表演，你知道的，那玩意儿是动真格的。比起你们，我其实没那么喜欢《角斗士》和《怒海争锋》。鲁德，我懂。我跟你一样。我其实更喜欢《怒海争锋》。我刚看开头时并不喜欢《角斗士》。
Plenty ofyer doesn't do anything. I did nothing for me. And I've given it a few more tries since then. It doesn't work for me. It's kind of the point where I kind of got off the Russell Crowe train. Yeah. That's what people got on. That's what the train was around.
《角斗士》什么也没讲。对我毫无触动。从那以后我又试着看了好几次。它就是对我没用。那差不多是我开始对罗素·克劳路转粉的节点。对。那是人们开始粉他的起点。
I know that's what's so weird about that. It's so weird. It's all on the roof. And I would take, take you know take him or leave him in certain places like I think for for example Nice guys I think is like the purpose of him in a certain way right and But but he never like Sold a movie for me the same way again after no no I think for me It's I probably say insiders the best performance and then then I think this LA Confidential, nice guys. And I'm trying to think what my fifth would be.
我知道，这才是最奇怪的地方。太奇怪了。全在鲁德身上。而且在某些地方我对他是可有可无，比如我认为《耐撕侦探》在某种程度上展示了他的用途，对吧？但他再也没有像以前那样让我为一部电影疯狂买单了，没有，没有。我觉得对我来说，我可能会说《惊爆内幕》是最好的表演，然后是《洛城机密》和《耐撕侦探》。我在想要把哪部排在第五。
Well, I mean, there's some others good pro performances for not showing out three ten to you. He is actually fantastic in that. He is fantastic in that. I think he's good in man of steel that I wouldn't call that. But he's very good. He's a lot of fun. He played two characters in a little film called The Mummy,
好吧，我是说，还有其他一些不错的表演，比如《决战3:10》。他在那里的表现实际上好极了。他在那里的表现好极了。我觉得他在《钢铁之躯》里表现不错，但我不会把那称作……不过他真的很棒。他玩得很开心。他在一部叫《新木乃伊》的小成本电影里演了两个角色，
Dr. Jekyll, and wait a second. What's this? What's it's coming into focus? Hold on, just a minute. Mr. Hyde. David is holding a jeweler's loop up to his computer screen. I love, I love Rosalkova. And then absolutely, you know,
杰基尔博士，等等。这是什么？这是怎么回事？稍等一会儿。海德先生。大卫正拿着一个珠宝放大镜贴着他的电脑屏幕。我喜欢，我喜欢罗素·克劳。然后绝对地，你知道的，
Rompress, Tompour is an incredible performance. If anyone has not seen that film, Proof is a really good movie. That Hugo Weaving is also in that film and he's also really good. That's a gem that people should find. And it's another movie where they made another movie called Proof.
《罗马本色》是一场不可思议的表演。如果有人还没看过那部电影，《证明》真的是一部很好的电影。雨果·维文也在那部电影里，而且他也演得很好。那是人们应该去发掘的一颗遗珠。而且这是另一部他们拍过同名电影的作品，那部叫《证明》的电影。
So yeah, the, the, the, the, the math play movie, that bad movie, desemplate. And in the other movie, so small, that nobody cared. He's also, it was also an Australian movie called The Some of Us, where he plays a gay character that was sort of, you know, for 1994, like, you know, a fairly adventurous role,
所以，是的，那部关于数学游戏的电影，那部烂片，简直没法看。而在另一部电影里，制作非常小，以至于没人关心。里面还有一部澳大利亚电影叫《我们俩》，他在其中扮演一个同性恋角色，在1994年的时候，这算是一个相当具有冒险精神的角色，
like, you know, he's pretty good in that too, thinking of his pre-ollywood stuff. He guys don't like Gladiator. Gladiators based on a painting. We got to cover Gladiator for that story alone. It's just fucking Ridley Scott seeing a painting of a Gladiator batch and being like, Gladiator, we gotta do it.
你知道的，他在那部里也演得相当不错，考虑到这是他进好莱坞之前的作品。你们居然不喜欢《角斗士》。《角斗士》是根据一幅画改编的。我们必须为了这个故事去聊聊《角斗士》。这纯粹是因为雷德利·斯科特看到了一幅角斗士战斗的画，然后就说：角斗士，我们必须得拍这个。
This is gonna be great. Can I just run through what Russell Crowe has on deck? Sure. Cause it's a pretty exciting line of actual. He's working, the man works. The man's working, okay. He's playing Zeus in pretty exciting line of actual. He's working. The man works. The man's working. Okay. He's playing Zeus in Thor, Love and Thunder. He is. He directed a movie that he's starring in called poker face where he plays a tech billionaire who gathers his childhood
这太棒了。我能快速盘点一下罗素·克劳接下来都有哪些作品吗？当然可以。因为他的片单实在太令人兴奋了。他在工作，这人是个劳模。这人真的在工作，好吧。他在《雷神4：爱与雷霆》里演宙斯。
friends to his Miami estate for what turns into a high stakes game of poker. I am to use the term all in on that show. It's pretty good pretty good. He's in the world of this cast, but sure. Sure. He's in the greatest beer run ever, which is Peter Fairley's follow up to Green Book. It's him and Efron, a man's story of leaving New York in 1967 to bring beer to his childhood buddies in the army while they're fighting in Vietnam. Then he's, I think Bill Murray is in there, but he is.
朋友们齐聚迈阿密庄园，随后演变成一场高风险的扑克局。我甚至想用“全押”这个词来形容那部剧。挺不错的，挺不错的。他在这个演员阵容里，不过当然了。当然了。他参演了《尚好的宿醉》，那是彼得·法雷里继《绿皮书》之后的又一部作品。主演有他和埃夫隆，讲述了一个男人在1967年离开纽约，去越南战场给参军的童年死党们送啤酒的故事。然后还有，我想比尔·默瑞也在里面，但他确实在。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yes. while they're fighting in Vietnam, then he's, I think Bill Murray is in there. He is. Yeah. Yes. He's doing Craven the Hunter playing who knows what he's playing Rothko in a Mark Rothko biopic. And then what's the last thing here? Oh, American son. Oh, he's doing the remake of a prophet, a movie that Sam Remy was originally supposed
对，对，对。是的。他们在越南作战的时候，然后还有，我想比尔·默瑞也在里面。他在。对。是的。他要演《猎人克莱文》，演谁都不知道；他还要在一部马克·罗斯科的传记片里演罗斯科。然后最后一部是什么来着？哦，《美国之子》。哦，他在翻拍《预言者》，一部原本由山姆·雷米执导的电影。
to direct. Right. He's, he's that Sam Remy was originally supposed to direct. Right. He's he's playing the the Neil South drop. Yeah, the Neil South. Yeah, that's cool. That's an interesting line of movies ahead of I like him working. I look unhinged was a good time, but I'd like him to do more serious stuff as well. Sure.
对。他，他……原本是由山姆·雷米执导的。对。他，他……演的是尼尔·索斯。对，尼尔·索斯。对，这挺酷的。接下来这一长串电影真是有意思，我喜欢他拼命工作。《Unhinged》挺有意思的，但我希望他也能演点更严肃的角色。当然。
Another actor who's in this film, guys, is Lee and Arda de Caprio. Yeah. Have you heard of him? Yeah, familiar. Yeah, it's a movie star. He was a recent Oscar nominee, of course, at the time, right? Because Gilbert Grape is what the year before. Yeah.
各位，这部电影里的另一位演员是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。对。你们听说过他吗？听过，挺熟的。对，是个电影明星。当然，他当时刚获得奥斯卡提名，对吧？因为《不一样的天空》是前一年的作品嘛。
And he was sharing some was intent on casting him. Apparently, Stone and Rainey paid him themselves out of their budget, out of their salaries, I guess, yeah. Correct. She was so insistent on him being hired that she had them take his salary out of her salary on this movie. It's weird that they wouldn't want him.
而且他分享了一些……对他的选角非常坚持。显然，莎朗·斯通和雷米是从他们自己的预算、从他们的薪水里掏钱雇他的，我猜是的。没错。她太坚持要雇他了，以至于她让剧组从她在这部电影的片酬里扣掉他的片酬。他们居然不想要他，这挺奇怪的。
That's the only thing I don't understand. It's like he seems like a really hot name, yeah. It does feel like there might have been a perception thing because you also have this boy's life. It's like De Niro has said like this kid's good, right? But I almost feel like there was a perception thing of like he's a serious actor. He's not a movie star.
这是我唯一不理解的地方。感觉他当时是个非常热门的名字，是的。感觉可能存在某种认知上的偏差，因为你还有这部《男孩的生活》。德尼罗都说过这小子很有天赋，对吧？但我总觉得当时有一种刻板印象，觉得他是个严肃演员，而不是电影明星。
Yeah, right, right. Which is incredibly bizarre to think. Is it that he was too babyface like or was it that right? He only did like serious movies. Yeah. I had read that that Matt Damon was also considered for the day. One in Sam Rockwell was considered. Yeah. You know, this is those 90s whenever like Damon or whoever is interviewed now, it's like you think about all those all these a list movie stars like who are like
对，对，对。现在想起来这简直不可思议。是因为他长得太显嫩娃娃脸了，还是因为……对啊？他只演那种严肃电影。是的。我曾读到过，马特·达蒙也是这个角色的考虑人选之一。萨姆·洛克威尔也被考虑过。你知道，每当90年代的达蒙或其他什么人现在接受采访时，你会想起所有这些A咖电影明星，就像那些好莱坞年轻当红小生……
young Hollywood bucks like Trying to get a good role right like is when Damon gets courage under fire. He's like I got the role like you know That's why he like lost 400 pounds I got a like a wall in on this right, but you could see Damon's face working in this movie although I love you. Yes, I'm not a caprio in this, but like he He has it like a harder like a you know like face and you could see him fitting in this movie, although I love Lee. Yes. I mean, I had a caprio on this, but like he has a like a harder like, you know, like face and you could see him fitting in this milieu a little more than then one of the things that's funny and odd about Leonardo Caprio is he just seems like a 90s teen heartthrob
为了得到一个好角色在努力，对吧？就像达蒙接拍《生死豪情》时，他说我拿到这个角色了，你知道的。这就是为什么他减了400磅，我一定要拿下这个角色，对吧？但你能看出达蒙的脸很适合这部电影，虽然我很喜欢利……是的，我喜欢迪卡普里奥在这部里的表现，但他的脸更有棱角，你知道的，你能看出他更适合这种环境，虽然我很喜欢利……是的，我是说迪卡普里奥在这部里的表现，但他的脸更有棱角，你知道的，你能看出他更适合这种环境，稍微比……关于莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，有一点挺搞笑也挺奇特的，他在这个角色里看起来就像个90年代的青春偶像，
in this role, which is kind of with the role needs, you know, but it's not, it doesn't have the western part of it. He's not dirty at all. He's not dirty at all. He's not dirty at all. He's a true like golden boy. Yeah. That's why it does work for me because he does feel like freaking, you know, I mean, this isn't an old movie, but like Alden Aaron Reichen, Hale Caesar or whatever, like, he does feel like some shiny little Hollywood star from the 30s, right? I think that's right. I think that's what's funny about him is he's like being cast
这某种程度上也是角色所需的，你知道的，但它没有那种西部片的粗粝感。他一点也不显脏。他一点也不显脏。他一点也不显脏。他活脱脱就是个金童。是的。这就是为什么这对我挺管用的，因为他真的感觉像是个……你知道我的意思，这不是部老电影，但就像《凯撒万岁》里的奥尔登·埃伦瑞奇一样，他真有点像30年代那种光鲜亮丽的好莱坞小明星，对吧？我想是的。我觉得他好玩的地方就在于他被选去演
in a western movie. Like, yes. He's like, hey guys, so fast, baby. He's not being, he's not in a western. Like, he's not, it's a complete meta commentary of a certain type of movie. He feels like Bobby Driscoll and like a live action Disney movie or something.
一部西部片。就像是，没错。他就好像在说，嘿伙计们，太快了，宝贝。他其实没有……他不是在演西部片。这完全是对某种特定类型电影的元讽刺。他感觉就像真人版迪士尼电影里的鲍比·德里斯科尔或者别的什么人。
Like this is the very last performance DeCaprio gives that still has any child actor energy in the like growing pains sense, right? Because when he makes a transition from like growing pains and critters three and whatever, it's like, oh no, but he's working with heavy duty actors and to Nero's telling people that he's like very serious minded and he's like wise beyond his years and Gilbert Grape, everyone said, how could someone so young give a performance like that?
这可以说是迪卡普里奥最后一次在表演中带有那种童星的光芒，带有《成长的烦恼》那种感觉，对吧？因为当他从《成长的烦恼》、《魔精3》之类的转型时，你会觉得，哦不，但他是在和硬汉演员合作，而且德尼罗告诉别人说他非常有思想，而且他少年老成。在《不一样的天空》里，每个人都说，这么年轻的人怎么能给出这样的表演？
This is the last movie where he's got a little bit of child star shine on it. Yeah, yeah. Like, there's that cleanness to his delivery and even just how he's styled. And I do think you're right that like Matt Damon's face even at this age fits into this milieu better, but it works against the movie almost.
这是他身上还带有一点童星光环的最后一部电影。对，对。他的台词处理有一种纯净感，甚至连他的造型也是如此。而且我觉得你说得对，马特·达蒙的脸即使在这么年轻的时候，也比他更适合这种环境，但这几乎跟电影本身起到了反效果。
If you have someone who is more realistically cast, they leaned into something that might seem in Congress, but it worked, I think for the movie really, really well. And it's exactly why that fucking final moment between him and Hackman is a goddamn himmer blow. Because when like the entire child star facade drops from him, and he's just going to the paint like full de Camperio, the it's it's it's heartbreaking.
如果你找一个更写实的演员，他们可能会倾向于某种看似不协调的东西，但它确实奏效了，我觉得对这部电影来说真的非常非常棒。这正是为什么他和哈克曼之间那场该死的最后对决简直是致命一击。因为当那种全盘的童星外表从他身上褪去，他完全进入状态，展现出百分百的迪卡普里奥风范时，那真的是……太心碎了。
It's hard break. And it's what you said. This thing where you're just like kind of impressed at this movie is able to pull off slow quiet moments of genuine emotion to that degree and a film that is otherwise so kinetic and frenzy. Right. In a film that is about a march madness of shooting. Like that is what it's about. Because it's like Sharon Stone rides into town. There's the little, you know, brief prologue with Tobin Bell. But basically Shurides into town and Pat Hingle is there and he's got like a chalkboard with a bracket
太心碎了。正如你所说的那样。你会对这部电影在一部原本如此动感和疯狂的影片中，依然能够呈现出那种缓慢、安静且达到这种程度的真挚情感而感到印象深刻。对。在一片充满枪战的疯狂混乱之中。这正是它的核心所在。因为就像莎朗·斯通骑马进城一样。中间有一个简短的序幕，有托宾·贝尔。但基本上，莎朗进城了，帕特·辛格也在那儿，他手里拿着一个带有
on it. And he's like, well, are you are you in? Yeah, it's a knockout. Here's the deal with this town. We just do a fucking shootout every day at the at the strike a noon. And it's a quick draw. This's towns around by this shitty guy. I mean, it's such a bad town. Like, what if you want to go like buying onion? Yeah, right. Yeah, like it's like, sorry. There's no onion salesman here, only shooters.
对阵图的黑板。他问，怎么样，你要加入吗？对，太棒了。这个镇子的规矩是这样的。我们每天中午12点整都会进行一场他妈的枪战。这是快枪对决。这个镇子被这个混蛋控制了。我的意思是，这镇子也太糟了。比如说你想去买个洋葱怎么办？对，没错。对，就像是，抱歉。这里没有卖洋葱的，只有神枪手。
The only other person I want to shout out is Lance Hendrickson who I will talk about. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. We'll talk about Keith David in a second, but I don't think there's any Keith David rich research specifically in here. I mean, we love Keith David, obviously. But just the funny Landtendrix thing is
我唯一想大加赞赏的另一个人是兰斯·亨利克森，我等会儿会聊到他。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。我们一会儿会聊到基思·大卫，但我认为这里面并没有什么关于基思·大卫的特别研究。我的意思是，我们当然都很喜欢基思·大卫。但兰斯·亨利克森好笑的地方在于
he knew someone who I guess worked in Wild West shows and stuff. His name is Rex Rossi and Landtendrixen before the movie starts, before production starts, goes to Rex Rossi and says, I got a shoot a card out of his kid's hand. That's in the script. I think there should be more to it than that. So teach me a horse trick. So Rex Rossi taught him the trick where he flips off the horse backwards.
他认识一个曾在野生西部秀之类的节目里工作过的人。那个人叫雷克斯·罗西（Rex Rossi）。在电影开拍前，在制作开始前，兰斯·亨利克森去找雷克斯·罗西说：“我得从这小子的手里把一张纸牌打飞。剧本里是这么写的。我觉得应该加入更多内容。所以教我一个马术绝技吧。”于是雷克斯·罗西教了他一个绝技：从马背上向后翻身跃下。
And when he showed up on set, he says, Sam, I want to show you something. Bring a horse over. He jumps on the horse, he flips out off of the horse, shoots under its belly, and Sam Raimi was like, this rules, that's in the movie. That's great. So later we're just showed up with a special horse trick.
当他出现在片场时，他说：“山姆，我想给你看个东西。牵匹马过来。”他跳上马，从马背上翻身跃下，在马肚子底下开枪。山姆·雷米当时就觉得：这太酷了，把它加进电影里。这太棒了。所以后来我们看到的就是他展示了一个特殊的马术绝技。
And I guess rather than Sam Raimi being like, Jesus, like, why did you work so hard on this without telling me? Sam Raimi was like, of course. You got to do this. A horse, of course. A horse, of course, like, you got to do this. A horse, of course. A horse, of course. I'm looking here at the notes. It also says that Lance Henrickson showed up to set dress like this and said, where is
我想山姆·雷米非但没有觉得“天哪，你为什么不告诉我，这么拼命苦练”，反而觉得“当然了。你必须得这么做。马嘛，当然得这样。马嘛，当然得这样……”我正在看笔记。上面还说兰斯·亨利克森穿着这身衣服来到片场，并问道：“发型和化妆师在哪儿？”他们回答说：“我们直接用这个造型把你拍进镜头里。”这太搞笑了。不过他在片中的造型简直不可思议。那一头乌黑的长发。头发。是的。他真的穿得像……
hair and makeup? And they said, we're just going to put you on camera in this look. That's a joke. But his, his look in this is unbelievable. The long jet black hair. The hair. Yeah. He truly is dressed like, um, God, like, like a rapper now.
天哪，就像现在的一个说唱歌手。
You know what I'm saying? Right. Like, who's the rapper with all the face tattoos? Who's like, does country stuff to post Malone? Post Malone. Like that's some shit post Malone would fucking go out at the VMAs wearing. But he's got that sort of like the Renaissance Van Dyke facial hair. Oh, yeah.
你知道我在说什么吗？对。就像是，那个满脸纹身的说唱歌手是谁？那个搞乡村音乐的波兹·马龙？波兹·马龙。那绝对是波兹·马龙去MTV音乐录影带大奖时才会穿的鬼东西。但他留着那种文艺复兴时期的范戴克式面部胡须。哦，对。
I mean, just he's he's leaning so hard into his gimmick. He has all the aces in his deck of cards for each kill. You've got Keith David absolutely swacked out, looking incredible. The best outfit. Sick ass pipe, big pipe, big voice. Like he's got it all. He's incredible. Yeah.
我的意思是，他把自己的噱头发挥到了极致。他为每一次击杀准备了满满一手牌的王牌。你还有基思·大卫，完全帅呆了，看起来帅惨了。最佳造型。超酷的烟斗，大烟斗，充满磁性的嗓音。他全占了。他太厉害了。是的。
I love the outfits in this, like unironically love. But that's good. Yeah. So of course, like Henrichson and David are such specific castings of, like, not only are these actors who are very familiar faces to audiences at this time, even if they don't know my name, they're gonna stick out, they're gonna remember them. And they also have incredibly distinctive voices, because you need to just introduce them
我超爱这片里的服装，是那种非讽刺意义上的超级喜欢。这很棒。所以当然了，亨利克森和大卫都是非常精准的选角，不仅因为这些演员对当时的观众来说是极具辨识度的面孔，即使观众叫不出他们的名字，他们也会脱颖而出、让人印象深刻。而且他们的嗓音也极具辨识度，因为你需要在前五分钟内
the first five minutes, put a pin in them and make sure the audience doesn't forget when they come back and are relevant again. Totally. You got Mark Boone Jr. who of course, Griffin, you once said on his performance at batman against it looks like he sleeps under a pizza. Another person I have never forgotten. All of my most savage opponents. No, it's just like he is, he is the any time Mark Boone Jr. in a movie. Isn't a movie you're like, oh, I get it. This guy's a bit of a scumbag, isn't he? Like, he's just got the perfect face for, he scars. You got Tobin Bell, Jake saw himself.
介绍他们出场，给他们一个特写，确保观众在他们再次回归并发挥作用时不会忘记他们。完全如此。你还有马克·布恩·儒尼奥尔，格里芬，你曾经评价过他在《蝙蝠侠》里的表演，说他看起来像是个睡在披萨底下的人。这是另一个我永远不会忘记的人。我所有最残忍的对手。不，这只是……他每次只要马克·布恩·儒尼奥尔出现在电影里。只要他出现在电影里，你就会想：哦，我明白了。这家伙有点像个人渣，对吧？他就是长了一张完美的人渣脸。你还有托宾·贝尔，也就是“竖锯”本人。
Right. What do you, what do you, what do you strode? This is his final movie, right? What do you strode right at the end of his career? You're right. Yeah, he died before this movie even came out. Yeah. You got, what's it called?
对。你……你……这是他的最后一部电影，对吧？你……他在职业生涯的尾声演了这个？你说得对。是的。他在电影上映前就去世了。对。你还有，那个叫什么来着？
What's his name? Robert's Blossom. Oh, famous old man. Yes. He was in Christine. We've discussed him in man. Yes. He was in Christine. We've discussed him in that. Obviously, he was in a couple of the demis. He's the old man in home alone. Yeah. And you've got a Keith Kevin Conway, who I've always liked as a what's it called as dread. Yes. Judge who gets his dick shot off. Yeah. Not to not to. And can
他叫什么名字？罗伯特·布洛森。哦，著名的老头。对。他演过《克里斯汀娜回魂》。我们讨论过他在那部片里的表现。当然，他演过好几部《小鬼当家》。他就是《小鬼当家》里的那个老头。对。你还有凯文·康威，我一直很喜欢他演的那个……叫什么来着，那个判官。对。那个命根子被枪打飞的判官。对。不是说……我可以
I say to find a point deserves it deserves it. My opinion. Yeah. Not to, not to, and can I say, to find a point of it? Deserves it, my opinion. Yeah, he's a bit of a jerk. I think he played, I think Kevin Cahn what, yes, he played Kayless in Star Trek the next generation.
把话说得更明白点，他罪有应得，罪有应得。依我之见。是的。不是说……我可以把话说得更明白点吗？他罪有应得，依我之见。是的，他有点混蛋。我想他演过……我想凯文·康威，是的，他在《星际迷航：下一代》里演过凯利斯。
If anyone's a Star Trek fan out there, yeah, it's just, it's just an incredible lineup of beautiful character actors. Great faces. Yeah, such good faces. Yeah, it's really, really fun. And there's been there's others I'm not remembering. And obviously like Bruce Campbell shows up for a second and Gary
如果这里有任何《星际迷航》粉丝的话，对，这简直是一份不可思议的优秀性格演员阵容。绝佳的面孔。是的，都是这么棒的面孔。是的，真的非常非常有趣。还有一些我记不清了。当然，布鲁斯·坎贝尔客串了一秒钟，加里·西尼斯
Sinise obviously shows up in flashback, which is kind of a coup, kind of a casting coup, Gary Sinise, like right off of a far as come. Yeah. I remember that being notable at the time. Like we see is you see his face as a kind of de-garrotype before he shows up. And he plays a good role. And he plays like you can see the way that he looks and mirrors court in a lot of ways. And it's really something. And I also think that flashback scene of her initial trauma, which has takes a surprising turn. Where he's like, and it mimics, you know, reflects the moment that court is brought in. And he's like, they, they, they, the chair and the, and, and, you know, she's given the, the gun to save her father and shoot some in the head instead. It's like a real moment. It really, you feel it, it to me at least.
显然在闪回中出场了，这算是一个惊喜，可以说是选角上的一个神来之笔，加里·西尼斯，刚演完《阿甘正传》就来了。我记得当时这挺引人注目的。比如我们看到他的脸就像一张银版摄影照片，然后他就出场了。而且他演得很好。他演得……你能看出他的外表在很多方面都呼应了科特（Court），这真的很了不起。而且我也觉得她最初遭受创伤的那段闪回戏，有了一个令人惊讶的转折。他当时说，这也呼应了（科特被带进来的那一刻）。他说，他们，他们，椅子，还有，你知道的，她本该拿枪去救父亲，结果却一枪打中了父亲的脑袋。这真的是一个很有冲击力的时刻。至少对我和观众来说，你真的能感受到那种痛楚。
No, I agree, I agree. You think it's a good job being genuinely visceral in all the cartooniness. Yeah, exactly. There's the thing I've been vote too many times, but I always just think it's such a good storytelling lesson for movies, but the Andrew Stanton finding Nemo thing, where originally he had that movie structured
不，我同意，我同意。你觉得它在所有的漫画感之中，真正做到了发自内心的 visceral（ visceral：直击心灵的/血淋淋的）。对， exatamente。有一个桥段我已经被提及过太多次了，但我一直觉得这是电影叙事中非常棒的一课，就是安德鲁·斯坦顿在《海底总动员》里的那个处理。原本他把那部电影结构设计成
where you would get glimpses to the flashback of the Barakuda killing his wife and all the other babies throughout the movie. And when they screened it for people, they were like, I cannot stand this Alper Brooks character. He's driving me fucking insane. Why won't this fish calm the fuck down? And so they were like, as an experiment,
在整部电影中，你会断断续续地闪回巴库达鱼杀死他的妻子和所有其他鱼宝宝的画面。当他们把片子拿去给观众试映时，大家的反应是：我简直无法忍受这个阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯角色的唠叨。他快把我逼疯了。这条鱼为什么就不能闭嘴安静一会儿？所以他们就想，作为一个实验，
what if we just take the scene and we run it in full at the very beginning of the movie and the movie immediately worked? And it was just that thing of like, you think you're being clever by withholding information for later, but not only is it almost never worth it, it also you're depriving the audience of the information that will help them understand the character
如果我们把这个场景完整地放在电影的一开始播放会怎么样？结果电影立刻就成功了。这就是那种情况：你以为自己通过把信息留到后面揭晓是在耍小聪明，但不仅这种做法几乎从来不值得，而且你还剥夺了观众在开头就能理解角色的必要信息。所以当这部电影把这些闪回的小片段和加里·西尼斯穿插在一起时，我并没有被劝退，但我会想：为什么他们不直接把事情告诉我呢？但最后的揭晓是如此精彩，以至于我觉得：这是正确运用这种手法的典例之一，因为你以为自己已经拼凑出了所有的线索。我懂了。哈克曼杀害了她的父亲。
at the beginning. So when this movie is doling out these little glimpses as the flashbacks with Gary Seneese, I'm not turned off, but I'm like, why aren't they just telling me the thing? But that final reveal is so good. I'm like, this is one of the examples of this being done right because you think you put together all the pieces. I get it. Hackman killed her father.
这就是她恨他的原因。我们为什么还要在这件事上拐弯抹角？而他们压轴的最后一击是：这正是你之前看过的那个场景的镜像。你还记得那个时刻，但在当时，它只觉得像是很酷的西部片桥段。而现在，电影中的一切都有了更厚重的分量。我认为这是这种叙事手法真正让整部电影受益的少数几次之一。
That's why she hates him. Why are we like tiptoeing around this? And the final hammer blow they're like holding back on is, it's the mirror of the scene you've already seen. And you remember that moment, but it just felt like cool western shit in that moment. And now everything in the movie has like added weight. I think it's one of the few times where that device actually benefits the film at large.
是的，但你说的对，直到那个时刻之前的紧张感，因为那种模棱两可的闪回并没有起到什么作用。它们感觉……作用不大，但它确实得到了完美的回报，并且做到了那种完美的事情——让你重新评估电影的其余部分。当那个时刻来临、重现她父亲遇害的那一幕时，你确实看到了她的恐惧，就像记忆本身以一种极棒的方式震撼了你，促使你重新审视一切。我觉得这真的非常非常棒，而且惊心动魄。
Yeah, but you write about the tension up to that point because the sort of vague flashbacks don't do anything for you. They're like, they don't do much, but it really does pay off and it does that perfect thing of making reevaluate the rest of the movie. And you do see her fear and her when when that moment happens, where it is the exact same scene of her father, and it's like, just like the memory of it, like Joltz you in this great way of re-evaluation. I think that's really, really great and harrowing.
而且这也是真正出人意料的。比如我原本以为她会连续开枪打偏很多次或者别的什么，结果第一枪就击中了她父亲，这简直就像是一记沉重的重击。这就像是完美的背景故事。这就是你需要的一切。你知道的，关于这些角色的一切，你只需要这一个瞬间来定义她。
And it's also truly surprising. Like I expected her to miss a bunch of times or whatever, but first shot hits her dad is like, it's a real gut punch. It's like, it's just perfect backstory. That's all you need. You know, it's like everything you need to know about those characters in that one moment defining her.
它展现了她的动机，但是……你知道的，直到最后你把所有这些线索拼凑在一起，迎来了最后的对决时，她并没有被塑造成一个超人。她被塑造成一个能干的人，一个非常优秀的人，但她并不是一枪打断绳子然后百发百中，她只是砰、砰、砰地开枪，你会觉得：她其实……并不是说她在这方面完美无缺，她只是被复仇驱使着。
And it shows her motivation, but like, you know, she's not until the end where you put all that stuff together and there's the sort of final confrontation, she is not presented as superhuman. She's presented as competent, she's presented as very good, but she doesn't shoot the rope once and not, she just goes, bam, bam, bam, you're like, she really like, it is not that she's perfect at this, she's just driven.
我认为这也是这部电影的另一个绝妙之处：每个人都很擅长开枪，显然如此，这也是他们想要决斗的原因。但没有人被塑造成彻头彻尾的终结者。如果要说的话，那个小伙子可能才是最具天赋的一个，因为他不停地说“我太快了”，你知道的，这似乎几乎成了一种超能力。而简·哈克曼似乎也拥有某种超能力。我觉得他很吓人。但他在那种情况下又显得如此脆弱，以至于你会觉得——
And I think that's another great move with this movie, is that everyone is good, obviously, at shooting, but that's why they want to do the shooting. But no one is presented as a total terminator. If anything, the kid is maybe the most like naturally gifted in a way, and that he keeps being like, I'm so fast, like, you know, and that sort of seems to almost be a superpower. And Gene Hackman seems to have a certain superpower too. I'm like, he's scary. But he also feels so vulnerable in that way where you're just like,
我是说，尤其是那个小伙子死去的那个场景。他说：“从来没有人证明过他是我的儿子。”在那场戏里他是那么的卑微可怜，而且显然无法承认自己的人性，或者……你知道我的意思吗？以至于你甚至会觉得：“哦天哪，赶紧把这家伙解决掉吧。”这太完美了。是的，附和一下大卫的观点。我只想说，还有那次决斗之后，当他赢了的时候，显然
I mean, it's especially the scene obviously where the kid dies. And he's like, it was never proven that he was my son. Like, he's so sort of pathetic in that scene. And like clearly just unable to admit his humanity or what you know what I mean like that you kind of are just like, oh god someone take this guy down like it's so perfect. Yeah, I'll for that David. I'll just say to like, there's the time when after a fight when he wins obviously he
他停顿了一下，等着所有人为他鼓掌。对， exatamente。这让我想起了伯恩斯先生。就是伯恩斯先生参加那个电影节的时候，你知道我的意思吗？电影节。是的，是的，当然。这完全就是那种氛围。他真的只是个可怜虫，真的。是的，那真是一个绝妙的时刻。他举起双手说“请为我鼓掌”，这太棒了。而且他满怀期待。他觉得自己就像是……我是这部电影的英雄，对吧？
pauses to wait for everyone to clap for him. Yeah, exactly. It made me think of Mr. Burns. It when Mr. Burns competes in the film, you know what I mean? Festival. Yes, yes, of course. Like it just had that vibe. Like he is really just pathetic, truly. Yeah, that that is a really good moment. If I hold up his hands and please clap for me, it's so good. Like and he's expecting it. He's like, I am, you know, the hero of this movie, right?
对。对。对。和小伙子对决的那个时刻太他妈棒了，而且你们之前已经铺垫了一种紧张悬疑的氛围，比如迪卡普里奥告诉你“我觉得他是我的父亲”，对吧？你看到他们有过好几次交锋，而你根本分不清哈克曼是完全装糊涂、
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The moment with the kid is so fucking good, and you've set up this uneasy thing of like, the caprio's told you, I think he's my father, right? You've seen them have a number of exchanges, and you can't tell whether Hackman is completely oblivious,
心里明白但极力不肯承认，还是根本不相信这是真的，对吧？然后，你知道的，他说了句类似“行了行了，小伙子”之类的话，他们走向了决斗场。莎朗·斯通试图劝迪卡普里奥放弃。迪卡普里奥说：“我只需要他承认我，对吧？我需要赢得他的尊重。”对。这，天哪，太悲伤了。太悲伤了。这，这，这，你从这上面到底能得到什么？
knows but is trying not to acknowledge it or doesn't believe it's true, right? And then, you know, he's sort of saying like enough enough kid, they go to the shoot out. Stone's trying to talk to Camprio out of it. He says like, I just need him to acknowledge me, right? I need to earn his respect. Right. It's, man, it's sad. It's so sad. It's, it's, it's, what do you want out of this?
就像是：“我只需要他他妈的尊重我。”然后，他设置那个镜头并进行剪辑的方式——拔枪，拔枪，哈克曼中枪倒地，脖子上中弹——你几乎会以为迪卡普里奥赢了。然后当你镜头切回迪卡普里奥的脸时，你看到了他对自己竟然击中了一枪的震惊，而这震惊瞬间转化成了身体上的……他演得太好了。他他妈演得太好了。那个倒下，对。
It's like, I just need him to fucking respect me. And then the, the moment the way he sets that up and cuts it so that it's like draw, draw, hackman responding to the bullet on the neck, you almost think the caprio's one. And then when you cut back to decapriose face, you see his like shock that he landed a bullet that immediately turns into the physical, like. He plays it really well. He plays it really fucking well. The collapse, yeah.
然后他就那样倒下了，对吧？就像一个丢脸的小孩在痛哭，吓得要死。我不想死，对吧？而哈克曼站在他上方，他妈的伸出手去……他就是在这个地方展现演技的。哦，他他妈地伸出手去。而哈克曼，正如你所说，在迪卡普里奥死后，他开始走过场般地辩解：
And then he just collapsed, right? He's like full on like embarrassing child crying, so terrified. I don't want to die, right? And Hackman stands over him and he fucking reaches out. That's where he plays that moment. Oh, he just fucking reaches out. And Hackman, as you said, once the caprio dies, he goes through all the motions of,
“从来没有人证明过他真的是我的孩子。我给他留了退路。我告诉过他他不必这么做……”诸如此类，哈克曼找尽了每一个借口。当他看着迪卡普里奥时，他面无表情。你根本读不懂他的脸。而迪卡普里奥只是想从他那里得到哪怕一点点回应。是的，却什么也没得到。
well, they never proved he was actually my kid. I tried to give him an out. I told him he didn't have to do this. This and that like Hackman's making every single excuse. When he looks at the caprio, he was actually my kid. I tried to give him an out. I told him he didn't have to do this. This and that, like, Hackman's making every single excuse. When he looks at the Caprio, he is inscrutable. You cannot read his face. And the Caprio just wants anything out of him. Yeah, gives him nothing.
这真的太棒了。而且正如罗曼所说，这些更有情感张力的时刻很容易显得苍白无力，因为这部电影的基调被拔得太高了。所以，当影片中还穿插着诸如有人一枪打穿基思·大卫的脑袋、脑浆飞溅的画面时，要让这些情感戏份起作用其实是一项棘手的任务。对我来说，那是哈克曼另一个不可思议的场景。对。仅仅是那一幕。那真是一场极好的戏。对。对。你把基思·大卫
Yeah. It's really good. And again, like Roman saying, it would be easy for these more emotional moments to fall really flat because the movie is so heightened. Like it's, it's a tricky task like getting that stuff to work when you also have like someone shooting a perfect hole and keep David's head and the wind blowing through it. So that's the other unbelievable hack man scene for me. Yeah. Just that. It's a really good scene. Yeah. Yeah. You've kept keep David on the
晾在一边有一会儿了，对吧？你会想：为什么你要……如果你不在长达40分钟左右的时间里好好使用他，你为什么要介绍他出场？他在那儿。是的。但他是一个如此独特的人物，然后他有了那场小小的会面，他在会上试探了那个家伙，然后说：“好吧，他们花钱雇你来除掉我。”接着就是那种他妈的残酷转折：“规矩变了。现在这是生死决斗了。”对。我不会放过这家伙的，我要在他脑后开个洞，
shelf for a while, right? You're like, why would you? You're not introduced if you're not going to really use him for like 40 minutes or whatever. He's around. Yeah. But like such a distinctive dude, then he has that little meeting where he susses the guy out and he's like, okay, they paid you to bring me in. And then that fucking just brutal, like the rules have changed. This is now to the death. Right. I'm not gonna this guy down. I'm blowing a hole in the back of his head
然后告诉你们所有人……这事情转變得有多快：“哦，所以你们可以因为我没有足够的钱而看不起我，但你们却花钱雇了某人来杀我。”这太棒了。他的那种威慑力，将局势瞬间逆转，进一步增强了他整体的霸气。这太棒了，就像是……我觉得这部电影的结构简直完美无缺，它真的……它模仿视频游戏的程度可能超过了其他任何东西，
and I'm telling all of you how quickly it turns into the like, oh, so you can play into me about not having enough money, but you paid some fucking guy to kill me. That's great. His menace, like turning that moment around is like, just adding to his like overall power. It's like, it's it's great it's like I think this movie is so perfectly structured it like and it mimics really mimics a video game more than probably anything and you
每一次枪战的场景设置都是层层递进的，你会觉得：没错，事情就该是这样，不可能有别的结局。你知道的，比如最后必须是科特和那个女人对决，事情只能是这样，它的结构完美无缺，最后的那个小伙子和小女孩也是如此。所有的这一切作为情节机制都被设置得非常、非常完美。而且你拥有四个完美的角色弧光。绝对如此。它完美地命中了所有靶心。在一部拥有如此荒谬、真的极其荒谬的前提的电影里。你知道的，这绝对是一个无法辩护的荒谬前提，千真万确。
go where you just get progressively each each sort of setup of the gun fight is is like yep that has to be the way it is it can't't be another way around. You know, like, it has to be a court and the lady at the last one, it has to be that it's just, like, it's perfectly structured and the kid and herod at the very end. Like, all of it is like, set up really, really perfectly as a plot mechanism. And you have four perfect character arcs. Like, totally. and it hits it. And amongst this like very, really, really silly premise. You know, like, it is undeniably ridiculous premise. No one could possibly defend it, it's true.
我觉得电影里确实有那么一个场景，对我来说感觉有点怪异。什么场景？我觉得这是整部电影里唯一一个让我感觉调校得有点失准的场景，那就是莎朗·斯通和罗伯特·布洛森在墓地、在火车里的对峙。感觉演得太用力了。
I think there is, like truly one scene in this movie that feels a little bit wonky to me. What's that? I think it's the only scene in this movie that feels just a little bit misky to me. What's that? I think it's the only scene in this movie that feels just a little bit miscalibrated, which is the Sharon Stone, Robert Blossom confrontation in the graveyard, in the train. It just feels overcranked.
她和布洛森两人的表演都有点过火。台词写得过满。感觉 expository（说明性太强）。就像电影不得不——而且它出现得也挺晚的。所以电影不得不慢下来去处理它。这就有点像是……我们其实已经猜到这些了。你知道我的意思吗？
Like her and Blossom are both sort of overacting. The scene is overwritten. It feels too expository. Like the movie has- It's also coming kind of late. So the movie has to slow down to do it. And it's sort of like, we kind of already figured this out. You know what I mean?
这就好像电影在以一种你并不需要的方式强行赶进度。对。不过下雨的特效挺好的。下雨挺好的。挺有氛围的。是的。
Like it feels like you're kind of the movie's catching up in a way that you don't need it too. Yeah. The rain is good though. The rain is good. It's good. It's like. Yeah.
这倒不是毁灭性的败笔。但如果要拿莎朗·斯通在这部片里的表现开玩笑，这就是那个会被拿来开玩笑的场景。这是最适合被拎出来批判的一幕。这是整部电影中唯一可能暴露出她演技弱点的场景。而且我觉得电影的其他部分都是那么干净利落、
It's not ruinous. But if like if you're making fun of Sharon Stone in this, this is the scene you make fun of. It's the scene to pull out. It's the one scene that may be placed to her weaknesses. And I also think the rest of the movie is just kind of like so clean and lean
精简干练、犹如钻石切割般精准，相比之下，这唯一的一场戏就显得 sloppy（粗糙）很多了。是的，我同意这一点。不过我在看的时候还是完全能够忽略它的。好吧，反正这是一部很好看的爆米花电影。好吧，本，你接着说。
and economic and diamond cut that this one scene ends up feeling a lot sloppy or by comparison. Yeah, I agree with that. I'm totally able to get over it though when I'm watching it. Well, it's just an easy watch. Yeah, go ahead Ben.
我想大声赞美“斑马”（Spotted Horse）这个角色。这个角色他妈的太酷了。我超爱他。他整个人设就是：“我他妈根本不怕这个。”你知道的，因为——我觉得我们之前没怎么讨论过他。但他的整体特质就是，他数着自己挨过的那些子弹，看起来简直酷毙了。
I want to shout out spotted horse. That character fucking rules. I love that. His whole thing is he's like, I'm just not afraid of this. You know, because like, I don't think we really discuss him. Like his whole trait though, if like, and he runs through all the bullets he's taken and he just seems so fucking badass.
他仿佛子弹都打不死。是的。我真的很舍不得这个角色领便当。不过那场戏也非常紧张且聪明。关于科特的所有那些情节，比如……你知道的，喊着“给我另一颗子弹，给我另一颗子弹”，你知道的，还有那个盲童……天哪，这部电影我真的很好奇，在1995年，人们会不会觉得内容太多、花样太杂了？比如，有个盲童在子弹堆里翻找……
He cannot be killed by a bullet. Yeah. I really, I was very sad to lose that character. Well, that scene is also really intense and clever. The whole thing with court, like, you know being like get me another bullet get me another bullet You know like the blind kid god this movie is I Do wonder right in 1995 if people were just like too much too many bits like yeah, there's a blind kid like rifling through the bullets
你知道的，难道这里没有一个正常人吗？这难道成了一种套路吗？因为我刚才正想着那个场景，然后心想：对啊，这不仅是我刚才描述的那些，而且那个盲童接着还在子弹堆里翻找35毫米子弹或者别的什么。对。不，也许这一切……雷米走得太快、太超前了，而文化直到现在才赶上他的脚步，对吧？在我们要如何处理海量信息以及所有这些方面，尤其是当其中大部分都是视觉呈现的时候。但我确实觉得这是我最爱他电影的一点，那就是每一分每一秒、每一个细节都可以蕴含深意。这里没有无关紧要的细节、时刻、角色、表演镜头。我认为这部电影只是时代的牺牲品。这是一部属于电影、而他也是一位
Like you know like is no one in this normal? Is that, was that become a plane? Because I was just thinking of that scene and I'm like, right, it's not only is it everything I'm describing, but the blind kid is then working through the bullets to find a 35 millimeter or whatever. Yeah. No, maybe everything. Rainy was too fast, too early, and culture has caught up to him, right? In how we can process information and all of this, especially when so much of it's visual. But I do think it's a thing I love about his movies, where it's just like every single thing can be something. There's no like, unimportant detail, moment, character, performance shot. I think this was a victim of its time. This is a movie and he's a director
充满无拘无束的热情的导演。而当时电影界的风气并不奖励热情。那是一个非常愤世嫉俗的时代。但我想如果你今天把它拿出来重映，人们绝对会……你知道的，如果这部电影今天在HBO Max上线，它绝对会成为热议话题。所有人都会爱死它的。每一幕都会被奉为神作级别的电影。我们在开始录音前就说过这个，罗曼，我觉得在每个迷你剧集里，至少都会有一部我们在播客里涵盖过的电影，由于本播客涵盖整个导演生涯的性质，它可能属于那种其他播客永远不会为其专门做一整期节目的电影。那种有点被遗忘在中间的作品，不管
of unfettered enthusiasm. And this was a moment in cinema where enthusiasm was not rewarded. It was really a cynical time. And but I think if you pulled it out today, people would just like, you know, this showed up on HBO Max today, it would be the talk. Like everyone would love it. Everything was the most amazing second coming type of movie. We were saying this right before we started recording, Roman, I feel like at least once a mini series, there is a movie that we've covered on the podcast, which because of the nature of this podcast covering an entire career, is the kind of movie that maybe other podcasts will never devote an entire episode to. That's sort of a forgotten middle thing, whether,
怎么说都好。我觉得每个迷你剧集里都有一部电影，能让我们的听众觉得：“卧槽，这他妈是什么神仙电影？我以前怎么不知道？这是我的新最爱电影。”我确实预计很多人会发出这样的感叹：“哦天哪，我以前怎么会不知道这部电影的存在？”或者“哦，那是我小时候在TBS电视台看过的电影。”
you know, whatever. And I feel like there's one movie per miniseries that like our listeners are like, holy shit, this fucking thing. How did I not know? This is my new favorite movie. And I do expect that a lot of people are gonna be like, oh my God, how was I unaware of this film existing? Or that's some movie I watched on TBS when I was a kid.
我完全不知道那是山姆·雷米的电影。现在这一切都说得通了。我……但我觉得它比你想象的要多出10%的爆发力。对，对。那部电影深深地印在了我小时候的脑海里，或者说当我当年在大学宿舍里看到它的时候，也是如此。
I had no idea that was a Sam Raimi movie. It all makes more sense now. I, but like it, but I remember it having, you know, 10% more mustard than you could think. Right. Right. That moves stuck in my mind as a kid, or, you know, when I saw it in a dorm room or whatever.
它太棒了。回想山姆·雷米的整个职业生涯，这确实挺逗的。基本上我们所有人都只会说：“我爱死这个了，再多来点荷兰式斜拍，多来点暴力美学冲击。太棒了，太棒了，太棒了。”但山姆·雷米拍完这部电影后的反应却是：我需要放松。我需要好好休息一下，冷静收敛一下。
It's so good. It is funny to think of it in Sam Raimi's career as well. We're like, we are all basically just like, I love it, more Dutch angles, more smash. Yeah. Great, great, great. But Sam Remy's reaction to making this movie was, I need to relax. I need for a treat and to a hold.
他在1998年带着《简爱》（译者注：此处主播口误，实指《简单的计划》）回归，那是他所有作品中最收敛、最剥离视觉特效花招的一次。但随后的《对垒特工》和《礼物》也同样要克制得多，对吧？他花了相当长的一段时间，直到《蜘蛛侠》才重新激发了他那些疯狂荒诞的风格。他确实进入了一段时间的冬眠期。对。
He comes back in 1998 with a simple plan, which is his most toned down, you know, you know, sort of visual trickery free movie ever. But then the four of the love of the game in the gift are similarly much more muted, right? Like it takes him quite a while before Spider-Man sort of encourages all of his loony-tune stuff again. Like he really goes into hibernation. Yeah.
让我们也承认另一个转变，我的意思是，这就是我们整个迷你剧集一直在铺垫的东西，但他在那个特定时刻接手《蜘蛛侠》实在是太诡异了，因为他们几乎是在把他从替补席上叫上场，去干他之前已经刻意金盆洗手不干的活儿。他曾付出那么多努力，就是为了不被定型成那种类型的导演，而他们却说：“嘿，整个电影工业已经变天了，我们需要那种类型的导演。”你知道的，这就像他们在墨西哥的某座教堂里找到格鲁伯，然后对他说：“我们需要你破釜沉舟，重操旧业。”
And let's acknowledge the other shift is, I mean, it's what we've been like, you know, setting this up the entire miniseries, but it is so bizarre that he gets Spider-Man at that moment because they're almost calling him off the bench to do the thing he had sort of walked away from doing. Like he had worked so hard to not be seen as that guy and they were like, hey, the entire industry's changed, we need that guy. You know, it's like them finding the gruber like at the fucking church in Mexico going, we need you to cut your head and come back in the action.
他们需要的是一个狂热分子，这就是他们需要的。我的意思是，问题在于，作为一个漫画迷，我们当时所呼唤的，正是这样一个能够理解原作素材的人，或者至少能理解其精神内核的人——而当时没有人能做到这一点。每个人都在想：好吧，我们得让他们脱掉那些制服。我们得剥离这些，我们得让他们脚踏实地。而那正是……我们得让他们脱掉制服，我们得剥离这些，我们得让他们脚踏实地。这就是当时所有的冲动。但他并没有那样做。
We need an enthusiast, is what they need. I mean, the thing is, like, that's what, that's what, as a comic book fan, that's what we were calling for, was someone who understood the material, or at least the spirit of it in a way that, that didn't, nobody really did. Everyone was like, okay, we got to take him out of the costumes. We got to take him out of the, we got to ground them in this. And, and that was the, all, we gotta take him out of the costumes. We gotta take him out of this. We gotta ground them in this. And that was all the impulse. And he didn't do that.
对，因为蒂姆·伯顿、布莱恩·辛格，那些导演虽然名声很好，但在采访中他们会说：“哦，我其实从来不怎么看漫画。”你知道的，这当时被视为一种好事、好事、好事、好事、好事。你今年不会让我出丑，对吧？而山姆·雷米则完全是另一种风格。
Right, because yeah, Tim Burton, Brian Singer, those were directors where it's like they were well regarded directors, but in the interviews, they'd be like, yeah, I never really read a comic book. Like, you know, and that was seen as like, good, good, good, good, good. You're not gonna embarrass me this year or whatever, right? And yeah, yeah, Sam Raymean is a different good. You're not going to impair us this year or whatever. Right. And yeah, yeah, Sam Raymean is a different vibe.
我只记得当年走出第一部《蜘蛛侠》的影院时，心里想的是：这是我看过的第一部真正拍出漫画感觉的电影。有那么多人曾试图以一种字面上的方式来还原漫画感，比如迪克·特雷西式的风格，让画面看起来像一本漫画。但后来他们发现，你可以用插画的美学来拍电影，而那是第一部让我从情感上觉得这就是漫画的电影。他们保留了漫画那种矫揉造作的呈现方式，而我当时的感受是，当我读漫画时，我是把它们当严肃作品来看的，就像它们在画格与画格之间是有情绪流动的，而不仅仅是在画面周围加一个华丽的卷轴边框。这真的是
I just remember walking out of the first Spider-Man and going, that's the first movie I've seen that actually feels like a comic book. And so many people had tried to in a literal way, like Dick Tracy's style, make something look like a comic book. But then they're like, you can make a movie with the aesthetics of illustration. and that's the first movie where I'm like emotionally this feels like a comic book Right that they they took the archeness of its presentation and I the thing was with when I read comic books I treated them seriously like like they were they had a motion between the panels and it wasn't just putting a Persemin pracingium arch around a frame. It really was
完全不同的东西，我觉得他比任何人都更完美地捕捉到了这一点，而且其中的技术层面也太棒了，他简直就是把这个项目拿捏得死死的。直到《蜘蛛侠1》里他其实还显得挺克制的，然后到了《蜘蛛侠2》里，里面居然包含了一个真正的恐怖片场景——就是章鱼博士的那场外科手术戏——当时你会想：哦天哪，这才是那个导演。没错，没错，没错。
something else and I thought that he captured that for the first time more than anybody and then also the technical aspects of it were so great and it like he just sort of nailed it and it wasn't until actually I thought he was pretty muted for him in Spider-Man 1 and then Spider-Man 2 where they have an actual horror scene inside of it with the doc ock of surgery where you go like, oh God, that's the guy. That's right. Right. Right.
现在他完全找回自我了。没错。第一部感觉他还在试水阶段。对。好吧，你会慢慢看到的。对，我的意思是，这真的信息量很大。
Now he's totally back in it. Right. One it still sort of feels like he's auditioning a little bit. Yeah. Well, you'll get there. Yeah. No, I mean, it's a lot. It's a lot.
在进入下一个话题之前，还有一件事需要提一下，我想我们应该继续看下去。我刚进来时想说的是，在这部电影和试图将自己转型为严肃成人剧情片导演的《简单的计划》之间那三年里发生的事情，就是他整个电视帝国（的建立）。是的，这也是他的冬眠期的一部分，对吧？那是他进入“好吧，好吧，我在干别的”的状态的一部分。
The other thing just to call out before, I guess we should go on the box. I was came in and any other thoughts we have is that the other thing that happens in the three years between this and a simple plan when he sort of tries to remake himself as like a serious adult picture maker is the entire TV empire. Yeah. Which is part, that's part of his hibernation, right? That's part of him being like, okay, okay. Yeah. He's doing something else.
我想在我们继续讨论之前，还有一件事需要指出，我进来时想到的以及我们的其他看法是，在这部电影和《简单计划》之间的三年里，当他试图将自己重新塑造为严肃的成人电影制作者时，还发生了另一件事，那就是整个电视帝国。是的。这部分也是他隐退生活的一部分，对吧？这部分是他意识到，好吧，好吧。是的。他在做别的事情。
Yeah, and he's actually figuring out a really good path for him, which is kind of fascinating and probably both more lucrative and more like ability to have success and also not have your life determined by a bunch of morons who run movies to us. That's the biggest thing I think, Grom. Is he sort of gets his freedom, he gets his sort of like confidence, you know.
是的，而且他实际上为自己摸索出了一条非常好的道路，这有点迷人，可能既更赚钱，又更有成功的把握，同时又不会让自己的生活被一帮经营电影的白痴所左右。我觉得这才是最重要的事情，格罗姆。他某种程度上获得了自由，某种程度上获得了自信，你知道的。
He's built this little empire, it's syndicated, they're not really beholden to anybody. It's ever expanding. He's employing all of his friends and his brothers. And it's like that, it puts a lot of the anxieties to bed, maybe, so that he's able to come back and just go like, what do I want to do as a filmmaker? That's the only concern. Yeah, it makes total sense to me that it would take something like Spider-Man to be like, okay, well, that's a thing with enough resources and enough, you know, like, whatever, to pull me off of this other thing, which I control everything and I don't have to listen to any
他建立了自己的小帝国，它是联合发行的，他们其实不依附于任何人。它在不断扩展。他雇用了所有的朋友和兄弟。这就像是，也许能消除很多焦虑，让他能够回来，然后只是想：作为一名电影制作人，我想做什么？这才是唯一的关切。是的，这对我完全说得通，需要像《蜘蛛侠》这样的作品出现，才能说，好吧，这是一部有足够资源和足够什么的、能把我从这另一件事情中拉开的作品，在这另一件事中我掌控一切，而且我不用听任何
idiots, you know, and that's a good position to be in in your career to be able to say no to everything, which he probably did. He, you know, like, he probably said no to a ton of things that we would have loved him to do, but it just wasn't right. And we're more power to him. We'll do, uh, at some point in some episode, but there, he's one of those guys with there is an entire Wikipedia entry just on unmade Sam Raimi projects. It's not a subsection of his wiki page. It is its own page. I'll say a non-marchindized spotlight. I know you've made the comparison very aptly
笨蛋的话，你知道的，在你的职业生涯中，能够对所有事情说不，这是一个很好的立场，他大概也这么做了。他，你知道的，他大概对我们很希望他做的很多事情都说不，但就是不合适。这更增强了他的能力。我们会在某个时刻、某集节目中做……但是，他是那种拥有整篇维基百科条目只收录未拍成的山姆·雷米项目的人。这不是他维基页面的一个小节。它就是它自己的页面。我说的是一个没有商品化的聚光灯。我知道你已经非常贴切地做了对比
and number of times now, Roman, but watching this, I kept on thinking like, God, I really wish there had been like a Sega Genesis game. It just, you could make sure the shootout game with all of these guys who would translate so perfectly into that sort of pixelated art. Someone make that now, make a, you know, a web browser shooting game, 16 bit. I want to see, you know, frickin, Keith David and Lang's Hendrickson's faces all pixelated.
好多次了，罗曼，但看着这个，我一直觉得，天哪，我真的很希望有个世嘉MD（Sega Genesis）的游戏。就是，你可以弄个枪战游戏，里面有所有这些家伙，他们能完美地转化成那种像素风的艺术。现在就有人去做一个吧，做一个网页浏览器枪战游戏，16位元的。我想看到，你知道的，该死的基斯·大卫（Keith David）和兰斯·亨克尔森（Lance Henriksen）的脸都变成像素风。
Like, give me that, please. With Gene Hackman is the final boss, Obviously, right. Yes, right. himself with a little bowler hat. We've showed about this before, but it is so funny that like casting Commissioner Gordon now is like casting a yago or something. And it's like, who is worthy of picking up the bad?
请给我来一个，谢谢。吉恩·哈克曼（Gene Hackman）作为最终Boss，显然是吧。是的，没错。他戴着一个小圆顶礼帽。我们以前谈过这个，但是把现在的戈登局长选角弄得就像选一个雅戈（Iago）或者别的什么一样，这太搞笑了，就好像，谁配得上拿起这个警徽？
And at that point, they were like, I don't know, who's some guy who looks like a cop? Like, patting him never fit Commissioner Gordon as a type. You've got love of them. I mean, I love them both in all movies and as Commissioner Gordon, but it is funny that
而在那个时候，他们就像是，我不知道，谁是个看起来像警察的家伙？帕特·亨利（Pat Hingle）从来都不适合作为戈登局长的典型形象。你得爱他们。我的意思是，我在所有的电影里都爱他们俩，也爱他们饰演的戈登局长，但搞笑的是
every other Commissioner Gordon, I mean, the one's post, Gary Olman, right? Yeah. It's like a soft, spoken, intelligent, cerebral kind of, you know, war, weary cop. Pangles just like basically got a pocket watch. He's like, Batman, are you here yet? Mr. Freeze is tearing up the museum. Like, you know, Pangles just like basically got a pocket watch. He's like, Batman, are you here yet? Mr. Freeze is tearing up the museum. Like, you know, he's just, it also, it feels like every scene right before he goes on camera. He goes like, what's my guy's name again?
其他每一任戈登局长，我的意思是，加里·奥德曼（Gary Oldman）之后的那些，对吧？是的。就像是一个轻声细语、聪明、富有理智的、你知道的、厌战的警察。而帕特·亨利基本上就像带着一块怀表。他就像是：蝙蝠侠，你来了吗？急冻人正在把博物馆拆了。就像是，你知道的，帕特·亨利基本上就像带着一块怀表。他就像是：蝙蝠侠，你来了吗？急冻人正在把博物馆拆了。就像是，你知道的，他只是，而且，感觉他就像在每次上镜头前的那一秒。他会说：我的角色的名字叫什么来着？
Oh, exactly. Commissioner what? Um, so, uh, Pat, anything else? Yeah? At the end, I think, I mean, they, it's fun that the last 20 minutes of this movie are like an extended work, right? Like everything from the Capriots death on. And it the payoff, like I love court kind of turning superhuman for, you know, at this
哦，没错。什么局长？嗯，那么，帕特，还有别的吗？是的？最后，我觉得，我的意思是，他们，有趣的是，这部电影的最后20分钟就像是一场加长的枪战，对吧？就像从卡普里奥（Caprio）之死开始的一切。而且它的回报，就像我喜欢科特（Court）在这个
last moment where you just like shoots people, binds back and like you get like his full powers and realize how much he's been holding back. And the whole premise of like, she's literally not a better gunfighter than Jean Hackman. But in this moment, she is. And both you believe it, Jean Hackman believes it. They just made that really work for me. They built up this whole thing to lead to this moment and it's super convincing and it's very satisfying ending. And then she throws the Marshall Star at court who's now gonna be like the new Sheriff in town. Just what you wanted, even though you haven't
最后的时刻变得有点像超人，在那里他只是开枪射击，反弹回来，然后你得到了他的全部力量，并意识到他一直在压抑多少。整个设定就是，她字面意思上枪法并不比吉恩·哈克曼好。但在这一刻，她是。而且你信了，吉恩·哈克曼也信了。他们把这一点处理得真的很好，为我。他们铺垫了这一切来引向这一刻，而且极具说服力，是一个非常满足的结局。然后她把法警星章扔给科特，他现在要成为镇上的新警长了。这正是你想要的，尽管你还没
think you're gonna be right at it. And you're like, yep, oh, that's perfect. It has all these things that come together and then it's like black and then it's like done and it's like no wasted time. You know, I mean sheriff of what's left of the fuck. I know. Not the greatest town. Yeah, he left the she left quite a mess in her way. He's in a lot of people showing up being like, hey, is this where we do the shooting? And it's like, no, we don't do that anymore.
觉得你马上就能看到。然后你会觉得：没错，哦，太完美了。它把所有这些东西汇聚在一起，然后就像是黑屏，然后就像是结束了，就像是没有浪费时间。你知道的，我的意思是，废墟里还剩什么的警长。我知道。不是最棒的小镇。是的，她离开时留下一堆烂摊子。他有很多各种各样的人出现，然后说：嘿，这是我们开枪的地方吗？然后就像是：不，我们不再那样做了。
Like, is that happening over and over again? Like, I don't know. It is this thing. I love though that, you know, she throws the star back to him. You're completing his arc, right? Here is this guy who never wanted to be a killer who was forced to shoot this pastor who's tried to recommit himself to the cloth because he feels like he can never get over this sin.
就像是，这种事一遍又一遍地发生吗？就像是，我不知道。但这就是我所喜欢的，你知道的，她把星章扔回给他。你完成了他的成长弧光，对吧？这就是那个从来不想当杀手、却被迫射杀这个牧师的家伙，他试图重新投身于教会，因为他觉得自己永远无法克服这个罪孽。
They tease him out. He realizes these innate instincts he has. He cannot help but kill when placed in this situation. That first moment, his first shootout, when you truly feel like he's ready to die and he is surprised that his hand reached for the gun and shot that fast. It's really, really cool.
他们引诱他出来。他意识到了自己拥有的这种与生俱来的本能。当处于这种境地时，他情不自禁地开始杀戮。那个最初的时刻，他的第一场枪战，当你真正觉得他已经准备好去死了，而他惊讶于自己的手竟然去抓枪并且开枪那么快。这真的，真的很酷。
It's shot really well. And he's also his twitch when they, they give him guns to like, yeah, to, to, you know, and he, he's looking at him and he knows how to use them and he knows he wants to touch them. And it's all there. It's shot really, really well. And, and it's super convincing. And then you get this moment at the end where you're like, I wasn't thinking about this.
拍得真的很好。而且他在他们给枪他的时候，他的抽搐，为了让他们，你知道的，他看着枪，他知道怎么用它们，他知道他想抚摸它们。这一切都在那里。拍得真的，真的很棒，而且极具说服力。然后你在最后得到了这样一个时刻，你会觉得：我之前根本没想到这个。
I wasn't thinking about the redemption of court this whole time at all. And, and then it's like, oh, this is the perfect marriage of the things he's feeling and wants to, you know, make amends for. And his literal skill set, you know, and it makes tons of sense. It just, it just, it just works. It feels like this very clean, neat, tidy, happy ending. That is fully earned. Yeah.
我这一整都没在想科特得到救赎这回事，然后就像是，哦，这是他内心的感受、想要弥补的事情与他字面上的技能的完美结合，你知道的，这太合乎逻辑了。它就是，它就是，它就是行之有效。感觉这是一个非常干净、整洁、利落、幸福的结局。这是完全应得的。是的。
But, but he like lingers on it for an additional moment before it fades to black where you see him looking at the badge and considering it. Like, Remy could have cut like a second or two earlier and it was just he has the badge, everything's in order and it does feel like there's this extra moment there of him looking at it and debating whether or not he wants to do this and I think of like all three Spider-Man movies and like that. It is this thing that's so distinctive in those movies that all three movies end with this weird lingering moment of Mary Jane being like, what happens now? You know, like all three of them end on her face, I think. And the evil dead movies obviously all
但是，但是他在那上面多停留了一会儿，在画面淡出成黑色之前，你能看到他看着徽章并端详着它。雷米本可以早剪掉一两秒钟，那样的话就是他拿到了徽章，一切都尘埃落定，但感觉确实有这样一个额外的时刻，他在看着它，并且在纠结他是否真的想这么做，我想到了所有三部《蜘蛛侠》电影，以及类似的事情。这是那些电影中非常独特的东西，所有三部电影都以一个奇怪的、挥之不去的玛丽·简的镜头结束，好像在说：接下来会发生什么？你知道的，就像所有三部电影最后都定格在她的脸上，我想。而《鬼玩人》电影显然都
end with Ash getting like upended in some way, but I feel like he always like for a, he always needs to pull the rug a little bit or at least leave some kind of graduate-esque lingering question of like, but is it really going to be that tidy? The guy, the guy still lets odds with himself a little bit, you know? That's interesting. I think I read that differently. I think I read it as like taking time for you to recognize the genius of all this stuff coming together in the right way. It's like part of way I read that too.
以阿什（Ash）以某种方式被颠覆而告终，但我感觉他总是喜欢稍微掀翻地毯一下，或者至少留下某种充满《毕业生》风格的、挥之不去的疑问，仿佛在说：但事情真的会这么整洁吗？这家伙，这家伙内心仍然有点跟自己过不去，你知道的？这很有趣。我觉得我的理解不太一样。我觉得我的理解是，花时间让你去认识到所有这些东西以正确的方式汇聚在一起的天才之处。这也是我解读的那一部分原因。
But that's that's super fascinating. I do think he becomes sheriff, but I don't think it's something that like it's not a tidy resolution in the end. I don't think he can take it on easily. I think he's nothing else. Yes, to start hiring a bunch of contractors to come. It's got shit to do. Such a good fucking movie. It's a good fucking movie. It's a good fucking movie. You want to play that box office? Wait, wait, last last thing, Lance Hendrickson's death, the squib shot. Also, the speed with which everyone takes all of his clothing. Oh, I know, yeah.
但那，那超级迷人。我确实觉得他成了警长，但我不认为这是一个，最后不是一个整洁的结局。我不认为他能轻松地接受它。我觉得他……别的不用说。是的，开始雇佣一堆承包商来。他有一堆破事要处理。真他妈是一部好电影。真是一部好电影。真是一部好电影。你想聊聊那个票房吗？等等，等等，最后一件事，兰斯·亨克尔森的死，血包（squib）镜头。还有，所有人抢他衣服的速度。哦，我知道，对。
It starts fighting each other over it. And him, like the image of him and is just his long underwear after he's been stripped and he's like, is this naked, like plucked chicken looking thing is a real, also kind of like pathetic and sad and is a good image to end on him with with all of his like since he's all surface, you know, he's all like leather and, you know, and playing with all of this stuff.
他们开始为此大打出手。而他，他被剥光衣服后只穿着长内衣的形象，就像是一只被拔了毛的、看起来光秃秃的死鸡一样的形象，既有点可悲又让人难过，而且是一个用来收尾他的很好的画面，他所有的，因为他整个人都是表面功夫，你知道的，他浑身都是皮衣，你知道的，还在摆弄所有这些东西。
It was all the costume basically. I mean, not at all, but, yeah. Lovely and Sandrookson at all times. He also seems like someone who would scare the shit out of me in real life, but that's absolutely. Yeah. The box of his game for this one is great. I got to be honest. Okay. Well, this phone came out February 10th, 1995. Okay. This is a real, there's a lot of
基本上全是戏服。我是说，倒也不是完全如此，但是，是的。随时随地都爱兰斯·亨克尔森。他看起来也是那种在现实生活中会把我吓得半死的人，但绝对是这样。是的。这一期的票房游戏很棒。老实说，好吧。好吧，这部电影于1995年2月10日上映。好吧。这是一个真正的，这里面有很多
bends choices in here. I think. Oh, wow. Quick and the dead open number two six and a half million dollars on its way to an 18 million dollar gross, which is about half its budget. So rude. Not go bad. Unfortunately, but it is also opening behind a very dumb comedy that was the launch, I would say, of a major comedy star. So is this a magic this like sort of a Ben pick? It's a bit of a Ben pick. And it is indeed the film Billy Madison. Wow. And I do think getting your lunch eaten by Billy Madison, if you're like Sharon Stone and you're like, you know, big fancy western, it's not a good look, right? Yeah. It's rough, especially that one where it's right to particularly dumb style movie.
古怪的选择，我觉得。哦，哇。《致命快感》（The Quick and the Dead）开画票房650万美元，朝着1800万美元的总票房迈进，大约是其预算的一半。真惨。也不算太糟。不幸的是，它上映时还落后于一部非常愚蠢的喜剧，可以说那是一部重要喜剧明星的崛起之作。所以这是一个Ben精选的电影吗？这有点算是Ben精选的。它确实是电影《光辉岁月》（Billy Madison）。哇。而且我确实觉得，如果你像莎朗·斯通（Sharon Stone）一样，拍了一部你知道的、大制作的豪华西部片，结果被《光辉岁月》抢了饭碗，这可真不好看，对吧？是的，太惨了，特别是那部电影是那种特别愚蠢风格的电影。
Although I think it's a very good, like that's one of my favorites. So it's absolutely. Absolutely. We all, yeah, that's top here. Sam. Yeah. Yeah. Right. We all, yeah, that's top here. Sam, yeah, yeah. Timmer Davis is also someone, if there was ever a Ben region in March madness, she is a real candidate.
虽然我觉得那是一部非常好的，那就是我最喜欢的电影之一。所以绝对是。绝对是。我们都，是的，那是顶级水准。山姆。是的。没错。我们都，是的，那是顶级水准，山姆，是的，是的。塔玛拉·戴维斯（Tamara Davis）也是那种人，如果在疯狂三月里有什么Ben选择区的话，她绝对是一个强有力的候选人。
Yeah, well, you know, it's a weird, it's a weird bunch of movies. It's gone crazy, which I've never seen, but is the Drew Barrymore Michael Ironside kind of like action in D, right? Yeah. Then CB4, which is is a crucial part of the art effects. Yep. Then Billy Madison, then best man, the Dean Cain, anti-dick. I've never seen that. That doesn't really exist. But what's the next one, David? It's a little film called Half Baked. Oh, yeah. Half Baked is like hands down the movie I've seen the most.
是的，好吧，你知道的，这是一堆很奇怪的电影。有《疯狂》（Guncrafter），我从来没看过，但那是德鲁·巴里摩尔（Drew Barrymore）和迈克尔·艾恩赛德（Michael Ironside）那种B级动作片，对吧？是的。然后是《CB4》，那是亚特·方胜（Alez Winter）作品中至关重要的一部分。没错。然后是《比利·麦迪逊》，然后是《最佳男主角》，迪恩·凯恩（Dean Cain）反恶作剧的电影。我从来没看过。那其实并不存在。但下一部是什么，David？是一部叫《半烘熟》（Half Baked）的小电影。哦，是的。《半烘熟》绝对是我看过最多的电影。
Dude, I'm not too surprised to hear that. Um, then skipped parts, which is like a Jennifer Jason Lee movie that never really came out. Then the Britney Spears movie Crossroads. Yes. Uh, and then, uh, she made like a Basquiat documentary. And also an incredible, incredible amount of music videos for awesome bands. Like, yeah, some really big music video director. Some really huge stuff.
老兄，听到这个我并不太吃惊。嗯，然后是《被跳过的部分》（Skipped Parts），那是一部詹妮弗·杰森·李（Jennifer Jason Lee）的电影，从未真正上映。然后是布兰妮·斯皮尔斯（Britney Spears）的电影《十字路口》（Crossroads）。是的。然后，她还拍了一部关于巴斯奎特（Basquiat）的纪录片。还有，令人难以置信的大量为超棒乐队制作的音乐录影带。就像是，一些真正大牌的音乐录影带导演。一些非常重磅的作品。
A lot of TV as well. But also, let's not brush over her Basquiat documentary. She worked at an art gallery in 1986, or is it 83? She was friends with Baskot. It's a documentary of footage she shot interviewing him as her friend. Right, right. Two years before he died and she sat on it
还有很多电视作品。但是，我们也不要轻描淡写她拍的巴斯奎特纪录片。她在1986年时在一家艺术画廊工作，还是83年？她是巴斯奎特的朋友。这是她采访他的作为朋友拍摄的素材剪辑成的纪录片。对，对。在他去世前两年，她把这些素材压箱底
for 20 years before she was ready to edit it. So it's like someone making a documentary with all this unbelievable unseen footage from. Fine, we're doing Tamara Davis. She's on it. Okay. A list. Half the podcast did, I. It's decided. Okay. List. Half podcasted.
了20年，直到她准备好剪辑它。所以这就好像有人用所有这些令人难以置信的、从未见过的素材制作了一部纪录片。好吧，我们要聊塔玛拉·戴维斯。就定她了。好吧。A级名单。一半的播客都，我。就这么决定了。好吧。A级名单。一半的播客都。
I don't know. Billy Madison number one. Quick and a dead number two. Number number three is a, it's a sort of, it's a holdover from Christmas season. It's a very Tony, pretty, epic movie that is not very good. It's one of those movies that was clearly a major Oscar play and was widely ignored except for technical nominations. But it
我不知道。《比利·麦迪逊》第一名。《致命快感》第二名。第三名是一个，它有点像是圣诞档期的遗留作品。这是一部非常华丽、漂亮、史诗级的电影，但并不是很好。它是那种明显在冲击奥斯卡大奖、却除了技术类提名之外被广泛忽视的电影。但它
is a major moment for its star who is on the up and up. It's one of those movies that is basically forgotten except as sort of a title and it's scores kind of famous. Huh, it's a period film. It is. It's a, it's a, it's a Western as well. It's another Western actually. We forgot to mention this one.
为其主演来说是一个重要的时刻，这位主演正处于上升期。它是那种基本上被遗忘了的电影，除了作为一个片名之外，它的配乐还挺有名的。哼，这是一部古装片。是的。这是一部，它也是一部西部片。其实是另一部西部片。我们刚才忘了提这部了。
So frontier movie big. It's, it's long, it's dramatic. There's crying. People die, you know. Did, did you have a guess until he said Western Roman, it looked like you had a notion. No, I, nothing is ringing a bell with me. And it was just like, this is a hallmark of me listening to the show and listening to the box office games.
所以是一部宏大的边境电影。它很长，很戏剧化。有哭泣。有人死去，你知道的。在你说是西部片之前，你有猜过吗，罗曼，看起来你有个概念。没有，我脑子里一点印象也没有。这就像是，这简直是我听这个节目和听票房游戏的标志。
So yeah, I don't, I have no idea. The score is sending me because I feel like I, I keep track of like those sort of, it's a famous one overused scores overused in trailer that people even forget what movie they're originally from exactly that would be the holiday time of 94 it was released Christmas 94 it was a hit it made a lot of money it made not maybe not is enough that it made it made $66 million, $160 worldwide. It was a pretty solid hit for what I think is an R rated super long. It's not, it's like two hours, 20 minutes or whatever.
所以，是的，我不知道，我完全没头绪。这个配乐让我抓狂，因为我觉得我一直在留意那些，这是一个著名的、在预告片中被过度使用的配乐，以至于人们甚至忘记了它最初出自哪部电影。没错，那将是94年的假日档期，它于94年圣诞节上映，它是一部热门片，赚了很多钱，也许没有赚到，它赚了6600万美元，全球1.6亿美元。对于一部我认为是R级、超级长的电影来说，它算是一个相当稳固的热门。它不短，它大概有两个小时20分钟还是多久。
Yeah. What about the director? He's a director who has made a lot of epic films. He's a fairly major director, but I would say he is not the best director of the films. Okay. He's a fairly major director, but I would say he is the best. It's not as weak is it? It is as weak. It is as weak. So what's the zwick after glory? It's after glory. He also did a movie called Leaving Normal in between this and glory with the Christian Loddy and Mike Tilly. I think one of his better movies. Of course, he does courage on the Fire right after this movie.
那导演呢？他是一个拍过很多史诗级电影的导演。他是一个相当重要的导演，但我会说他并不是这些电影里最好的导演。好吧。他是一个相当重要的导演，但我会说他是最好的。这不是兹威克（Zwick）吧？这就是兹威克。这就是兹威克。所以是兹威克在《光荣战役》（Glory）之后的作品？这是《光荣战役》之后的作品。他在《光荣战役》和这部电影之间还拍了一部叫《远离正常》（Leaving Normal）的电影，由克里斯蒂娜·拉蒂（Christine Lahti）和梅格·蒂利（Meg Tilly）主演。我觉得这是他较好的电影之一。当然，他紧接着这部电影就拍了《生死豪情》（Courage Under Fire）。
I already mentioned that this episode. So is this the last samurai? It's not the last samurai. That's in the 2000s. Okay, that's what it's really for off. But that's the only big thick of. That's first time I remember his name. That is his Wic, of course.
我这集已经提过了。所以这是《最后的武士》（The Last Samurai）吗？不是《最后的武士》。那是2000年代的。好吧，那是真正大火的作品。但那是唯一一个大热的。那是第一个我记住他名字的作品。那就是兹威克，当然。
He also made Blood Diamond. He made the Siege. He made Love and Other Drugs. Somewhat bizarrely. It's not legends of the fall. It's legends of the fall. Okay. Okay. Brad Pitt, Anthony Hopkins, Aiden Quinn, Julia Ormond, movie I recently watched for reasons I cannot remember. Can confirm. Pretty boring.
他还拍了《血钻》（Blood Diamond）。他拍了《紧急动员》（The Siege）。他拍了《爱情与灵药》（Love and Other Drugs）。有点奇怪的是。这不是《燃情岁月》（Legends of the Fall）。这就是《燃情岁月》。好吧。好吧。布拉德·皮特、安东尼·霍普金斯、艾丹·奎因（Aiden Quinn）、茱莉亚·奥蒙德（Julia Ormond），我最近为了一个我想不起来的原因而重温的电影。可以证实。相当无聊。
Look at that. Right. Right. And it's kind of like a pit performance because this is post, you know, pit emerging as like him Bo King, Johnny Sway, Thelma and Louise, cool world, right? Like it's post that. It's in his like river runs through it, you know, interview with the vampire legends of the fall days where he's so pretty, but he's boring. Like, yeah, he doesn't get to have any fun. Like, and it's like, once he's in 12 monkeys and true romance and shit, it's like, fun.
你看。没错。没错。这有点像是皮特的某种表演，因为这是在，你知道的，皮特崛起成为像万人迷之后的时期，比如《末路狂花》（Thelma and Louise）、《美女闯天关》（Cool World），对吧？是在那之后。是在他拍《大河恋》（A River Runs Through It）、你知道的、《夜访吸血鬼》（Interview with the Vampire）、《燃情岁月》的日子里，那时他长得太漂亮了，但很无聊。就像是，是的，他一点乐趣都没有。而且就像是，一旦他演了《十二只猴子》（12 Monkeys）和《浪漫风暴》（True Romance）这些烂片，就，很有趣。
Yes. Right. Brad Pitt is actually a very twitchy over the top actor. It is funny that 95 is seven and 12 monkeys. Like legends of the fall interview with the vampire is peak like 94, let Brad Pitt just be pretty. Let him stay. He's straight up bad in interlude the vampire.
是的。没错。布拉德·皮特其实是一个非常抽搐、夸张的演员。有趣的是，95年是《七宗罪》（Seinfeld）和《十二只猴子》。就像《燃情岁月》和《夜访吸血鬼》是巅峰期一样，比如94年，就让布拉德·皮特当个美男子吧。让他待在那。他在《夜访吸血鬼》里简直糟透了。
Like Tom Cruise acts him off the screen in that movie and it's annoying because it should be like, here we go. Cruise and Pitt, you know, like, you know, this is gonna be great and Pitt is such a dish rag in that movie. And in Legend of the Fall is a little more fun but he's, you know, just very serious, very serious. Sure, sure.
就像汤姆·克鲁斯（Tom Cruise）在那部电影里的演技把他秒杀得体无完肤，这很烦人，因为这本来应该是：来吧。克鲁斯和皮特，你知道的，你知道的，这将会太棒了，而皮特在这部电影里就像一块抹布。而在《燃情岁月》里稍微有趣一点，但他你知道的，只是非常严肃，非常严肃。当然，当然。
Yeah, yeah, it's a James Horner score. Right, yeah, no, no, no, no, no. but he's just very serious, very serious. Sure. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. It's a James Horner score. Right. Yeah, no, no, no, no. Yeah. For some reason, I always think that movies earlier, because of how big it was for Pitt's career. But yes, yeah.
是的，是的，这是詹姆士·霍纳（James Horner）的配乐。没错，是的，不，不，不，不，不。但他只是非常严肃，非常严肃。当然。当然。是的。是的。这是詹姆士·霍纳的配乐。没错。是的，不，不，不，不。不知为何，我一直以为那部电影更早，因为这对皮特的职业生涯来说太重要了。但确实，是的。
That's why I was second-guessing it. Number four is a, you know, a dramedy female characters. I've never seen it. It's the final film of a fairly well-done director in a very long career, making Hollywood comedies and dramas. Three female stars, I would say two very famous at the time, one kind of on the up and up, but famous now. I always get these confused as a boys on the side. It's boys on the side. Okay. Well done. Who directed it, Griffin?
这就是为什么我刚才在犹豫。第四名是一个，你知道的，带有女性角色的轻喜剧（dramedy）。我从来没看过。这是一位在好莱坞喜剧和剧情片领域有着极长职业生涯、相当出色的导演的最后一部电影。三位女主角，我想说其中两位当时非常有名，一位有点在上升期，但现在很有名。我总是把这部和《油脂妹》（Boys on the Side）搞混。这就是《油脂妹》。好吧。干得好。谁是导演，格里芬？
That's what I'm trying to remember. Boys on the side is Herbert Ross. It's a Herbert Rod. It's his last film. Okay. After a very obviously Herbert Ross made funny lady and yes, the turning point and the goodbye girl and, you know, pennies from having he made so many foot loose, you know, steel magnolias, he made tons of movies. It's written by Don Rousse, which is interesting.
这正是我在努力回想的。《油脂妹》是赫伯特·罗斯（Herbert Ross）导演的。这就是赫伯特·罗斯的最后一部电影。好吧。在非常显然赫伯特·罗斯拍了《妙女郎》（Funny Lady）、是的，《转折点》（The Turning Point）、《再见女郎》（The Goodbye Girl）以及，你知道的，《妙想天开》（Pennies from Heaven），他拍了那么多……《浑身是劲》（Footloose），你知道的，《钢木兰》（Steel Magnolias），他拍了无数电影。编剧是唐·罗斯（Don Roos），这很有趣。
Griffin, you know, before obviously he becomes a director. Yeah, Merritt Wuppie Goldberg drew Barrymore, Mary Louise Parker. I get boys on the side confused with how to make an American quilt. Yeah, that's fair. I get boys on the side confused with how to make an American quilt. Yeah, that's fair. I mean, I think that's okay. And I feel like there's one other movie of that era where I'm just like, which combination of the actors is it?
格里芬，你知道的，显然在他成为导演之前。是的，玛丽·露易斯·帕克（Mary-Louise Parker）、乌比·戈德堡（Whoopi Goldberg）、德鲁·巴里摩尔。我总是把《油脂妹》和《编织恋爱梦》（How to Make an American Quilt）搞混。是的，这很公平。我总是把《油脂妹》和《编织恋爱梦》搞混。是的，这很公平。我的意思是，我觉得这没问题。而且我觉得那个时代还有另一部电影，我当时就在想：那是哪位演员的组合来着？
Those movies where they're kind of generational. And I'm like, which ones Drew Barrymore, which ones were on the ride or which ones will be, which ones I am banged craft? Exactly. Yeah. Is anyone seen, boys on the side? I am banged craft. Exactly. Yeah. Is anyone seen boys on the side? I've not. No, I've not seen boys on the side.
那些带有时代印记的电影。我当时想：哪个是德鲁·巴里摩尔，哪个是薇诺娜·赖德（Winona Ryder），哪个是，哪个是帕克·波西（Parker Posey）？没错。是的。有人看过《油脂妹》吗？我没有。不，我没看过《油脂妹》。
It is really amazing to watch this in person because I was 20 years old when this came out and I have no memory of it whatsoever. I think you were maybe nine, Griff. I don't even want to be a whole lot of that. I think you were like six. I was six. I was six. And so this is a pleasure to watch. So honestly, he was about to turn six.
亲眼见证这一幕真是太神奇了，因为这片上映时我20岁，我对它完全没有任何记忆。我想你当时可能九岁吧，格里芬。我甚至不想说得那么夸张。我觉得你当时大概六岁。我当时六岁。我当时六岁。所以看这个是一种享受。老实说，他快要满六岁了。
My birthday is coming up. All right. Number five of the box office. It's a hit comedy that had come out in Christmas. It's made $111 million. Is it like a family comedy? No, it is more of a teen gross out vibe although the characters are not teens.
我的生日就要到了。好的。票房榜第五名。这是一部在圣诞节上映的热门喜剧。它获得了1.11亿美元的票房。它是那种家庭喜剧吗？不，它更有一种青少年恶俗喜剧（gross out）的氛围，尽管角色不是青少年。
Sure, okay, so it's a 1994 gross out comedy. Is it, is it Dumb and Dumber? It's dumb and Dumber. Yeah, wow. Yeah. Another Ben pick, Bright Ben. I'm sure you liked Dumb and Dumber. No, I hated it.
当然，好吧，所以这是一部1994年的恶俗喜剧。是，是《阿呆与阿瓜》（Dumb and Dumber）吗？是《阿呆与阿瓜》。是的，哇。是的。另一个Ben的选择，杰出的Ben。我确信你喜欢《阿呆与阿瓜》。不，我讨厌它。
It was actually really like felt like soap and youth me kind of. You found it disrespectful. Yeah, it was disrespectful. It's actually really like felt like so beneath me kind of you found a disrespectful. Yeah, it was disrespectful. It's tasteless. You know, I'm sorry, sorry for saying anything, Ben. Yeah. I mean, I don't love when somebody just makes a really loud annoying noise for a long extended period of time driving a hitman insane. Not your kind of leading him to have a heart attack. That isn't hilarious to me. Some other movies in the content. You've got nobody's fool, the Paul Newman Oscar vehicle. You've got in the mouth of madness,
它实际上真的让人觉得，就像是贬低了我一样。你觉得它很不尊重人。是的，它很不尊重人。这很没品。你知道的，我很抱歉，抱歉说了什么，Ben。是的。我的意思是，我不喜欢有人只是连续很长时间发出非常响亮、讨厌的噪音，把一个杀手逼疯。不是那种导致他心脏病发作的。这对我来说一点也不好笑。榜单上的其他电影。你有《大智若愚》（Nobody's Fool），保罗·纽曼（Paul Newman）的奥斯卡冲奖片。你有《战栗黑洞》（In the Mouth of madness），
a little bit of you we've discussed before, very cute movie. Great, great. We're seeing the theater and I enjoyed your coverage of it. I think that one's another underrated movie. Agreed. I think that was similarly kind of the quick and the dead of that series. Yeah. Yeah.
我们之前讨论过的一部小众电影，非常酷的电影。太棒了，太棒了。我们在影院看过，我很喜欢你们对它的报道。我觉得那也是另一部被严重低估的电影。同意。我觉得那同样有点像是那个系列的《致命快感》。是的。是的。
You got the kind of mostly forgotten film murder in the first, which was one of the Dan and Kevin Bacon Oscar play. Yeah. Exactly. One of the many early 90s movie, the Kevin Bacon Popson, and he got like a sag nomination and got an Oscar. You know, like there's just like that run of bacon in the 90s, where it's like he's it's post, you know, cute bacon in the 80s. It's him proving himself like JFK, few good men, riverwile, murder in the first Apollo 13. Right. I don't need to be the star. I want to do good supporting parts in big movies. Yeah. He's good in all of them and he's always overlooked. Is Gary Oldman the other counterpart in that one or am I thinking of a different movie?
你还有那部基本上被遗忘的电影《一级谋杀》（Murder in the First），那是克里斯蒂安·史莱特（Christian Slater）和凯文·贝肯（Kevin Bacon）的奥斯卡冲奖片。是的。没错。这是90年代初凯文·贝肯众多热门电影之一，当时他获得了美国演员工会奖（SAG）提名并获得了奥斯卡。你知道的，就像凯文·贝肯在90年代的那段全盛期，那是他在80年代那种可爱形象之后，证明自己的时期，比如《刺杀肯尼迪》（JFK）、《义海雄风》（A Few Good Men）、《大河恋》、《一级谋杀》、《阿波罗13号》（Apollo 13）。没错。我不需要当主角。我想在大电影里演好配角。是的。他在所有这些电影里都演得很好，但总是被忽视。加里·奥德曼是那部电影里的另一个对手吗，还是我想的是另一部电影？
Well, Gary Oldman, of course, is in JFK. He plays Lee Harvey. No, but in murder. Yes, he is in murder in the first with Christian Slater. Right. Slater is the, he's the do gooder lawyer who is defending Kevin Bacon. And I think Oldman might be the villain lawyer or something. a good lawyer who is defending Kevin Bacon. And I think Oldman might be the villain lawyer or something. He's the associate prison warden of Alton. He's the prison warden there. That's right.
嗯，加里·奥德曼当然演了《刺杀肯尼迪》。他饰演李·哈维（Lee Harvey）。不，但在《谋杀》里。是的，他和克里斯蒂安·史莱特一起演了《一级谋杀》。没错，史莱特饰演那个为凯文·贝肯辩护的正直律师。我想奥德曼可能是那个反派律师什么的。那个为凯文·贝肯辩护的正直律师。我想奥德曼可能是那个反派律师什么的。他是阿尔卡特拉兹岛（Alcatraz）的副监狱长。他是那里的监狱长。没错。
Yeah. Oh, yeah, he's actually really good. This is one of those movies that's like, it's a total six out of 10 with the actors, Slater is kind of whatever, but like everyone else is good because William H. Macy is in it. And Beth David's Brad Dorif, Arley Irmy, Tobalowski, Mia Kerr. Arley Irmy is the judge, I think.
哦，对，他其实演得非常好。这是一部那种总体来说在演员阵容上能得6分（满分10分）的电影，史莱特表现平平，但其他所有人都很好，因为威廉姆·H·梅西（William H. Macy）在里面。还有贝丝·格兰特（Beth Grant）、布拉德·道里夫（Brad Dourif）、R·李·艾尔梅（R. Lee Ermey）、理查德·坎德（Richard Kind），不对，里奇·托博尔斯基（Richie Tobolowski）、米娅·柯施纳（Mia Kirshner）。R·李·艾尔梅好像演的是法官。
That's what he has a lot of fun. It's a very subtle performance, of course, by Arley Irmy. Ben, another film here, I'm noticing that maybe you were interested in number nine, the jerky boys. In theaters. No, David, you're nine, the jerky boys. In theaters. No, David, you're completely, you're completely off. Of course, Frank Hall.
这就是他觉得很有趣的地方。当然，这是R·李·艾尔梅的一个非常微妙的表演。Ben，这里还有一部电影，我注意到你可能对第九名感兴趣，是《杰基小子》（The Jerky Boys）。在影院上映。不，David，你完全，你完全猜错了。当然是弗兰克·卡洛（Frank Callo）。
Of course. Frank Hall. You know, I was too busy just deep into reading, Lobby Dick and, you know, find the rest of literature. I would never laugh, you know, like a guy who says, you kicked my dog. And number 10 at the box office, Highlander three, the sorcerer, also known as Highlander, the final dimension. Another Ben pick. Another Ben pick, of course, because can we say Ben is just, he's been petitioning to do Highlander
当然是弗兰克·卡洛。你知道的，我当时太忙了，正沉迷于阅读《白鲸记》（Moby Dick）和，你知道的，寻找其余的文学作品。我绝不会笑，你知道的，就像一个说“你踢了我的狗”的家伙。而票房榜第十名是《高地人3：魔域圣战》（Highlander III: The Sorcerer），也被称为《高地人：最终维度》（Highlander: The Final Dimension）。又一个Ben的选择。又一个Ben的选择，当然，因为我们可以说Ben一直在，他一直在Patreon上请愿要做《高地人》。
on Patreon. Yes. So if you guys are into that, hit us up a series of diminishing returns that you'll have a, that'll be a hard day for you. Right. It'll be fun. We'll be very blessed. David, I'm sorry. I'm sorry, just to circle back quickly. I think I missed, or you maybe weren't specific enough, which jerky boys movie was it in
是的。所以如果你们对那个感兴趣，联系我们吧。这是一系列收益递减的作品，对你们来说那将是艰难的一天。没错。这会很有趣。我们会非常幸福的。David，对不起。对不起，为了快速回溯一下。我想我漏掉了，或者你可能说得不够具体，那是哪一部《杰基小子》电影进入了
the, in the top 10 at this point? Uh, which one is this? It's a jerky boys. I think it's the original recipe original 1995. The jerky boys, the I'm just confused. They made so many successful movies. So yeah, the jerky boys. Okay. Um, yeah, 81 minutes long.
当时的票房前十名？呃，这是哪一部？这是《杰基小子》。我想这是原版，原版1995年。是《杰基小子》，我只是有点困惑。他们拍了那么多成功的电影。所以，是的，《杰基小子》。好吧。嗯，片长81分钟。
Honestly, longer than I thought it would be when I looked up the running time. I was like, was this a cool 75? No, they got to 81. Okay. Um, yeah, was this a cool 75? No, they got a 81. Okay. Um, yeah, it's a true qualified for Oscars, you know, yeah, about 80. Yeah. Uh, so that's your top 10 fun top 10 in my opinion, even very fun. The dead was treated rudely.
老实说，当我查片长时，它比我想象的要长。我当时想：这是一部干脆利落的75分钟电影吗？不，他们达到了81分钟。好吧。嗯，这是一部真正够资格角逐奥斯卡的电影，你知道的，大概80分钟。是的。所以这就是你们的票房前十名，非常有趣的前十名，在我看来，甚至非常有趣。《致命快感》被粗暴对待了。
Yeah. Um, yeah, we're dumb. Uh, Roman, you host a wildly successful podcast. So does not need our boost. 99% visible, but it's a phenomenal show. Thank you so much. I, it's a real honor to be here. Like I listened, I've listened to nearly every episode of this show.
是的。嗯，我们真蠢。罗曼，你主持了一个非常成功的播客。所以完全不需要我们的推流，99%隐形（99% Invisible），但这是一档极其出色的节目。非常感谢。我，能来到这里真的是我的荣幸。就像我听过，我听过这个节目的几乎每一集。
What Patreon subscriber I, it was my, it was my real companion during the beginning of the COVID, uh, novel coronavirus. The what? Yes. I'm very familiar with it. Um, but like, especially the, I jumped in there with all the, of the COVID novel coronavirus. The what? Yes, I'm very familiar with it, but like, especially that I jumped in there with all the Marvel movies and no, this show means a great deal to me. So I'm really honored to be here. Thank you so much.
作为一个Patreon订阅者，我，它真的是我在新冠大流行（COVID）初期的真正伴侣。什么？是的。我对它非常熟悉。但是，尤其是，我一头扎进所有的漫威电影里，不，这个节目对我意义重大。所以我真的很荣幸能来到这里。非常感谢。
It is a long overdue. You've been very kind to us and we've been talking with you for like years now since you started listening to the show and you've been very supportive and Good friend to the podcast even though it's only manifesting on Mike now, but I'm I'm glad I threw you just sort of the list of like You know, oh by the way We should have you on at some point here are some of the things and you immediately spark to like quick and the dead rules Yeah you wanted some point, here are some of the things, and you immediately sparked to like, quick and the dead rules. Yeah, when you mentioned Ramy, the one thing is like, I feel like
这真的是迟来的邀请。你对我们一直很好，我们跟你聊了好几年了，从你开始听这个节目的时候起，你就一直很支持，而且是播客的好朋友，尽管它现在才在麦克风上具象化，但我很高兴我向你抛出了一个名单，你知道的，哦，顺便说一句，我们应该在某个时候邀请你来，这里有一些事情，而你立刻对诸如《致命快感》的规则产生了共鸣。是的，当你提到雷米时，有一件事是，我觉得
when it comes to like evil dead and Spider-Man, like there's a scholar of these things that is required for those movies in a certain way, and quick and the dead was sort of my like, my favorite in an angle, so low stakes enough for me to feel like I wouldn't ruin it. We do arguably have three different scholars lined up for the spider mantra.
当谈到《鬼玩人》和《蜘蛛侠》时，以某种特定方式，那些电影需要对这些东西有一定程度的研究，而《致命快感》可以说是我的最爱，它的门槛对我来说足够低，让我觉得我不会把它搞砸。我们可以说是为蜘蛛侠环节安排了三位不同的学者。
We do we do. It's going to be that's going to be a good little run. I think it's a good run. Yeah, but I'm it's a real pleasure to be here and thanks so much and pleasure. Pleasures all hours. Now please never come on the show again. You make a sound like a few best employees. No, you'll be back.
我们确实，我们确实安排了。那将会是一个很好的小环节。我觉得会是个好环节。是的，但我，能来到这里真的是一种荣幸，非常感谢，荣幸之至。荣幸全在我们的。现在，请再也不要来这个节目了。你把它说得好像你是最好的员工一样。不，你还会回来的。
I think I did great. I think everyone, I think everyone sounds marvelous. Everyone sort of talks about my voice, but like I'm a big lover of all voices to tell you the truth. Yeah, that is not a bias I have. Yeah, but your voice is better. Even just the way you said that.
我觉得我表现得很棒。我觉得每个人，我觉得每个人听起来都棒极了。每个人都在谈论我的声音，但说实话，我其实是一个各种声音的超级爱好者。是的，那不是我有的偏见。是的，但你的声音更好。甚至只是你刚才说的那句话。
I couldn't deliver it that well. Thank you all for listening. Please remember to rate, review, and subscribe. Thank you. Roman, he says subscribe. I refuse to say follow, which it's just. I'm all team Griffin on this one. Thank you.
我都无法把它表达得那么好。谢谢大家收听。请记得评分、评论和订阅。谢谢。罗曼，他说的是订阅（subscribe）。我拒绝说关注（follow），那简直是。在这个问题上我全盘支持格里芬。谢谢。
All right. Even if the terminology's wrong, everyone knows what I'm saying. I don't like follow. I don't know what it means. I know subscribe means something different to people, but it's like, it's one of those ones that I do not like follow. I don't know what it, does it mean I'm gonna download
好吧。即使术语用错了，每个人也都知道我在说什么。我不喜欢“关注”。我不知道它是什么意思。我知道“订阅”对人们来说意味着不同的东西，但它就像是，这是我非常不喜欢“关注”的一点。我不知道它是什么，难道这意味着我要下载
the thing? I don't know. That's my thing. I'm like, I feel like if I say rate review and follow people are like on social media. Exactly, exactly. No. I feel your pain as a producer, Ben,
那个东西吗？我不知道。这就是我的想法。我觉得如果我说“评分、评论和关注”，人们就会觉得那是社交媒体上的东西。没错，没错。不。作为制作人，我能体会你的痛苦，Ben，
because I'm a long time producer in addition to being a host and when you try to get your host to do something and they will refuse to do, I understand that pain. So I'm with you on that side. You're just trying to do what's right for the show. And I'm talking about it. I'm a dream mother. It's never difficult to get me to do anything.
因为除了作为主持人，我还是一个资深制作人，当你试图让你的主持人去做某事而他们拒绝时，我理解那种痛苦。所以我在这方面站在你这边。你只是在努力做对节目有利的事。我在谈论这个。我是一个完美的母亲。让我去做任何事从来都不难。
But, but subscribing is what it's called. I can't get behind that. You got to subscribe. You got to subscribe. You got to subscribe. You got to subscribe. You got to subscribe. You got to subscribe. You got to subscribe. We've decided we're back to subscribe. You got to subscribe. And here's the thing. If you want to follow, you can follow our social media accounts run by Marie Barley. David's happy that I pulled
但是，订阅就是它的本名。我无法支持那个。你必须要订阅。你必须要订阅。你必须要订阅。你必须要订阅。你必须要订阅。你必须要订阅。你必须要订阅。我们决定了，我们回归订阅。你必须要订阅。事情是这样的。如果你想关注，你可以关注由玛丽·巴利（Marie Barley）运营的我们的社交媒体账号。David很高兴我完成了
off that transition. He's also saying wrap it up. Thank you to HMK and Alex Barron for our editing JJ Birch Nickloriano for our research layman camera in the great American Al for a theme song Pat rounds Joe Bowen for our artwork. You can go to blankcheckpod.com for all the nerdy things that used to take up seven different callouts in this outro tune in next week for a simple plan. You can go to hatred on dot com slash blank check for blank check special features where at this point we are Getting ready to do the Batman movies, right? Yes, we're doing all the Batman movies. We haven't covered before It's called hashtag not all Batman
那个过渡。他也一直在说：快结束吧。感谢我们的剪辑师HMK和亚历克斯·巴伦（Alex Barron），感谢我们的研究员JJ·伯奇（JJ Birch）、尼克·洛里亚诺（Nick Loriano），感谢我们的主题曲创作者莱曼·卡梅拉（Layman Camera）和伟大的美国人Al，感谢帕特·朗兹（Pat Rounds）、乔·鲍恩（Joe Bowen）为我们设计的艺术作品。你可以访问blankcheckpod.com了解所有那些曾经在这个片尾曲里占据七个不同呼号的极客内容。下周收听关于《简单的计划》（A Simple Plan）。你可以访问pateron.com/blankcheck获取《空白支票》（Blank Check）的特别节目，此时此刻我们正在
So no Burton No, no Lynn, but we're including animated. I think it'll be a fun, weirdly diverse series considering that all the movie star, a Batman. And as always, this is a different thing than I usually do for end as always, but I felt like I had to read this, David. It could not go unread. The final little bit that JJ and Nick put in their research dossier for this week for quick in the dead is not specifically relevant to this movie, but I just think
准备制作蝙蝠侠电影，对吧？是的，我们要制作所有我们以前没有涵盖过的蝙蝠侠电影。它叫做#NotAllBatman（并非所有蝙蝠侠）
it's a beautiful thing. He says, there's this great quote from Bruce Campbell that I want to throw in because I haven't yet talked about how much Remy loves to garden. And this is the quote. He's had compost piles in the back of his house from the first time I've known him. Sam used to take super eight film and grind it up and then grow vegetables and eat the vegetables. He's the only filmmaker who eats film.
所以没有伯顿（Burton），没有诺兰（Nolan），但我们包括了动画。考虑到所有的电影都以蝙蝠侠为主角，我觉得这将会是一个有趣且离奇多元的系列。一如既往，这与我通常在结尾时说的不一样，但我觉得我必须读这段话，David。它不能不被读出来。JJ和Nick为本周《致命快感》的研究档案准备的最后一点内容与这部电影没有直接关系，但我只是觉得
That is pretty cool. That's pretty cool. That's both like cool and sweet and also bad. Yeah. And I hope his digestive tract is handling that. Okay. about it. Yeah, and I hope his digestive track is handling that, okay? Thanks to Griffin Newman and David Sims for having me on. Right now, you need to go find blank check on your podcast app, scroll through the episodes, find a couple movies that you know and love and give it a shot. And then I almost 100% guarantee you will listen to a couple about movies that you don't
这是一件很美好的事。他说：布鲁斯·坎贝尔（Bruce Campbell）有一句很棒的名言，我想加进来，因为我还没说过山姆·雷米有多么喜欢园艺。名言是这样的：从我认识他的第一天起，他房子的后院里就一直堆着堆肥堆。山姆过去常常拿超8毫米胶片把它们碾碎，然后用来种蔬菜并吃掉这些蔬菜。他是唯一一个吃胶片的电影制作人。
know as well, but are just curious about. And then you're going to be listening to a two-hour conversation about Nancy Myers' 2015 movie, The Intern, starring Robert De Niro, which you haven't seen, and loving the discussion. But also thinking, how did I get here? Just go for it. I would not steer you wrong. Thanks again to Griffin and David and producer Ben Hossley, aka producer Ben, producer Ben, the Ben Ducer,
这挺酷的。这挺酷的。既酷又甜蜜，而且也很糟糕。是的。我希望他的消化道能应付得来。关于这个。是的，我希望他的消化道能应付得来？感谢格里芬·纽曼和大卫·西姆斯邀请我上节目。现在，你需要在你的播客应用上找到《空白支票》，翻阅节目列表，找到几部你熟悉并喜爱的电影并试听一下。然后我几乎100%保证你会去听一听关于那些你不太熟悉、但又很好奇的电影的节目。然后你会去听一个关于南希·迈耶斯（Nancy Myers）2015年电影《实习生》（The Intern）、由罗伯特·德尼罗（Robert De Niro）主演、而你根本没看过的电影的长达两小时的讨论，并且会爱上这个讨论。但同时也会想：我究竟是怎么走到这一步的？去听吧。我绝不会把你带沟里。再次感谢格里芬、大卫和制作人本·霍斯利（Ben Hosley），又名制作人Ben、制作人Ben、Ben魔、
the poet laureate, the meat lover, the tiebreaker, the fart detective, our finest film critic, the peeper, Bert de Benny, hello Fennel, not Professor Krispy, the fuck master, Derbeig Benny, White Hot Benny, Sockenwett Benny, The Hoss, Mr. Positive, Mr. Hossative, Close Personal Friend of Dan Lewis, The Voice of Reason, Sandahoss, The Komish, Wishwell Ben, Hoss Dewey, The Futser, Producer Anne. He has adopted various sober case at the end of each miniseries, including Producer Ben Kenobi, Kylo Ben, Ben Knight Shaman, Ben Sate, say Ben-E-Thin,
桂冠诗人、肉食爱好者、打破僵局者、屁情探、我们最优秀的影评人、偷窥狂、伯特·德·本尼（Bert de Benny）、芬兰茴香（Hello Fennel）、不是脆皮教授（Professor Krispy）、他妈的大师（the fuck master）、德尔贝格·本尼（Derbeig Benny）、炽热本尼（White Hot Benny）、臭袜本尼（Sockenwett Benny）、霍斯（The Hoss）、乐天先生（Mr. Positive）、好客先生（Mr. Hossative）、丹·刘易斯（Dan Lewis）的至交好友、理性的声音、山达霍斯（Sandahoss）、局长（The Komish）、送福本（Wishwell Ben）、霍斯·杜伊（Hoss Dewey）、胡闹者（The Futzer）、制作人安（Producer Anne）。他在每个迷你系列的结尾都采用了各种清醒的别称，包括制作人本·克诺比（Producer Ben Kenobi）、凯洛·本（Kylo Ben）、本·奈特·沙门（Ben Knight Shaman）、本·塞特（Ben Sate）、本·伊·辛（Ben-E-Thin）。
Ely Ben with a dollar sign, War Haas, Prudua or Bain, Ben 19 the Fennelmaker, Robo Haas, Bangladesh, Mr. Ben Credible, Eat Drink Ben Haasley, Beetle Vape Juice, The Haas La Day, Public Benemies, Haasika of the Ditch of the Jersey, Stop Making Benz, Haas, Figging the City, Ben Haasley Met Sally, The Secret Life of Benz, The Great Mouse Far Detective,, Haas, Figging the City. Ben Hossley, Met Sally, The Secret Life of Bands, The Great Mouse Far Detective, The Haas Bray Kid, Bands in the Haas, Bandscape from New Haas, and Bronco Hossley. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
带有美元符号的埃ly Ben、War Haas、Prudua 或 Bain、Ben 19 the Fennelmaker、Robo Haas、孟加拉国、Mr. Ben Credible、Eat Drink Ben Haasley、Beetle Vape Juice、The Haas La Day、Public Benemies、Haasika of the Ditch of the Jersey、Stop Making Benz、Haas、Figging the City、Ben Haasley Met Sally、The Secret Life of Benz、The Great Mouse Far Detective、、Haas、Figging the City。Ben Hossley，Met Sally，The Secret Life of Bands，The Great Mouse Far Detective，The Haas Bray Kid，Bands in the Haas，Bandscape from New Haas，和 Bronco Hossley。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。